COMMITTEE ON PANDEMIC EMERGING
RESPONSE AND THE SENATE
EDUCATION COMMITTEE JOINT
HEARING WILL NOW COME TO ORDER.
GOOD MORNING EVERYONE IN
RESPONSE TO THE COVERT NINETEEN
EMERGENCY AND TO PROTECT THE
PUBLIC LEGISLATORS EMPLOYEES WE
MUST LIMIT NONESSENTIAL
GATHERINGS AND HERE'S SOCIAL
DISTANCING IT FACE COVERING
GUIDELINES IN COMPLIANCE WITH
THOSE GUIDELINES THE STATE
SENATE HAS MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL
PRACTICES. IN ORDER TO ENSURE
THAT THE PUBLIC CONTINUES TO
EXPECT TO HAVE ACCESS TO THE
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS WE'RE
HOLDING TODAY'S INFORMATION
HEARING HERE IN THE CAPITAL IN
THE SENATE CHAMBER. IN THE
CHAMBER WITH ME THIS MORNING
ARE THE CULTURE OF TODAY'S
HEARING SENATOR CONNIE LEYVA-
AS WELL AS SENATORS PATRICIA
BATES- DAVE CORTESE BRIAN DOLLY
STEVE GLAZER LENA GONZALEZ MIKE
MCGUIRE ROSALIE A SHOW ABOUT.
THAT RICHARD ROTH AND SANDRA
RICHARD TAN THE PNEL SPEAKERS
WITH US TODAY ARE PARTICIPATING
REMOTELY CENTER LAVINE I WILL
INTRODUCE THEM BRIEFLY AT THE
BEGINNING OF EACH OF THE THREE
PANELS AS PART OF TODAY'S
COMMITTEE HEARING. FOR A REMOTE
PARTICIPANTS PLEASE MUTE YOUR
PHONES OR COMPUTERS THIS WILL
GREATLY AID IN ELIMINATING ANY
ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK WE ALSO ASK
THAT EVERY TIME YOU WISH TO BE
RECOGNIZED THAT YOU USE THE
RAISE YOUR HAND FEATURE IN THE
SOON PROGRAM EACH TEAM EACH
TIME YOU'RE RECOGNIZED TO
SPEAK. A POP UP WINDOW WILL
APPEAR ASKING IF YOU WOULD LIKE
TO ON MUTE PLEASE SELECT ON
MUTE BEFORE YOU BEGIN SPEAKING
ONCE YOU RECOGNIZE TO SPEAK
PLEASE MAKE SURE YOU CAN BE
SEEN ON THE SCREEN STATE YOUR
NAME CLEARLY AND THEN YOU ARE
READY TO ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE-
I. T. R. I. T. PERSONNEL WILL
PLACE YOU BACK ON MUTE. THAT
WHEN YOU'RE DONE WITH YOUR
TESTIMONY TO ENSURE PUBLIC
ACCESS TO THAT FOR TODAY'S
HEARING WE HAVE ADMITTED
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC TO TWO
HEARING ROOMS TO THE EXTENT
THAT SOCIAL DISTANCING
REQUIREMENTS ALLOW THAT AS WELL
AS TO THE SENATE GALLERY. WE'LL
ALSO BE USING A TELECONFERENCE
SERVICE FOR MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC WHO WISH TO TESTIFY
TODAY FOR ALL INDIVIDUALS
WISHING TO PROVIDE PUBLIC
COMMENT THE PARTICIPANT TOLL
FREE NUMBER AT CISCO- POSTED ON
OUR COMMITTEE WEBSITE IT WILL
JUST BE DISPLAYED ON THE SCREEN
AS IT IS IN THE HOUSE NOW.
TODAY'S PARTICIPANT. NUMBER IS
EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN THREE THREE
SIX. FOUR FOUR SEVEN. FIVE THAT
IS H. SEVEN THREE THREE SIX
FOUR FOUR THREE SEVEN AND THE
ACCESS CODE IS EIGHT TWO SIX.
EIGHT FOUR TWO EIGHT AGAIN THE
EIGHT FOUR TWO EIGHT FOR
DETAILED INSTRUCTIONS. ON HOW
THE TELECONFERENCE SYSTEM WORKS
PLEASE REFER TO THE SENATE AND-
COMMITTEE WEBSITES. AFTER WE'VE
HEARD FROM ALL THE PANELISTS
FOR TODAY'S AGENDA WE WILL HAVE
A PUBLIC COMMENT PERIOD FOR
THOSE. WHO WISH TO COMMENT ON
THE TOPICS COVERED THIS
INFORMATION COMMITTEE HEARINGS.
HEARING IS SCHEDULED TO END. AT
TWELVE NOON TODAY SO OUR
ABILITY TO TAKE PUBLIC COMMENT.
MAY BE LIMITED BY THAT TIME
CONSTRAINTS. SHOULD ANY EFFORT
TO ACCOMMODATE AS MANY MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC AS SWITCHING JUST
TO COME IN AS POSSIBLE. PUBLIC
COMMENT TODAY WILL BE LIMITED
TO ONE MINUTE PER SPEAKER THAT
TIME LIMIT. WILL BE STRICTLY
ENFORCED TO ENSURE THAT WE- GET
AS MANY SPEAKERS AS POSSIBLE.
FOR THE PUBLIC PLEASE NOTE THAT
IN ORDER FOR US TO HEAR YOU
CLEARLY. INTO AVOID ACOUSTIC
FEEDBACK AGAIN YOU MUST MEET
THE DEVICE IN WHICH YOU ARE
WATCHING. THE HEARING PRIOR TO
GIVING YOUR TESTIMONY OVER THE
PHONE IT IS IMPORTANT THAT WE
HEAR FROM YOU. AND WE THANK YOU
FOR YOUR PATIENCE. MY CO CHAIR
SENATOR LEVIN I WILL MAINTAIN
DECORUM DURING THE HEARING AS
IS CUSTOMARY. AND WHILE WE
DON'T ANTICIPATE THIS WILL BE
AN ISSUE. ANY INDIVIDUAL WHO IS
DISRUPTIVE MAY BE REMOVED FROM
THE ROAD FROM THE REMOTE
MEETING SERVICE OR HAVE THEIR
CONNECTIONS MUTED. WHILE EVERY
EFFORT HAS BEEN MADE TO
STREAMLINE HEARING PROCESSING
CONDUCTOR HEARINGS AND IT'S
CLOSE TO THE SAME MANNER. AS IS
CUSTOMARY THERE MAY BE SOME LAG
TIME FOR PARTICIPANTS WERE
ADJUSTING. TO THE USE OF ONLINE
TOOLS OR TECHNOLOGIES PLEASE BE
RESPECTFUL AND PATIENT. SO.
THAT ALL INTERESTED PARTIES CAN
BE HER. LET ME BEGIN THE
HEARING NOW. IN THE AFTERMATH
pOUR KIDS SPEND AWAY FROM SCHOOL
CAMPUSES OFTEN IN ISOLATION
OFTEN UNDER GREAT STRAIN.
TODAY'S HEARING WILL ENDEAVOR
TO EXAMINE THE IMPACTS OF CODE
NINETEEN ON STUDENT WELLBEING.
AS STUDENTS RETURN TO SCHOOL
AMIDST. UNSETTLING TIMES AND AS
THE DELTA VARIANT CONTINUES TO
LOOM. WILL EXPLORE WAYS TO
MINIMIZE ANY FURTHER ACADEMIC
OR SOCIAL LOSSES FOR OUR
STUDENTS. AND LEARN ABOUT HOW
THE STATE AND OUR PARTNERS ARE
HELPING SCHOOLS PRIORITIZE
STUDENTS SOCIAL AND EMOTIONAL
NEEDS. TO RETURN BOOSTED THEIR
ACADEMIC PERFORMANCE. AS WE'RE
ALL AWARE DURING THE TWENTY
TWENTY ONE SCHOOL YEAR- MOST
STUDENTS HAD BY TWENTY TWENTY
TO TWENTY TWENTY ONE SCHOOL
YEAR THE PAST TWO YEARS. MOST
UNITS HAD RELATIVELY LITTLE IN
PERSON INTERACTION WITH THEIR
TEACHERS. OR WITH ONE ANOTHER
AND NOW AS THEY RETURN IN
PERSON TO CLASSROOMS IT SHOULD
COME AS NO SURPRISE THAT MANY
OF THEM MAY BE RETURNING
DIFFERENT. THAN WHEN THEY LEFT
NOT IN MANY CASES MORE
RESERVED. IN MANY CASES MUCH
MORE ANXIOUS WHILE OTHERS HAVE
BEEN COMPLETELY LOST. TO THE
CHALLENGES OF REMOTE LEARNING
DURING THAT TIME. HOPEFULLY
SCHOOLS HAVE BEEN ABLE TO SEIZE
OPPORTUNITIES OVER THE SUMMER
FOR STUDENTS TO ENGAGE WITH
EACH OTHER AND RECONNECT WITH
OTHERS. AS MUCH AS POSSIBLE.
WITH APPROPRIATE DISEASE
MITIGATION STRATEGIES LIKE MASK
WEARING FREQUENT HAND
SANITIZING AND SOCIAL
DISTANCING IN PLACE. THIS
SUMMER AN EXTENDED LEARNING
PROGRAMS WE HEAR ABOUT TODAY OR
INTENDED TO SET A FOUNDATION
FOR HELPING OUR STUDENTS
TEACHERS. AND OTHER SCHOOL
PERSONNEL REESTABLISHED THE
CONNECTIONS. WITH ONE ANOTHER
AS WE CONTINUE TO EMERGE. FROM
THIS PANDEMIC AND BEYOND.
WHATEVER MODEL INSTRUCTION
STUDENTS ENCOUNTER THIS FALL
THERE WILL BE ONE CONSTANT
SOCIAL EMOTIONAL LEARNING NEEDS
WILL BE HIGHER. THAN EVER
BEFORE WE URGE THE EDUCATION
COMMUNITY. IN THEIR EFFORTS TO
KEEP STUDENTS PHYSICALLY SAFE.
TO ACKNOWLEDGE THEIR STRUGGLES
AND PRIORITIZE THEIR WELL BEING
IT IS. MORE URGENT NOW. THAN
EVER. HAVING DOUBTS. SOME OF
WHAT TODAY'S HEARING WILL BE
ABOUT I THINK IT'S ACTUALLY
ALSO IMPORTANT TO STATE CLEARLY
WHAT TODAY'S HEARING IS NOT
ABOUT TODAY'S HEARING IS NOT
ABOUT MASKING. AT LEAST NOT
ABOUT PROSPECTIVE PLANS OR
POLICIES THAT MAY ULTIMATELY
ULTIMATELY PUT IN PEOPLE BEING
PUT. IN PLACE STATEWIDE. WORN
ANY PARTICULAR SCHOOL DISTRICT
NEITHER IS TODAY'S DISCUSSION
ABOUT VACCINATIONS THESE ARE
OBVIOUSLY IMPORTANT ISSUES. AND
SUBJECT TO INTENSELY HELD VIEWS
WHAT IS THE GOAL OF TODAY'S
HEARING IS TO TALK ABOUT
APPROACHES TO. AND LESSONS
LEARNED ABOUT TEACHING AND
LEARNING IN THE WAKE OF THE
PANDEMIC. WE WILL BE D. B.
DELIBERATELY BE LEAVING
DISCUSSIONS ABOUT THESE OTHER
OBVIOUSLY CONTENTIOUS TOPICS
FOR OTHER VENUES I RESPECTFULLY
ASK THAT YOU PLEASE KEEP THAT
IN MIND. AS YOU CONSIDERING
OFFERING PUBLIC COMMENT. THAT
WITH ALL THAT IS BACK IN A
CONTEXT IS NOW MY PLEASURE TO
WELCOME MY CULTURE AND
COLLEAGUE SENATOR LEYVA WHO
CHAIRS THE SENATE COMMITTEE ON
EDUCATION CENTER LABOR WOULD BE
GLAD TO HEAR YOUR THOUGHTS- AND
PERSPECTIVE AS WE KICK OFF THE
HEARING AND PREPARE FOR
INTRODUCTIONS OVER OPENING
PANEL. THANK YOU SENATOR NEWMAN
GOOD MORNING EVERYONE I AM SO
PLEASED TO BE A PART OF THIS
HEARING. WE ALL SHARE A DEEP
CONCERN FOR THE MENTAL HEALTH
AND WELL BEING OF OUR STUDENTS
AND STAFF. WE KNOW THAT
STUDENTS AND FAMIIES ARE
SUFFERING AND NEED OUR HELP.
THIS PAST YEAR AND A HALF HAS
PROFOUNDLY IMPACTED OUR
STUDENTS. BOTH ACADEMICALLY AND
EMOTIONALLY. THIS PAST THIS
HEARING PROVIDES AN OPPORTUNITY
FOR US TO HEAR ABOUT SOME OF
THE INCREDIBLE WORK. BEING DONE
IN OUR SCHOOLS AND OUR
COMMUNITIES THIS HEARING WILL
FOCUS ON K. THROUGH TWELVE
STUDENTS. WILL NOT BE ABLE TO
COVER THESE ISSUES AS THEY
RELATE TO EARLY EDUCATION OR
HIGHER EDUCATION. MANY STUDENTS
AND FAMILIES SUFFER FROM
CONTINUED TRAUMA WHETHER IT IS
FROM THE PANDEMIC. WILDFIRES OR
OTHER ADVERSE CHILDHOOD
EXPERIENCES. WE KNOW THERE'S
INCREDIBLE WORK HAPPENING
ACROSS THE STATE THAT HAS HELP
MINIMIZE SOME OF THESE IMPACTS.
WILL NOT BE ABLE TO HIGHLIGHT
ALL OF THE CREATIVE INNOVATIONS
TO SUPPORT STUDENTS AND THEIR
FAMILIES WE CAN ENCOURAGE.
THESE CONTINUED APPROACHES.
THANK YOU TO ALL OF OUR
WITNESSES THANK YOU FOR TAKING
YOUR TIME TO BE WITH US TODAY.
I REALLY LOOK FORWARD. TO
HEARING YOUR TESTIMONY. DO WE
HAVE ANY OTHER SENATORS ON
EITHER COMMITTEE WOULD LIKE
MAKE ANY COMMENTS. SENATOR OCHO
BUG. GOOD MORNING THANK YOU FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK. IN
LIGHT OF. THANK IN LIGHT OF
EVERYTHING THAT IS HAPPENING
RIGHT NOW IN OUR COMMUNITIES WE
NEED TO SUPPORT CALIFORNIA'S
CHILDREN AND GET THEM BACK IN
THE CLASSROOM HOWEVER THE
DISCUSSIONS LIKE THOSE HERE
TODAY MUST BE PRODUCTIVE AND
RESPECTFUL CONVERSATIONS THAT
IS WHY THAT IS THE ONLY WAY TO
DEVELOP POLICY THEY WILL BE
EFFECTIVE AND REASONABLE FOR
STUDENTS. THANK YOU TO ALL THE
PRESENTERS THIS MORNING AND FOR
ALL THOSE LEADING THESE TYPES
OF DISCUSSIONS IN OUR DISTRICT
MY HEART IS BROKEN FOR STUDENTS
OVER THE PAST SEVENTEEN MONTHS
I'VE HEARD NUMEROUS STORIES
ABOUT STUDENTS WHO USED TO LOVE
SCHOOL WHO HAVE COME TO HATED
IN THE VIRTUAL ENVIRONMENT
STUDENTS WHO THRIVED UNDER
NORMAL CIRCUMSTANCES DID POORLY
IN VIRTUAL SUBMISSIONS I'VE
SAID IT BEFORE AND I'LL SAY IT
AGAIN HE'S JUST GOT DECISIONS
SHOULD ALSO BE LEFT TO THE
LOCALS WHO CAN BEST MAKE THOSE
DECISIONS FOR THEIR STUDENTS.
THEY ARE EXPERTS IN COMPLETELY
CAPABLE OF DECIDING WHAT THEIR
COMMUNITIES NEED AND THEY HAVE
DIRECT CONDUITS TO GETTING THE
PERSPECTIVE OF THE TEACHERS
STAFF PARENTS AND STUDENTS.
HOWEVER WE NEED TO ALSO HAVE
CONVERSATIONS ABOUT HOW TO
PROTECT SCHOOL DISTRICT FROM
LIABILITY. IN ORDER TO HAVE THE
CAPACITY TO DEVELOP POLICY THAT
IS BALANCED CONDUCIVE TO THE
WELL BEING OF CHILDREN AND NOT
BASED ON FEAR. AGAIN I'M
THANKFUL THAT WE HAVE SO MANY
OFFICIALS FROM ACROSS THE STATE
HERE TODAY BUT WE NEED TO TAKE
ACTIONS IN OUR COMMUNITIES NOW.
THE SCHOOL YEAR HAS ALREADY
STARTED FOR MANY AND IF WE
PROLONG THIS CONVERSATION ANY
LONGER IF YOU'RE WE'RE GOING TO
LOSE A GENERATION THANK YOU.
BIG CENTER OF CHUBB OKAY ANY
OTHER MEMBERS WHO WISH TO MAKE
ANY COMMENTS. ALL RIGHT SEEING
THEN I WOULD LIKE TO INTRODUCE
THE FIRST PANEL WE WILL BE
HEARING FROM DAVE GORDEN. WHO'S
A COMMISSIONER WITH THE MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES OVERSIGHT
INCOME ACCOUNTABILITY
COMMISSION. ALSO WILL BE
HEARING FROM OUR OWN STATE
SUPERINTENDENT OF PUBLIC
INSTRUCTION TONY THURMAN. MR
MATSON OF OUR NOVEL THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF HE
CALIFORNIA COLLABORATIVE FOR
EDUCATIONAL EXCELLENCE. MR
GORDON PLEASE BEGIN. GOOD
MORNING SENATORS AND THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR HAVING ME IT'S MY
HONOR TO SPEAK HERE TODAY GOOD
MORNING DAVE GORDON. AS WAS
MENTIONED I'M A COMMISSIONER
WITH THE MENTAL HEALTH.
SERVICES OVERSIGHT AND
ACCOUNTABILITY COMMISSION AND I
ALSO SERVES THE SACRAMENTO
COUNTY SUPERINTENDENT OF
SCHOOLS. SUPPORTING THIRTEEN
SCHOOL DISTRICTS AND TWO
HUNDRED FORTY THOUSAND STUDENTS
IN ORDER TO HELP THE- I'M ALSO
A PROUD GRANDPA THE. THE GIRL
WHO SPENT THE- SENIOR YEAR OF
HIGH SCHOOL. IN FRONT OF THE
ZOOM SCREEN AND- I'VE I'VE I'VE
WATCHED WHAT HAPPENED TO HER IN
THIS PERIOD SO I WANT TO BEGIN
BY THANKING OUR STATE LEADERS.
GOVERNOR NEWSOM IN THE
LEGISLATURE FOR PROVIDING AN
EXTRAORDINARY INVESTMENT OF
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS IN FUNDING
TO SUPPORT SCHOOL MENTAL HEALTH
BY BRINGING OUR SCHOOL AND
MENTAL HEALTH SYSTEMS CLOSER
TOGETHER AND HOPEFULLY TO
FUNCTION MUCH MORE AS ONE
SYSTEM. I WANT TO EXPRESS
THANKS TO SUPERINTENDENT TONY
BURMAN THE CD IN OUR STATE
BORDER OF EDUCATION FOR
STEPPING UP WITH LEADERSHIP FOR
DISTRICTS BUT MOST OF ALL
HAVING GONE AROUND TO OUR
SCHOOL DISTRICTS THROUGHOUT THE
SUMMER IN THE LAST SEVERAL
WEEKS. I WANT TO THANK ALL OF
OUR TEACHERS COUNSELORS
CLINICIANS AND OTHER SCHOOL
EMPLOYEES AND LEADERS WHO HAVE
REALLY STEPPED UP TO EMBRACE
THEMSELVES THEIR STAFFS AND OUR
YOUNG PEOPLE PARTICULARLY
DURING THIS EXTRAORDINARILY
DIFFICULT PERIOD YOUR WORK I
CAN TELL YOU. IT'S BEEN A
ROLLER CAN LIKE CHANGING IT UP
INCLUDED IN MY PREPARED REMARKS
SOME EXAMPLES SOME OF THE
THINGS THAT HAVE BEEN GOING ON
IN MY OWN COUNTY. I'M ALSO
PROUD TO HIGHLIGHT SOME OF THE
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES
OVERSIGHT AND ACCOUNTABILITY
COMMISSION INITIATIVES AND THE
COMMISSION IS LED BY CHAIRMAN
ASPECT VICE CHAIR TOMORROW MY
WIFE. AND OUR. EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR TOLD THE US. AND LATE
LAST YEAR THE COMMISSION
PRODUCED A REPORT ON SO IN
MENTAL WE ARE MEANT TO YOU
CALL. EVERY YOUR HEART AND MIND
SCHOOLS AS CENTRES OF WELLNESS.
THEN THE REPORT LAID OUT A
BLUEPRINT FOR MAKING SCHOOLS
CENTERS OF WELLNESS FOCUSING.
ON NOT JUST TREATMENT BUT ALSO
ON PREVENTION. ALSO THROUGH THE
SNAPPLE HELP STUDENTS SERVICES
ACT FUNDING PROVIDED IN THE
STATE BUDGET. THIS WILL ALLOW
THE COMMISSION TO GO BEYOND THE
EXISTING EIGHTEEN LOCAL COUNTY
SCHOOL PARTNERSHIPS THE FUND
NOT JUST A FEW BUT EVERY
COUNTY. IN SUPPORTING ROBUST
COUNTY SCHOOL MENTAL HEALTH
PARTNERSHIPS WHICH IS WHERE
MUCH OF THE REAL WORK IS
PERFORMED. IN TERMS OF YOUR
VOICE AND YOU CAN GAUGE AND AS
ADULTS WE OFTEN ASSUME WE KNOW
WHAT'S BEST FOR CHILDREN YOUR
BEST BET I'M NOT LEANING MORE.
ON OUR YOUNG PEOPLE TO HELP US
UNDERSTAND THEIR NEEDS. OR
COMMISSION I'M PROUD TO SAY IS
LET'S WAIT TWO WORDS THE STATE
TO EXPAND OPPORTUNITIES TO
ENHANCE. THE VOICE OF YOUTH AND
STUDENTS. PRIOR TO THE PANDEMIC
THE COMMISSION SPONSORED THE
YOUTH ENGAGEMENT PROJECT. THAT
CREATED USE IDEAL LAUGHS AND
ARE YOU SO I CAN TELL YOU ARE
COMING UPS WITH SOME AMAZING
IDEAS WE NEED TO LISTEN TO THEM
MORE. WHEN ASKED WHAT TYPES OF
INTERVENTIONS OR SERVICES CAN
BE MOST HELPFUL YOUNG PEOPLE
SPOKE SPECIFICALLY ABOUT WAYS
TO EMPOWER THEM TO SHARE THEIR
OWN VOICES AND PERSPECTIVES.
THAT SHAPE OUR DECISIONS I WANT
TO RECOGNIZE THAT WE DON'T HAVE
ALL THE ANSWERS ABOUT HOW WE
CAN BEST SUPPORT OUR STUDENTS.
BUT WE DO KNOW THAT GETTING
THOSE ANSWERS NEEDS TO INCLUDE
ENGAGING YOUNG PEOPLE. IN THE
PROCESS. LOCALLY IN SACRAMENTO
COUNTY WERE SPONSORING AN
INITIATIE TO PLACE MENTAL
HEALTH CLINICIANS IN EVERY
SCHOOL THAT WOULD BE THREE
HUNDRED OR MORE SCHOOLS. MONTEL
HEALTH CLINICIAN THAT EVERY ONE
OF THOSE SCHOOLS IN THE COUNTY.
WE HAVE A PHASED ROLLOUT WE'RE
UP TO ABOUT TWENTY SCHOOLS WITH
THE GOAL OF REACHING MORE THAN
THREE HUNDRED. THE NATION'S
WORKING IN EACH SCHOOL ARE OUR
EMPLOYEES SUPPORTED BY
SUSTAINABLE FUNDING. FROM
MEDICARE HELLO I CAN'T
EMPHASIZE THE IMPORTANCE OF THE
SUSTAINABILITY OF FUNDING.
WE'RE ALSO SUPPORTING A
STATEWIDE COMMUNITY OF PRACTICE
WHICH WAS INITIALLY FUNDED BY
FEMA. THE N. B. IS GOING TO BE
CONTINUED FUNDING THROUGH
SEPTEMBER SOME OF THE STATE'S
MONEY AND THAT PROVIDES A FORUM
FOR HELPING US BUILD A
COMMUNITY OF FIRST RESPONDERS
AND IT HAS BEEN VERY WELL
RECEIVED- THROUGHOUT THE-
PROPERTY OF THE LAST COUPLE OF
MONTHS. SO IN CONCLUSION WE NOW
UNDERSTAND CLEARLY BUT AS YOUNG
PEOPLE COME BACK TO SCHOOL
FIRST AND FOREMOST THEY WILL
NEED A SAFE SUPPORTIVE SPACE
AND STRONG RELATIONSHIPS WITH
CARING ADULTS. THIS WILL TAKE
MORE TIME WITH SOME STUDENTS
SOME WITH OTHERS. BUT IS THAT
IT IS NECESSARY PATHWAY TO
ADDRESSING THEIR ACT NEEDS.
RESEARCH INDICATES THAT THE
MENTAL HEALTH IMPACTS OF THE
PANDEMIC WILL NOT GO AWAY WHEN
WE ARE BROUGHT DOWN
INSTRUCTIONS RATES. LESSONS
FROM OTHER LARGE SCALE
DISASTERS SUCH AS KATRINA WHEN
THE DEEPWATER HORIZON OIL.
SUGGESTED FEAR ANXIETY AND
RELATED MENTAL HEALTH NEEDS
WILL IMPACT STUDENTS FOR THREE
TO FIVE YEARS FOLLOWING THIS
PANDEMIC IF NOT LONGER. AND IT
IS SAID THAT OUT OF CRISIS
COMES OPPORTUNITY AND THAT IS
SO TRUE TODAY AND IN THE CASE
OF WHAT WE'RE WORKING ON. TODAY
WE'REFINALLY ON OUR WAY
TOWARDS BUILDING A STRONG
PARTNERSHIPS BETWEEN HEALTH AND
EDUCATION SYSTEMS. TO SUSTAIN
AND SUPPORT NOT JUST MENTAL
HEALTH. OVERALL HEALTH AND
PREVENTION SERVICES FOR ALL OUR
YOUNG PEOPLE AND THEIR FAMILIES
IT IS SO ENCOURAGING LEADERSHIP
THE OWNER STATE SUPERINTENDENT
AND ALL OTHER LEADERS HAVE
TAKEN THIS INITIATIVE. LET'S
NOT WASTE IT LET'S NOT. LET'S
NOT SQUANDER THE OPPORTUNITY
INSTEAD LET'S SEIZE THE
OPPORTUNITY THE PANDEMIC IS
PRESENTED US WITH AND GET THIS
WORKED OUT THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU SO MUCH MISTER GORDON
INSIGHTS MEMBERS WE'RE GOING TO
COMPLETE THE PANEL AND THEN I
WILL ASK FOR ANY QUESTIONS FROM
ALL OF YOU NEXT WE'RE GOING TO%
GO TO OUR STATE SUPERINTENDENT
OF PUBLIC INSTRUCTION TONY
THURMAN. SUPERINTENDENT ARE YOU
WITH US. YES HI THANK YOU
SENATOR LEYVA. CENTER IN NEW
ENGLAND- CENTERS- ACTUAL BOGAN
ANY OTHERS OF US WHO ARE
PARTICIPATING- TONY THURMAN
STATE SUPERINTENDENT OF PUBLIC
INSTRUCTION IN CALIFORNIA. IN
ORDER TO BE ON THIS PANEL
SUPERINTENDENT GORDON AND WITH
MANY NAVAJOS HEADING UP OUR OUR
GREAT- WAY OF A NEW ISSUE FOR
CLOSING- OPPORTUNITY GAPS IN.
PEOPLE LIKE ALEX BRISCOE AND
OTHERS WHO'VE BEEN WORKING ON
MENTAL HEALTH. WHAT ARE SCHOOLS
FOR A LONG TIME- IT YOU KNOW I
DON'T NEED TO UNDER ITS UNDER I
CAN'T STATE ENOUGH HOW
DIFFICULT THESE LAST EIGHTEEN.
MONTHS HAVE BEEN FOR EVERYONE I
DO BELIEVE THAT THIS IS ONE OF
THE TOUGHEST EXPERIENCES THAT.
WE WILL ALL UNDERGO IN OUR
LIFETIME. YOU KNOW LIKE TO JUST
START BY ACKNOWLEDGING OUR
STUDENTS AND THEIR FAMILIES AND
THANK THEM FOR THEIR INCREDIBLE
RESILIENCE- AS DIFFICULT AS
THIS TRAUMA HAS BEEN. OUR
STUDENTS ARE RESILIENT- THEY
WILL CONTINUE TO LEARN AND THEY
WILL CONTINUE TO THRIVE. BUT
THE TOPIC THAT YOU HAVE RAISED
IS A CRITICAL ONE. WE MUST
ADDRESS THEIR SOCIAL EMOTIONAL
LEARNING NEEDS AND WE MUST MAKE
SURE THAT THEY HAVE. THE RIGHT
SUPPORTS TO BE ABLE TO OVERCOME
THE TRAUMA WE'LL MUST ALSOPROVIDE THAT SUPPORT FOR ALL OF
OUR EDUCATORS ARE AND I WANT TO
THANK OUR CLASSIFIED AS A
DUPLICATED STAFF AND OUR
ADMINISTRATORS. FOR DOING THIS
VERY DIFFICULT WORK FOR WHICH
THERE IS NO PLAYBOOK. FOR HOW
TO NAVIGATE A PANDEMIC. AND
IT'S JUST BEEN AS DIFFICULT AS
YOU CAN IMAGINE AND- YOU KNOW I
DON'T HAVE TO TELL YOU. BUT
PUTTING IT IN CONTEXT
RECOGNIZING THAT OUR STUDENTS
AND FAMILIES THAT LOST LOVED
ONES. PEOPLE HAVE LOST JOBS.
HOMES IN THE DURING THE
PANDEMIC AT THE HEIGHT OF THE
PANDEMIC OUR SCHOOLS ARE
PROVIDED. FIVE HUNDRED MILLION
MEALS TO HUNGRY CHILDREN- THIS
IS AGAIN THE MOST DIFFICULT
CHALLENGE THAT WE WILL
EXPERIENCE. IN OUR LIFETIME
DURING THE PANDEMIC OUR OFFICE
HAS WORKED WITH DISTRICTS AND
COUNTY SUPERINTENDENTS PROVIDE
NEW RESOURCES NEW CREDIT
ACCOUNTS IN COALITION BECAUSE
WHEN I FIRST STARTED OUR
STUDENTS COULDN'T GET ACCESS TO
COUNSELORS. EVEN BECAUSE OF THE
LACK OF DIGITAL TECHNOLOGY THE
LACK OF DEVICES TO CONNECT. WE
KNOW THAT OUR STUDENTS
EXPERIENCE HIGH LEVELS OF
STRESS AND DEPRESSION- IT AND
THEN INCREASE RATES AND SUICIDE
AS A PANDEMIC GOT UNDERWAY. AND.
WE KNOW THAT OUR STUDENTS WILL
EXPERIENCE SOME JUST. AS THEY
COME BACK TO SCHOOL AND SO WE
CREATED THE AND COALITION. WE
CREATED STRATEGIES TO ADDRESS
THE HATE THAT MANY STUDENTS SAW
IMPACTS OF RACE AND- RACISM AND
BIAS THE KILLING OF GEORGE
FLOYD THE SPIKE IN HATE.
AGAINST THE ASIAN AMERICAN
PACIFIC ISLANDER COMMUNITIES
ALL THESE THINGS ADDED TO THE
STRESS THAT OUR STUDENTS WERE
DEALING WITH ON TOP OF THE
STRESS OF THE PANDEMIC. ITSELF
AND SO WE'VE ADDED YOU KNOW
STAFF AT THE DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION TO ADDRESS ISSUES OF
EQUITY WE'VE ADDED A FAMILY
ENGAGEMENT UNIT WE'VE ADDED A
YOUTH ADVISORY COUNCIL SO THAT
YOUNG PEOPLE. CAN HELP US HELP
OTHER STUDENTS IN NAVIGATING
THE STRESS THAT MANY OF OUR
STUDENTS ARE EXPERIENCING I
WANT TO TELL YOU THAT WHILE
IT'S CHALLENGING OUR STUDENTS
ARE DOING WELL. I'VE HAD THE
PERSONAL PRIVILEGE OF VISITING
MANY MANY SCHOOL DISTRICTS AS
THEY ARE OPENING AND PREPARING
TO REOPEN. YEAH AND IN ALL THE
DISTRICTS I'VE VISITED YOU KNOW
IT IS NOT UNUSUAL FOR MORE THAN
95% OF THE STUDENTS TO HAVE
RETURNED TO IN PERSON
INSTRUCTION WE KNOW THAT THAT
IS THE DEFAULT THAT IS THE BEST
WAY TO SERVE OUR STUDENTS. WHEN
THEY HAVE ACCESS TO THE
EDUCATORS WHEN THEY HAVE ACCESS
TO THEIR PEERS AND FOR THOSE
WHO NEED IT WE APPRECIATE THAT
THE STATE HAS PROVIDED. SOME
ABILITY FOR SOME FORM OF
INDEPENDENT STUDY FOR STUDENTS
WITH. MEDICAL NECESSITY OR
OTHER NEEDS BUT WE KNOW THAT
OUR STUDENTS. NEED TO HAVE
ACCESS TO IN PERSON INSTRUCTION
IT'S BEEN GREAT TO VISIT SO
MANY OF OUR SCHOOL DISTRICTS
AND TO SEE OUR STUDENTS
RETURNING. AND JUST SEE THE
ENERGY AND EXCITEMENT. FROM
STUDENTS AND FROM THEIR PARENTS.
WE ALSO SEE SOME LEVEL OF
ANXIETY- THERE'S A LOT GOING ON
IN THE WORLD AND IN TERMS OF.
THE CORONA VIRUS- KOBE NINETEEN
VIRUS SCAN IT THE LATEST- YOU
KNOW BEARING AND SO WE KNOW
THAT THERE ARE CHALLENGES. BUT
WE CAN NAVIGATE THESE
CHALLENGES AND WE WORK WITH OUR
SCHOOLS WE WORK WITH OUR
FAMILIES TO HELP NAVIGATE DOWN
OUR OFFICE IS WORKING WITH THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE AND OTHERS TO
PROVIDE. FIVE MILLION RAPID
COLBY TESTS TO HELP OUR SCHOOLS
HAVE AWARENESS ABOUT
ADDRESSING- WHO MIGHT BE A
POSITIVE FOR COVERT SO THAT WE
CAN HELP FAMILIES QUARANTINE.
AND HELP OTHERS- YOU'LL BE ABLE
TO STAY SAFE IN THE SCHOOL
COMMUNITY WE KNOW THAT ONE OF
THE BIGGEST STRESSORS IS KOBE
ITSELF. AND FOR CHILDREN WHO
COME TO SCHOOL- WHO HAVE LOST
LOVED ONES WHO'VE EXPERIENCED
LOSS IN YOUR COMMUNITY A LOVED
ONE HAS LOST A HOME OR A JOB.
WE DO SEE SOME EVIDENCE OF
STRESS THAT THEY MAY BE DEALING
WITH I WANT TO COMMEND SOME OF
THE SCHOOL DISTRICTS THAT HAD A
CHANCE TO VISIT. BUT THE CHULA
VISTA ELEMENTARY SCHOOL
DISTRICT THIS IS A DISTRICT
WITH FIFTY THREE SCHOOLS. EVERY
ONE OF THE SCHOOLS HAS A
COUNSELOR OR SCHOOL
PSYCHOLOGIST OR SOCIAL WORKER
WHO IS ATTENDING TO THE NEEDS
OF OUR STUDENTS. THIS WAS
LARGELY OUT OF THE INVESTMENTS
MADE BY YOU ALL OF YOU OUR
LEGISLATORS OUR GOVERNOR AND WE
WERE GLAD TO WORK WITH YOU ON
HOW. TO ENSURE THE DERBY FOUR
POINT THREE BILLION DOLLARS FOR
COUNSELING FOR YOUNG PEOPLE
FROM. BIRTH TO AGE TWENTY FIVE
ANOTHER THREE BILLION DOLLARS
FOR COMMUNITY SCHOOLS. FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS THAT. WAS
APPROVED IN THE BUDGET TO
SUPPORT SOCIAL EMOTIONAL
LEARNING FOR PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT FOR EDUCATORS IT
WAS A PLEASURE. TO SHARE A
STATEWIDE SOCIAL EMOTIONAL
LEARNING TASK FORCE THAT'S WORK
WITH MANY INCLUDING OUR
EXPANDED LEARNING AN AFTER
SCHOOL PROGRAM- PARTNERS WHO
DOING SO MUCH. TO SUPPORT OUR
STUDENTS WE SHOULD ALSO. THANK
ALL OF OUR AFTER SCHOOL EXPAND
LEARNING PARTNERS- ARE
EDUCATORS WORKING ALONGSIDE. OF
ALL OF OUR STUDENTS. IT'S GREAT
TODAY TO BE IN ANOTHER SCHOOL
DISTRICT I'M COMING TO YOU-
FROM THE BALLET. VIOLIN THOUGH
SCHOOL DISTRICT- THAT ALSO OPEN
TODAY THAT HAS CREATED FAMILY
RESOURCE CENTERS. AND HAS MADE
ACCESS TO SOCIAL WORKERS
AVAILABLE TO OUR FAMILIES TO
PROVIDE THEM SUPPORT. MANY
SCHOOLS ARE OPENING THIS WEEK
MANY ARE PLANNED TO OPEN IN THE
NEXT SEVERAL WEEKS. IN
PROVIDING SUPPORT AND
COUNSELING WILL BE AMONG THE
TOP THINGS THAT WE MUST PROVIDE
FOR ALL OF OUR STUDENTS THIS
YEAR WE WORKED IN SPONSORED
LEGISLATION- WITH- SOME
REMEMBER O'DONNELL AND OTHERS
THAT. RESULTED IN THE EXPANSION
OF MEDICS HOW. FOR MANY OF OUR
SCHOOL DISTRICTS WE CAN DRAW
DOWN MORE FEDERAL DOLLARS- TO
MAKE SURE OUR SCHOOLS HAVE
ACCESS. TO MENTAL HEALTH
RESOURCES THANK YOU ALEX
BRISCOE- FOR HELPING TO WORK
WITH US IN THE MEMBERS OF THE
MENTAL HEALTH ADVISORY. TASK
FORCE WORKING WITH US IN THE
LEGISLATURE AND THE GOVERNOR
FOR INFUSING MORE MONEY IN THE
STATE BUDGET TO HELP OUR
SCHOOLS LEARN HOW TO DRAW DOWN.
MORE FEDERAL DOLLARS FOR MENTAL
HEALTH YOU THE MATTER CAL
PROGRAM UP THERE MANY THINGS
THAT- WE HAVE AHEAD OF US TO
WORK ON- BUT AS AS
SUPERINTENDENT GORDON HAS
INDICATED- YOU ALL HAVE
PROVIDED US WITH THE KIND OF
BUDGET THAT ALLOWS US TO MAKE.
KIND OF LIFETIME CHANGES AND
MAYBE ONCE IN A LIFETIME TYPES
OF CHANGES TO OUR EDUCATION
SYSTEM. WE HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY
TO BUILD BACK BETTER THAN WE'VE
EVER HAD BEFORE THE CLIMB OUT
OF THE ASHES OF THE PANDEMIC
HAS CREATED IT'S A LITERALLY
CREATE THE KIND OF SYSTEM THAT
ENSURES. THAT WE PROVIDE A
GREAT EDUCATIONAL SYSTEM FOR
EACH OF OUR SIX MILLION
STUDENTS TO MAKE SURE THAT THEY
HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY FOR
LEARNING RECOVERY USING GREAT
TUTORING PROGRAM PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT LITERACY PROGRAMS.
AND OTHER THINGS THAT BUILD ON
SKILL I THANK THE MEMBERS OF
THIS. COMMITTEE FOR STARTING BY
FOCUSING ON THE SO EMOTIONAL.
THE OF OUR- TO KNOW THAT THAT
MAKES IT A GREAT DEAL OF
DIFFERENCE AND IF YOU ALLOW ME.
JUST A MOMENT PERSONAL
PRIVILEGES SAY I CONTINUE TO
APPLAUD ALLTHOSE WHO HAVE
RECEIVED THE VACCINATION I'M AT
A SCHOOL DISTRICT TODAY AND BY
A WINDOW WHERE NINETY EIGHT
PERCENT. OF THE EDUCATORS HAVE
RECEIVED A VACCINE THAT'S SO
CRITICAL FOR OUR CHILDREN UNDER
THE AGE OF TWELVE WHO CANNOT
GET ONE IN CRITICAL TO ALLOWING
US TO KEEP OUR SCHOOLS OPEN AND
SAFE. THEY'RE FREE THEY DON'T
HURT WE WILL ENCOURAGE EVERYONE
TO GET ONE AND AGAIN- SENATORS
THANK YOU FOR TAKING UP THE
ISSUE OF MENTAL HEALTH AND
SUPPORTS FOR STUDENTS. IT WE
REMAIN AVAILABLE TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS AND PROVIDE ANY
ADDITIONAL EXAMPLES OF THE WAYS
THAT WE CAN SUPPORT OUR SIX
MILLION STUDENTS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MR SUPERINTENDENT AND
THANK YOU TO YOUR STAFF AND C.
D. E. AND YOU'RE RIGHT THE
VACCINES ARE FREE AND THEY
DON'T HURT BUT THIS IS NOT
ABOUT THAT. THE NEXT STEP IS MR
MAT NOVEL MR NOVEL ARE YOU WITH
US. I'M HERE GREAT PLEASE
PROCEED WHEN YOU'RE READY. ALL
GOOD MORNING CENTERS COMMITTEE
CHAIRS NEWMAN'S UNDER WAY THANK
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY SPEAK
WITH YOU THIS MORNING. HI MY
NAME IS MATT NOT ON THE NEW
DIRECTOR EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
THE C. C. CALIFORNIA
COOPERATIVE FOR EDUCATIONAL
EXCELLENCE AND IT'S A PLEASURE
BEING WITH YOU HERE. THIS
MORNING. MY PRODUCT OF
CALIFORNIA EDUCATION AND SERVED
IN EDUCATION BOTH SPECIAL
EDUCATION GENERAL EDUCATION FOR
OVER TWENTY EIGHT YEARS. MASO
PARENT OF THREE. BOYS IN THE
EDUCATION SYSTEM. AND THIS IS A
TOPIC THAT'S DEAR AND NEAR TO
MY HEART I APPRECIATE.
LEGISLATOR TAKING THIS UP AS A
CONVERSATION. I'M I'M FOCUSED
AND HAPPY TO JOIN THE CCP. IN
CONTINUING ITS MISSION OF
BECOMING A- COCKFIGHTING
QUALITY TECHNICAL EDUCATION FOR
EVERY CHILD. BEFORE I START
WITH SOME OF THE HIGHLIGHTS FOR
CCP AT LIKE TO JUST SHARE. ON
SOME OF OUR STATEWIDE PARTNERS
AND KNOWLEDGE THE EFFORTS OF
BOTH LEGISLATURE THE GOVERNOR.
STATE SUPERINTENDENT OF PUBLIC
INSTRUCTION STATE BOARD OF
EDUCATION COUNTY OFFICES OF
EDUCATION MOST. FAMILIES AS
THEY NAVIGATE- AGAIN THIS NOVEL
VIRUS. THE C. C. WILL CONTINUE
TO SHIFT ITS PRIORITIES TO BEST
SUPPORT. EDUCATOR NEEDS A
STUDENT NEEDS. AND THE MOST
RECENT HISTORICAL INVESTMENTS
HAVE PROVIDED US AN OPPORTUNITY
AN UNPRECEDENTED. OPPORTUNITY
TO BETTER UNDERSTAND AND
ADDRESS THE- NEEDS OF MENTAL
HEALTH. NEEDS OF FORTY SEVEN
POINT. WELL THIS PANDEMIC
EASIER WORKED PROVIDER RANGE OF
SUPPORT. DELAYS BIKE QUICKLY
IDENTIFY AND DISTRIBUTING
STRATEGIES AND RESOURCES. TO
SUPPORT ALL ELLIE ACTS. IN THE
CC AND OTHER AGENCIES IN THE
STATEWIDE SYSTEM MUST. WORK
HARD TO SUPPORT EDUCATORS
STAKEHOLDERS IN MEETING THE
NEEDS AND LEARNING NEEDS SOCIAL
EMOTIONAL NEEDS BEHAVIORAL
NEEDS OF THE STUDENTS THEY
SERVE. I HAVE ELEVEN AVAILABLE
OUR TEAM HAS PROVIDED A
DETAILED HANDOUT THAT SHOULD BE
INCLUDED IN YOUR PACKET IN THE
TUBES ARE NOVEL I'M GONNA RIP
YOU FOR JUST A SECOND IF
SOMEONE HAS DIALED IN. MAKE
SURE THAT YOU'RE ON MUTE
BECAUSE. WE ARE GETTING
SOMEONE'S CONVERSATION. IF SEED.
THANK YOU I WASN'T SURE I
WASN'T SURE IF THAT WAS ON MY
END TO BE HONEST- WE TRY TO
YOU- HAND OUT OF. THAT GIVES
YOU AN OVERVIEW OF DETAILS IN
THE SUMMARY OF THE EFFORTS OF
THE C. C. MOST IMPORTANTLY. IT
PROVIDES THE FOCUS AREAS OF
SOCIAL EMOTIONAL LEARNING
SPORTS PROVIDED DAILY AIDS.
ASPECTS OF FINDING SOMEBODY
BILL EIGHTY SIX THE CC IS
RESPONSIBLE FOR PROVIDING
PROFESSIONAL LEARNING
OPPORTUNITIES. THANK CHRIS THE
CAPACITY OF LOCAL EDUCATION
AGENCIES TO ACCELERATE LEARNING
AND ADDRESS THE SOCIAL
EMOTIONAL BEHAVIORAL NEEDS OF
THE STUDENTS THEY SERVE. AS AN
EXAMPLE OF OUR EFFORTS. WITH
OVER NINE THOUSAND
PARTICIPATING ATTENDEES. THESE
MATERIALS HAVE BEEN ACCESSED
AND DOWNLOADED FROM OUR WEBSITE
FROM OVER ONE HUNDRED SIXTY
FIVE THOUSAND TIMES. WE'VE
PROVIDED FREE STATEWIDE ACCESS
TO PROFESSIONAL LEARNING ON A
VARIETY OF TOPICS THAT INCLUDE
SOCIAL EMOTIONAL. ARE LEARNING.
TO WELL OVER THREE THOUSAND
DELEGATES TAILORED PROFESSIONAL
LEARNING WITH ONGOING COACHING
TO OVER SIXTY. C. C. WILL
CONTINUE TO MEET URGENT NEEDS
OF LA AIDS BY COLLABORATING
WITH ITS COUNTY OFFICE PARTNERS
TO DEVELOP RESOURCES THAT
PRIORITIZE THE WHOLE CHILD
APPROACH TO PROFESSIONAL
LEARNING THAT ADDRESS TEACHING
AND LEARNING WITH THE
INTEGRATION OF SOCIAL EMOTIONAL
BEHAVIORAL PROBLEMS. FOR
EXAMPLE A TURNAROUND FOR
CHILDREN PROVIDED A WHOLE CHILD
SCIENCE SERIES FOR DISTRICT
TEAMS THAT WAS GROUNDED IN THE
SCIENCE OF LEARNING AND
POSITIVE YOUTH DEVELOPMENT
SOFTWARE TOOLS THAT CALM
STUDENTS AND STAFF. TO CREATE
POSITIVE CONDITIONS FOR
LEARNING. OUR MOST RECENT
RESOURCES THE PLAYBOOK FOR
XCELERATED LEARNED IT'S A TIME
SAVING TOOL THAT GIVES
INSTRUCTIONAL LEADERS HELPFUL
TIPS AND RESOURCES FOR CREATING
ACCELERATED LEARNING PLANS TO
FILL IN GAPS WHILE TAKING
STUDENTS THROUGH GRADE LEVEL.
OUR WORK IN ADDRESSING SOCIAL
MOTION. FOUNDATION ALL OF THESE
RESOURCES IS THE IS THE
CONTINUED NEED TO LEARN FROM
THE COMMUNITY ENGAGEMENT
INITIATIVE WE HAVE. ONGOING
WORK TO HELP BETTER SUPPORT OUR
STUDENTS FAMILIES AND
COMMUNITIES AT LARGE ADDRESSING
THE WHOLE CHILD NEEDS DURING
THE- AS WE MOVE FORWARD WILL
CONTINUE TO DEVELOP AND ENHANCE
A PROFESSIONAL LEARNING THROUGH
OUR A. B. EIGHTY SIX
OBLIGATIONS. WILL BE FOCUSED ON
COLLABORATING AND COORDINATING
STATEWIDE RESOURCES THAT FOCUS
ON BUILDING KNOWLEDGE AND BEST
PRACTICES FOR TEACHING AND
LEARNING. THROUGH THE
INTEGRATION OF SOCIAL EMOTIONAL
BEHAVIOURAL SUPPORTS. WILL BE
INCREASING ACCESSIBILITY FOR
ELEAZAR IDENTIFYING USED BEST
PRACTICES AND RESOURCES TO
ADDRESS SOCIAL EMOTIONAL
LEARNING NEEDS. AND WILL
CONTINUE TO BUILD PARTNERSHIPS
AND NETWORKS THAT CAN HELP
IDENTIFY AND ADDRESS ELEAZAR
HIGH PRIORITY AREAS TO BETTER
MEET THE- NEEDS OF THEIR
STUDENTS. IN ADDITION WITH THE
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO BUDGET
ACTING EDUCATION TRAILER BUILT
THE CCTV HAS BEEN CALLED TO
MINISTER IN PARTNERSHIP WITH
SELECTED COUNTY OFFICES OF
EDUCATION. EVIDENCE BASED
PROFESSIONAL LEARNING FOR
EDUCATORS THAT CAN SUPPORT
LEARNING ACCELERATION FOR
CALIFORNIA'S DIVERSE POPULATION
SPECIFICALLY IN THE AREAS OF
MATHEMATICS. LITERACY AND
LANGUAGE DEVELOPMENT. I THANK
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK WITH YOU TODAY EXCITED TO
SERVICE NEW DIRECTOR OF THE CCP
AND THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
MOST IMPORTANTLY THE CHILDREN
OF THIS GREAT STATE. I LOOK
FORWARD TO THE OPPORTUNITY TO
COLLABORATE STATE
SUPERINTENDENT OF PUBLIC
INSTRUCTION MR THOMPSON
THURMAN. AND SACRAMENTO COUNTY
OFFICE OF EDUCATION
SUPERINTENDENT DAVE COURT TO
SUPPORT THE ALLEGATIONS IN THE
DRESSING AS YOUR NEEDS FIRST.
NOT POSITIVE THE QUESTION. THE
YOU MR NOVEL. ALL OF OUR
PANELISTS SOMEONE TO SAY THANK
YOU FOR PARTICIPATING AND NOW
OPEN IT UP TO QUESTIONS FROM
ANY OF OUR MEMBERS THE SERVICE
SENATOR PAM AND THEN SENATOR
GLAZER SENATOR PAM THANK YOU SO
MUCH- CHARLIE OF- AND ALSO
CHAIR NEWMAN AND I REALLY WANNA
THANK OUR SPEAKERS FOR THE
PRESENTATIONS TODAY I DO WANT
TO RECOGNIZE AND THANK OUR
STATE SUPERINTENDENT OF PUBLIC
INSTRUCTION FOR HIS- VERY.
IMPORTANT WORDS ABOUT
VACCINATION AND HOW THAT IS
GOING TO HELP US STOP THE
SPREAD OF THIS DISEASE IN OUR
SCHOOLS AS WELL AS OUR STATE-
SOMEONE RECOGNIZE- DAVE GORDON
WHO COURSE SAYS- ABLY HELPING
US OUT IS- THE- SUPERINTENDENT
OF- THE SEGMENT OF COUNTY BOARD
OF EDUCATION HERE IN MY OWN
DISTRICT AS WELL. I GUESS ONE
OF MY QUESTIONS IS THAT IS- AND
I KNOW THAT- SUPERTANKER AND
ALSO SERVES ON THE- MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES OVERSIGHT
ACCOUNTABILITY COMMISSION AS
WELL IS- YOU KNOW WE KNOW
THERE'S A LARGE. DEMAND AND
NEED FOR MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES
FOR- FOR OUR STUDENTS AND OUR-
CHILDREN AND- WELL THINGS THAT
IS WE'RE DOING THIS HEARING IS
THINKING ABOUT YOU KNOW HOW DO
WE LEVERAGE ALL THE DIFFERENT
RESOURCES AND- YES MY QUESTION
IS THAT SO WHAT DO YOU SEE IS
THE ROLE OF THAT SAMPLE PRIMARY
CARE PHYSICIANS- SO MANY.
CHILDREN DO YOU HAVE A
PEDIATRICIAN OR FAMILY
PHYSICIAN WHO IS- PROVIDING
PRIMARY CARE- WE KNOW THERE'S A
SHORTAGE BEHAVIORAL HEALTH-
PROFESSIONALS- BOTH IN THE
COMMUNITY AND EVEN IN SCHOOLS.
SO HOW HOW DO YOU SEE-
DEVELOPING SYSTEMS THAT-
BASICALLY NOT ONLY OF COURSE
INTEGRATE SOME OF THE BEHAVIOR
HEALTH SPECIALISTS THAT PERHAPS
IN THE COUNTY AND OTHER PLACES
BUT ALSO PRIMARY CARE
PHYSICIANS AS WELL AND BUILDING
COLLABORATIONS- WITH US SCHOOLS
TO TRY TO. AGAIN PROVIDE MORE
RESOURCES AND- FOR- STUDENTS-
IS THERE BEING IS THERE GOING
TO THE EDUCATION SYSTEM. BOB
ALL GOLD I'M HAPPY TO TAKE A
SHOT AT THAT QUESTION- THANK
YOU SENATOR AND- AND THANK YOU
FOR ALL OF YOUR- EFFORTS
LOCALLY IN SACRAMENTO TO- TO
STAND UP FOR OUR- YOUNG PEOPLE
AND THEIR NEEDS IT'S SO
APPRECIATED. R. A. D. WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT FOR BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH PROFESSIONALSIS A
CRYING NEED AS I SAID WE'RE
WE'RE LOOKING TO FIND UP TO
THREE HUNDRED. PROFESSIONALS
JUST TO SEND OUT TO OUR SCHOOLS
IN SACRAMENTO COUNTY AND ONE OF
THE THINGS WE'VE BEEN WORKING
ON BOTH THE COMMISSION AND
LOCALLY. IS A WORKFORCE
PIPELINE. WHERE WE MIGHT- SO UP
MATH TO ENCOURAGE PEOPLE TO GET
INTO THE FIELD TO HELP SUPPORT
THEM THROUGH. MENTORSHIPS
INTERNSHIPS SO THAT THEY CAN BE
SUPPORTED OR GOING THROUGH
SCHOOL STAY IN TOUCH WITH THEM
ENCOURAGE THEM. IN CHURCH AND
TO COME BACK- AND WORK IN OUR
LOCAL SCHOOLS- AND LOCAL
COMMUNITIES I THINK YOUR IDEA
ABOUT REACHING OUT TO. A
PRIMARY CARE DOCTORS IS- IS
OUTSTANDING AND I THINK THAT'S
SOMETHING WE CAN DO WITH OUR
INITIATIVES. THAT WE HAVE
WORKING CLOSELY WITH COUNTY
PUBLIC HEALTH AND ALSO WITH OUR
OUR MEDICAL PROVIDERS OR
MANAGED CARE FOR BUYERS- AND
OUR HEALTH SYSTEMS AND THAT'S
ON OUR AGENDA TO. DO LOCALLY
AND STATEWIDE AS A COMMISSION
WE SHOULD. DR PANS OUT IF I
COULD ADD ON TO WHAT WE'RE
GOING TO COURT AND SAY- OUR OUR
OWN SECRETARY OF HEALTH AND
HUMAN SERVICES SAID DR GALLEY.
IS WORKING TO IMPLEMENT A PLAN
THAT WOULD DO IT SHE SAID BRING
UP MANAGED CARE PROVIDERS INTO
THE CONVERSATION YUP I'M A BIG
PROPONENT OF HOW WE USE
MEDICARE DOLLARS BUT AS YOU
KNOW. WE HAD MANY FAMILIES THAT
EVEN THOUGH THERE- YOU KNOW
DON'T EARN A LOT OF MONEY THEY
STILL DON'T THEY EARN TOO MUCH
TO QUALIFY FOR THE MEDICARE
PROGRAMS AND SO- WHAT DR
KELLY'S PLAN WILL DO- AND I
THINK IT BUILDS OFF OF THE FOUR
POINT THREE BILLION DOLLARS.
FOR MENTAL HEALTH FROM AGES
ZERO TO TWENTY FIVE WE'LL BRING
ALL PROVIDERS TOGETHER- FROM
BOTH THE SCHOOL COMMUNITIES AND
THE MENTAL HEALTH AND HEALTH
PROVIDERS AND IT WILL HELP US
TO DO SOMETHING THAT YOU KNOW
MANY OF US HAVE STRUGGLED WITH
FOR A LONG TIME. FILLING THOSE
GAPS THAT EXIST IN THE DELIVERY
OF MENTAL HEALTH INTO THE METAL
HEALTH ADVISORY OVERSIGHT
COMMITTEES OUT HAS BEEN A
REALLY CRITICAL IN HELPINGTO.
THINK ABOUT HOW TO BUILD A MORE
COMPREHENSIVE SYSTEM SO I THINK
AGAIN- THE FUNDING CREATES AN
OPPORTUNITY TO BUILD A BETTER
SYSTEM- THAT WILL ENVISION ALL
PROVIDERS BEING PART. OF THE
DELIVERY- SYSTEM. NO REALLY
PRETTY THE ANTS- FOR THIS.
PRIOR TO MEETING THE
LEGISLATURE AS ACTUALLY THE
MEDICAL CONSULTANT FOR SEX
SECOND CITY UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT AND PARTNERED WITH
SCHOOL NURSES AND PSYCHOLOGISTS
TO. BASIC FIGURE HOW WE CAN
BETTER INTEGRATE- CARE FOR
MENTAL HEALTH CONDITIONS
INCLUDING ADHD SO WE WEREN'T IN
KOBE BACK THEN BUT WE WERE
DEATHS. HOW DO WE LINK
EDUCATION AND HEALTH AND HEALTH
CARE TOGETHER. RIGHT AND SO OF
COURSE YOU KNOW- NOT ONLY OF
COURSE FOR. THE HALF OF
CHILDREN WHO ARE ON MEDICARE
NOW BUT ALSO EVEN THOSE WHO ARE
COMMERCIAL AS WELL SO.
CERTAINLY LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH EACH OF YOU ON
THIS ISSUE. I AM VERY- YOU KNOW
CERTAINLY AWARE AND X- EXCITED
ABOUT THE OPPORTUNITY THAT-
THAT WAS PROPOSED BY SECRETARY
GOLLY AND THAT I KNOW THAT WE
HERE IN THE LEGISLATURE HEARD
AND HAS SUPPORTED IN THE STATE
BUDGET. BUT SO I'M SURE THAT AS
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT MENTAL
HEALTH IN SCHOOLS TO DO THINK
ABOUT THE FACT THAT MANY OF
THESE CHILDREN A RAKE OUT ALSO
HAVE A RELATIONSHIP WITH. THEIR
PRIMARY CARE PHYSICIAN WHO THAT
YOU KNOW DOES HAVE TRAINING
AND- MANY BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
ISSUES AND BEING SURE THAT WE
DON'T MISS THIS OPPORTUNITY TO
ALSO LEVERAGE. THEIR CAPACITIES
AS WELL AS- GIVEN THE
SIGNIFICANT BURDEN. ON MENTAL
HEALTH IS- THE BASICALLY A LOT.
HEALTH THAT THEY'RE BEING FACE
BURCHILL. AND OF COURSE
AFFECTING THEIR EDUCATION SO
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU
SENATOR PAN CENTER GLAZER.
THANK YOU THANK YOU CHAIR LEYVA
ANSWERED NEWMAN FOR THE
SAMPLING THIS UP PANEL IN THIS-
ET TODAY IT'S IT COMES AT A AT
A IMPORTANT TIME BUT IT'S
CERTAINLY A DIFFICULT TIME. I
APPRECIATED HEARING FROM OUR
WONDERFUL SUPERINTENDENT IN
MISTER GORDON MYSTERY NOVEL
ABOUT- THE RESOURCES THAT WE
ARE DIRECTING TO TRYING TO DEAL
WITH THIS AT. THIS ISSUE- I
KNOW THAT- I- AND MY COLLEAGUES
WHO WERE PLEASE TO PUT THE
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS REALLY A
HUGE AMOUNTS OF MONEY. TO DAY
IN RECOGNITION OF THE
CHALLENGES THAT WE'RE FACING IN
OUR SCHOOLS AND WITH OUR KIDS.
BUT THE- THE QUESTION THAT THAT
IS ON MY MIND AND I IF THERE'S
A POTENTIAL RESPONSE I'D LOVE
TO HEAR IT. IS IT HOW DO WE-
HOW WE GOT A MEASURE- SUCCESS.
HOW WE CAN MEASURE PROGRESS.
HOW WE GONNA MEASURE WHAT KIND
OF AN ONGOING PROBLEM THIS
REALLY- IS. NOT FOR THOSE OF US
WHO ARE THAT MAKE DECISIONS
ABOUT POLICY AND BUDGET IN THIS
SPACE WE WANT TO MAKE GOOD
CHOICES. AND SO AS YOU ARE
ADVANCING THESE IMPORTANT
INITIATIVES TO HELP OUR KIDS.
AND OUR STAFF. DURING THESE
DIFFICULT TIMES HOW IS IT THAT.
YOU ARE GOING TO MEASURE AND
YOU CAN REPORT BACK TO US ON
WHAT REALLY. HAS BEEN THE
EFFECT OF THOSE INVESTMENTS SO
THAT WE KNOW HOW WE CAN AS
POLICY MAKERS MAKE GOOD CHOICES
GOING FORWARD. ALL RIGHT MA'AM.
MANY OF OUR PANELISTS WANT TO
TAKE A STAB AT THAT. YES I'M
HAPPY I'M HAPPY TO. LATE IN THE
DAY AND THEN I'LL LET THE STATE
SUPERINTENDENT. CHARLIE OFFICE
WITHIN MR BOARD TAKE CARE I
LOVE THE QUESTION ARE CENTERED
MAJOR AND THIS IS ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT WE ARE GRAPPLING
WITH PROSTATE ACTUALLY AS- AS I
WORK WITH THE NATIONAL CENTER
FOR SYSTEMIC IMPROVEMENT WE
LEAD OUR TWENTY EIGHT STATES
AROUND THIS CONVERSATION.
ACROSS THE COUNTRY AND
NATIONALLY WERE GRAPPLING WITH
THIS ABOUT HOW DO WE MEASURE
THE- THE QUALITY OF INVESTMENTS
RELATED TO S. E. L. WE ARE
TACKLING THAT NURSE IN OUR GEO
LEAD CONVERSATIONS IN OUR
STAKEHOLDER CONVERSATIONS ABOUT
WAYS THAT WE CAN MEASURE
PROGRESS. I THINK THERE'S A LOT
OF DEBATE NATIONALLY ABOUT HOW
WE DO THAT- D. REACTIONS FOR
ELLIE GAYS IN THE MIDST OF THIS
PANDEMIC SPIN TO REACT TO THE
PANDEMIC IN THE NEEDS OF
STUDENTS BY IMMEDIATELY TRYING
TO ASSOCIATE SOME TYPE OF
SCREENER. TO ASSESS WHETHER
SQUARE STUDENTS FALL ON A
CONTINUUM OF SUPPORTS A
NATIONAL YOU HAVE A LOT OF
DEBATES AROUND THAT I THINK BUT
OUR EFFORTS. WILL BE TO- AT THE
TIME. WERE OURS. ACROSS STATE.
IT'S TOO BAD- IDENTIFY HOW WE
CAN DO THIS MORE EFFECTIVELY SO
THAT WE CAN PROVIDE. FOR YOU
THE NEEDED INFORMATION THAT YOU
REQUIRE. NOW AND THAT WE
REQUIRE TO EVALUATE THE
EFFECTIVENESS OF OUR
INVESTMENTS SO MY SHORT ANSWER
IS- WE NEED TO WORK ON THIS
THIS IS SOMETHING THAT'S
HAPPENING ACROSS NATIONAL
ACROSS THE STATE I DON'T THINK
ANYONE HAS THIS. ASSISTING
CANCER AND I'M LOOKING FORWARD
TO THE OPPORTUNITY TO BRING IT
BACK TO YOU. HOW THOSE
CONVERSATIONS HAVE COME OUT BUT
WE'VE DEVELOPED AS A RESULT. IF
I COULD THANK YOU I WOULD JUST
ADD TO- MR NAVAJOS- RESPONSE I
THINK THAT. WE HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO CREATE- A WAY TO
MEASURE A STUDENT- SUCCESS AND
SCHOOL SUCCESS AND THAT CAN BE
THROUGH SCHOOL CLIMATE. THAT
CAN HAVE THERE COULD BE
MEASURES THAT WE CAN USE TO
MEASURE. INDIVIDUAL STUDENT-
SUCCESS AND HOW- YOU KNOW CAN
WE SEE A REDUCTION. IN CRISES
AND CRISES HOSPITALIZATIONS-
AND I'M GATEFUL TO THE
LEGISLATURE FOR YOUR WORK IN
THE BUDGET. TO PROVIDE THE
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION WITH AT
LEAST A HALF A DOZEN STAFF IN
THE SPACE OF MENTAL HEALTH.
THAT GIVES US AN OPPORTUNITY TO
BEGIN TO WORK WITH ACTS- IN
SUCCESS- AND ALL OF OUR SCHOOLS
TO BUILD A NETWORK FOR HOW WE
TOLD STORIES. OF SUCCESS FOR
OUR ENTIRE. DISTRICT WE KNOW
THAT THERE'S LOCAL CONTROL
INDIVIDUALS WILL USE VARIOUS
TYPES OF. WAYS TO SUPPORT
STUDENTS WE LIKE TO BUILD THE
PICTURE- IN BUILD THE METRICS.
FOR MEASURING SUCCESS- STATE
WIDE THE END PRIOR TO THIS
YEAR'S BUDGET THE DEPARTMENT
HAS HAD ONLY ONE. PERSON WITH A
JOB TITLE THAT WAS FOCUSED ON
MENTAL HEALTH AND I GOT TO GET
A GREAT SHOT OUT- TO MONICA.
ANNAPOLIS SAME- WHO'S BEEN
HELPING TO STEER SO MANY
TRAININGS. YOUR MENTAL HEALTH
FIRST AID IN OTHERS NOW WE HAVE
THE OPPORTUNITY CREATE.
INTEGRATED COMPREHENSIVE WAY OF
MEASURING AND I WANT TO SAY AN
EXACT KNOWLEDGE OF THIS WILL BE
A CHALLENGE. FOR OUR SCHOOL
DISTRICT BECAUSE THEY ARE
WORRIED. EVEN THOUGH THE
INVESTMENT IS SO ROBUST FROM
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. AND
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT THEY'RE
WORRIED ABOUT THE NATURE OF ONE
TIME DOLLARS THEY'RE WORRIED
ABOUT- HIRING POSITIONS. THAT
MAY HAVE TO GO AWAY IN A FEW
YEARS AND IT'S NOT JUST. THE
MENTAL HEALTH BY THE WAY- I
NUMBERS PUTTING THAT OUT THERE
BECAUSE I IT NOW. IT'S AN
OPPORTUNE FOR US TO BE MORE NOW
GET OUR OUR- AROUND HOW WE
DRESS THAT WE HAVE ALL THE
RIGHT EXPERTS ON THIS PANEL AND
MANY MANY OTHERS. WHO CAN HELP
US THINK THAT THROUGH BUT WE DO
SEE THE OPPORTUNITY CREATED
KIND OF INTEGRATED COORDINATED
WAY TO MEASURE STUDENT SUCCESS
GOING FORWARD AND- FOREST DR
DANIEL LEE- WHO HEADS UP OUR
EQUITY- UNIT AT OUR EQUITY
BRANCH OF THE DEPARTMENT
EDUCATION WHOSE- LICENSE SCHOOL
PSYCHOLOGISTS AND- A CLINICAL
PSYCHOLOGIST WILL BE HELPING
US. TO STEER THAT STATEWIDE
CONVERSATION ABOUT MEASURING-
THE IMPACT MENTAL HEALTH
THROUGHOUT THE STATE. AND I
ALSO SAY SENATOR LATER THANK
YOU FOR THE WORK WHEN YOU'RE
BUILDING YOUR- OUR PRODUCTS FOR
PARTNER WITH YOU ON- TO RAISE
AWARENESS AROUND MENTAL HEALTH
AND WE CERTAINLY WOULD BE EAGER
TO WORK WITH YOU ON THAT- IN
SUBSEQUENT- LEGISLATIVE FIVE.
YEARS OLD. IN CENTER. IF I JUST.
AND ONCE POINT I THINK AS WE
WORK TO BRING OUR HEALTH
SYSTEMS AND OUR SCHOOL SYSTEMS.
MORTON ALIGNMENT IT'S ABOUT
ACCESS MAKING SURE ALL OF OUR
YOUNG PEOPLE HAVE ACCESS. TO
CARE BUT MOST OF ALL THAT WE
FOCUS. AS MUCH ON PREVENTION AS
WE DO ON CARE SO THAT WE CAN
AVOID. THE THINGS THAT WHAT
YOUNG PEOPLE SO THAT MEANS ALSO
MOVING INTO THE ZERO TO FIVE
SPACE WALKS AS WE RAMP UP. A
TRANSITIONAL KINDERGARTEN IN
OUR IN OUR PRESCHOOLS. THE MORE
WE CAN LOAD IN PREVENTIVE
SERVICES THE MORE. WE WILL
AVOID MORE SERIOUS. YOUR BUT
DEAL WITH MAJOR ON IT'S- I WANT
THANK EACH THEM FOR THEIR
ANSWERS I APPRECIATE EACH OF
YOU THE LEADERSHIP THAT YOU'RE
PROVIDING ONE UNDERSCORE THE
IMPORTANT PINT THAT THE
SUPERINTENDENT MADE A MOMENT
AGO WE KNOW THIS IS NOT A ONE
TIME- ANSWER TO THIS PROBLEM IS
GOING TO BE AN ONGOING ONE. AND
THAT'S WHY IT'S IMPORTANT THAT
WE FIND WAYS TO TRY TO MEASURE
THE GREAT WORK THAT IS GOING TO
BE DONE AND WE HAVE TO WE HAVE
TO HAVE SOME SENSE OF PROGRESS
POINTS OR NOT IN ORDER FOR US
TO DO OUR BEST WORK AND MAKE
SURE THAT WE CAN PROVIDE THE
RESOURCES FOR THIS ON GOING TO
AN IMPORTANT EFFORT THANK YOU
SO MUCH. THANK YOU SENATOR
GLAZER SENATOR DOLLY THE ONLY
FRIEND SHE WAS AT LEAST GET A
REMIND PEOPLE AGAIN IF YOU ARE
CALLING IN MAKE SURE YOU WERE
ON YOU WE ARE GETTING SOMEONE'S
CONVERSATION CENTERED ALI THANK
YOU THE CO CHAIRS. AND I ALSO
LIKE TO JUST GIVE A SHOUT OUT
TO THE PANELIST I WANTED TO MR
THURMAN BEEN ON MANY- ZOOM
MEETINGS WITH MANY OF- MY
COUNTY SUPERINTENDENT OF
SCHOOLS IN MY DISTRICT AND I
APPRECIATE THAT I JUST WANT TO.
START OFF BY SAYING AS A
FATHER- THEY HAVE TWO SONS IN
HIGHER ED AND A DAUGHTER IN IN-
IN MIDDLE SCHOOL- IT'S BEEN A
VERY. DIFFERENT DIFFERENT- YEAR
OBVIOUSLY I ACTUALLY SPONSORED
LEGISLATION TO GIVE FIVE
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS FOR
MENTAL HEALTH FOR. SCHOOLS AND-
MR FORTINOS BILL WAS THE LEAD
BILL THAT CAME OUT BUT I WAS
HAPPY TO SUPPORT THAT- SO I
WANTED TO SHARE I THINK ONE OF
THE- THE- THERE'S NO LACK OF
RESOURCES. WE HAVE TONS OF
RESOURCES IN CALIFORNIA RIGHT
NOW AND IT AND IT'S A GREAT
OPPORTUNITY FOR US TO DO IT-
EXPEND THOSE RESOURCES BUT I
THINK. A COUPLE OF THINGS I
WANT TO. LOOK AT HERE IS. A BIT
AVAILABILITY OF PEOPLE ACTUALLY
DO THE WORK- REPRESENTING VERY
RULE DISTRICTS- THROUGHOUT THE
STATE. AND GETTING THE MONEY
OUT AND ACTUALLY FINDING THE
CLINICIANS- I'D LIKE TO MAYBE
TOUCH ON THAT A LITTLE BIT AND
THEN I WAS WONDERING AFTER YOU
KNOW THIS MANY. MONTHS OF BEING
IN THE PANDEMIC. ONE OF THE
THINGS I OBSERVED AS A PARENT
AND ALSO LISTENING TO MY-
DISTRICTS IS CONSISTENCY IN
LIKE POLICY SO I THINK- SENATOR
GLAZER KIND OF TOUCHED ON THAT
A LITTLE BIT LIKE. YOU KNOW HOW
TO MEASURE WHAT WHAT WE SEE AS
FAR AS- MOVING FORWARD SO. IF
YOU COULD TOUCH ON THOSE- AND
THEN THE LAST QUESTION WOULD
BE. HOW DO YOU SEE BEING
IMPLEMENTED IN THOSE AREAS THAT
ARE VERY RULE SO THOSE ARE THE
THREE. KIND OF TOP QUESTIONS I
HAD. HELLO THE PANELISTS DECIDE
WHO GOES FIRST THERE ARE. DOLLY
I GET OUTSIDE RIGHT I WANTED TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT IN NORMAL
AREAS THAT OUR FAMILIES ARE
DEALING WITH MANY THINGS IN
ADDITION TO COVERAGE WE'RE ALSO
DEALING WITH FIRES AND JUST
WANTED KNOWLEDGE HERE THAT
WE'VE HAD WHOLE COMMUNITIES
DESTROYED SCHOOLS LOSS AND LOSS
OF LOVED ONES AND SO AS WE
THINK ABOUT MENTAL HEALTH
SUPPORTS IN ADDITION TO CALL
BUT WE HAVE TO. PROVIDE
WRAPAROUND SUPPORTS FOR
FAMILIES IMPACTED BY A NATURAL
DISASTER- YEAH AND YOU'RE RIGHT
THE WORK FORCE HAS BEEN
IMPACTED YOU MENTIONED COUNTY
SUPERINTENDENTS ARE COUNTY
SUPERINTENDENTS HAVE BEEN
INCREDIBLE IN STANDING UP WAYS
TO- TO GROW THE WORKFORCE IN
SUPER JENNA GORDON TALKED ABOUT
IT. YEAH AND- YOU KNOW OUR
SOLANO COUNTY SUPERINTENDENT DR
HEARING JAN- HAS- I'M SORRY
CINEMA COUNTY SUPERINTENDENT DR
HEARING CAN HAS OUT OF
EXPERIENCE IN THE SESAME BUILT
A WAY TO HELP GET MORE
COUNSELORS AREAS ESPECIALLY
WHEN THEY'VE BEEN IMPACTED BY A
NATURAL DISASTER AND WE HAVE TO
LEARN FROM THAT AND BUILD FROM
THAT. AND BUILD THE WORKFORCE
PROGRAM SET SO THEY HELP US GET
MORE CLINICIANS IN THE AREAS
WHERE THERE ARE FEWER ACCESS
POINTS- TO HEALTH CARE AND TO
MENTAL HEALTH AND SO WE'RE
COMMITTED. YOU KNOW THIS IS
ALSO AN ISSUE WE HAVE TO DEAL
WITH IN TERMS OF WE HAVE
TEACHER SHORTAGES WE HAVE SO
MANY SUPERINTENDENTS ACROSS THE
COUNTRY WERE RTIRING THE
FATIGUE LEVEL OF EDUCATORS AND
MENTAL HEALTH PROFESSIONALS IS
SO SIGNIFICANT THAT PART OF OUR
CALCULUS IN THIS MOMENT HAS TO
BE ABOUT HOW WE SUPPORT OUR
EXISTING CLINICIANS AND YOU'RE
GONNA HEAR- FROM A GREAT
ASSOCIATION OF SCHOOL
PSYCHOLOGISTS AND COUNSELORS
ARE. LATER TODAY- I WON'T I
WON'T TAKE AWAY THEIR POINTS
BUT WE HAVE GREAT ASSOCIATIONS
FOR CLINICIANS WE HAVE TO
SUPPORT THEM WE HAVE SUPPORT
NOW IN TERMS OF STUDENTS WHO
ARE IN GRADUATE PROGRAMS TO
BECOME CLINICIANS AND REALLY
PUT THE INCENTIVES IN PLACE TO
HELP TEM- NOT ONLY BECOME
CLINICIANS BUT ALSO TO I'M TO
SOME OF THE COMMUTE. THAT HAVE
THE HIGHER. NEEDS IN OBVIOUSLY
WE'RE TO WORK YOU SENATOR DOLLY
ON WAYS THAT WE CAN BE
SUPPORTIVE I JUST WANTED TO
ACKNOWLEDGE ALL OF OUR FAMILIES
HAVE BEEN IMPACTED. BY THESE
FIRES- AND THANK ALL OF OUR
COUNTY SUPERINTENDENTS WERE
HELPING THEM. WE'VE ALSO RAISE
MONEY TO SUPPORT. THOSE
FAMILIES THAT NEED ADDITIONAL
RESOURCES AND SUPPORT AND- WE
STAND COMMITTED TO WORKING WITH
THESE PANELISTS AND- WITH OUR
OUR COUNTY SUPERINTENDENTS AND
OTHER LEADERS. ON HOW WE GROW
OUR WORK FORCE TO HAVE MORE
CLINICIANS ALL ACROSS THE STATE.
COULD I JUST BE VERY. DIRECT
THE- ARE YOU HAVEN'T SO IT
EVERY BUSINESS THAT I KNOW
INCLUDING MY OWN IS HAVING A
HARD TIME FINDING PEOPLE TO
WORK AND SO ARE WE ARE YOU
HAVING ITS DIRECTION ALREADY GE
OF. FILLING THESE POSITIONS.
ARE THEY AVAILABLE ARE THE
PEOPLE AVAILABLE. TO YOUR
QUESTION CENTER I THINK THAT IN
AREAS THAT HAVE HAD. TO HAVE
HEALTH CARE AND DON'T HAVE A
LOT OF HEALTH CARE PROVIDERS WE
HAVE SEEN HISTORICALLY. THAT
THERE HAVE BEEN CHALLENGES AND-
BEFORE THE END OF THIS HEARING
I CAN GET YOU ANY STATISTIC
THAT'S AVAILABLE ABOUT
SHORTAGES AROUND MENTAL HEALTH
I THINK SUPERINTENDENT BORDEN
ALLUDED TO IT IN HIS OPENING
REMARKS- BUT WE HAVE FOUND
THAT- OUR COUNTY
SUPERINTENDENTS HAVE REALLY
BEEN CREATIVE. IN COMING UP
WITH SOME- I WOULD SAY SHORT
TERM MEASURES AND LONG TERM
MEASURES TO ADDRESS SHORTAGES
AND I WOULD JUST MENTION-
FRESNO COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION FOR EXAMPLE. HAS YOU
KNOW BEEN ABLE TO FILL HUNDREDS
OF COUNSELING POSITIONS- IN
RECENT TIMES AND SO THERE ARE
EXAMPLES OF PLACES WHERE WE'VE
BEEN ABLE TO MEET THE NEED BUT
I THINK THAT WE SHOULD
ANTICIPATE. THAT THIS SECTOR
LIKE EVERY OTHER SECTOR IN OUR
WORK FORCE WILL BE IMPACTED IT
WILL NEED TO DO PLANNING AND
STRATEGIZING NOW. TO FIGURE OUT
HOW TO PROVIDE SHORT TERM NEEDS
AND TO BUILD A LONG TERM
WORKFORCE THAT WE WILL NEED
GOING FORWARD. THANK YOU FOR
THE DIRECTION TO CO ANSWER I
APPRECIATE THAT I KNOW IT'S A
CHALLENGE AND- I'LL JUST CLOSE
BY SAYING. YOU KNOW. I WANT TO
JUST GIVE ME THE REST OF THE
MEMBERS AND- SOME OF THE
CHALLENGES ARE FACED IN RURAL
AREAS IF YOU'RE IN HAPPY CAMP
WHICH IS. TYPICALLY IS ON THE%
KLAMATH RIVER IT'S IN MY
DISTRICT. IT'S NATIVE AMERICAN
HIGHEST SUICIDE RATE OF YOUNG
MAN IS NATIVE AMERICAN NINETEEN
TO TWENTY FIVE YEARS OLD. TO
GET THERE IS IT FROM PACIFIC
YEW FROM CITY COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION IS ABOUT A TWO AND A
HALF HOUR TRIP SO IF YOU IF YOU
SEND YOUR CLINICIAN OUT TO
OBSERVE. THEIR FIVE HOURS ON
THE ROAD EACH WAY BEFORE THEY
EVEN GET TO OBSERVE THE
STUDENTS AND SO THOSE ARE THE
CHALLENGES THAT ARE FACED WITH.
THROUGHOUT THE NORTHEASTERN
CALVARY I KNOW THE SENATOR
MCGUIRE'S DISTRICT AS WELL AND
SO THOSE ARE THE CHALLENGES AND
FAST BE ABLE TO FIND THOSE
FOLKS. TO START WITH SO
APPRECIATE- THOSE COMMENTS AND
I'LL BE LOOKING FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH OUR
SUPERINTENDENTS. IN OUR LOCAL
DISTRICTS AND YOU ALL AS WELL
AS TRYING TO FIND THOSE FOLKS.
TO GET OUT THERE AND ACTUALLY
DO THE WORK THAT WE NEED TO DO-
DESPERATELY FOR THESE YOUNG
PEOPLE. THANK YOU SENATOR DOLLY
CENTER GONZALEZ. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR AND I'M I WANT I
WANT TO THINK THE
SUPERINTENDENT AND MR GORDON
AND MR NAVO- FOR THIS PANEL
AND- AS WELL FOR CHAIRMAN FOR
PUTTING THIS ON- ALONG WITH
YOU- I HAVE A QUESTION AS IT
PERTAINS AND THIS MAY HAVE BEEN
ASKED TO READY SO FORGIVE ME IF
IT HAS BEEN BUT AS IT PERTAINS
TO RECRUIT THE RECRUITMENT OF.
MENTAL HEALTH- SOCIAL WORKERS
COUNSELORS WHO ARE- MULTI
LINGUAL IMMIGRATION COMPETENCE-
THAT CAN CERTAINLY WORK WITH
STUDENTS OF COLOR ESPECIALLY IN
THIS THIS AGE WHERE WE KNOW
THAT STUDENTS OF COLOR BIN YOU
KNOW HAD A LOT MORE CHALLENGES
WITH- THIS PANDEMIC- CAN YOU
DESCRIBE THAT AND HOW WE'RE
DOING WITH RECRUITMENT OR WHAT
THAT LOOKS LIKE IN SOME OF OUR
SCHOOL DISTRICTS TO GET A
BETTER IDEA. AND THEN I HAVE
ANOTHER QUESTION TO BUILD OFF
OF THAT PLEASE. I YOU KNOW IF I
COULD CENTER IS ALL THANKS TO
THE QUESTION I THINK THE SHORT
ANSWER IS OUR SYSTEM HAS TO DO
BETTER- JUST LIKE. HOW WE HAVE
TO DIVERSIFY OUR OUR OUR
EDUCATED WORKFORCE- WE HAVE TO
DIVERSIFY OUR OUR CLINICAL WORK
FORCE BUT- AGAIN I WANT TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THE TOWSON
COALITION THAT OUR OFFICE IS
PUT TOGETHER. THAT BRINGS
TOGETHER A SCHOOL PSYCHOLOGIST-
SOCIAL WORKERS- MF FEES- BRINGS
TOGETHER. EVERYONE WHO WORKS IN
A CLINICAL SPACE AND WE'VE MADE
THAT OUR TOP PRIORITY HOW DO WE
DIVERSIFY. THOSE WHO ARE. ABLE
TO PROVIDE- CLINICAL SUPPORT TO
OUR STUDENTS I WOULD SAY I
WOULD DESCRIBE AS A AS A NEED
IN A WORK IN PROGRESS- BUT WE
ARE WILLING TO WORK CLOSELY
WITH YOU SENATOR AND OTHERS- ON
THIS ET AS WE CONTINUE TO.
MOVE FORWARD AND- AS I'M
REMINDED THERE ARE MANY EFFORTS
TO DIVERSIFY THE TYPES OF
PROVIDERS WHO CAN BE HELPFUL
AND THERE ARE SOME FOLKS WHO.
WILL HAVE LICENSED PROVIDERS IN
SOME CASES WILL HAVE
PRACTITIONERS- WHO MAY BE AT
THE BACHELOR LEVEL OR WHO
APPEAR- LEVELS AND THAT THEY'LL
BE WASTING INTEGRATE MORE FOLKS
AND I BELIEVE THIS WILL ALSO
ALLOW US. TO DO A BETTER JOB OF
DIVERSIFYING- THE COUNCIL
WORKFORCE. THE ANSWER AND SAID
LET LET ME JUST ADD THAT I
THINK. IN THE END WE ALSO HAVE
TO WORK MUCH HARDER TO GROW OUR
OWN WE HAVE OUR CAREER
TECHNICAL EDUCATION PROGRAMS
BUT WE'VE BEEN WORKING LOCALLY.
TO FIGURE OUT WAYS TO INTEREST
YOUNG PEOPLE IN GOING INTO
THESE FIELDS BUT MORE THAN
THAT. TO PROVIDE THEM SUPPORT
AS THEY NAVIGATE THROUGH GOING
THROUGH- A COMMUNITY COLLEGE
INTO A FOUR YEAR COLLEGE INTO
THE LICENSING PROGRAMS THEY
WILL NEED SUPPORT THEY WILL
NEED FINANCIAL SUPPORT. IN THE
FORM OF JOBS AND INTERNSHIPS
AND I THINK WE CAN DO THAT IF
WE ORGANIZE IF WE ORGANIZED THE
SYSTEM AND APPRENTICESHIPS. IN
THOSE SORTS OF AVENUES I THINK
I THINK WE CAN GET IT DONE IF
WE'RE IF WE'RE FOCUSED AND JOB.
WE'VE GOT SOME INITIAL SUCCESS
SO FAR. THANK YOU COMMISSIONER
AND I HAVE ONE MORE QESTION IT
JUST A PERTAINS TO KIND OF
BUILDING OFF OF THAT YOU KNOW
IN IN LONG BEACH THAT I
REPRESENT A VERY DIVERSE I'VE
GOT ONE OF THE LARGEST. I
ALWAYS TALK ABOUT THE CAMBODIAN
COMMUNITIES AND SO AND LIKE TO
KNOW- THE EFFORTS TO
DISAGGREGATE THE DATA FOR API
COMMUNITY BECAUSE- FOR THE
CAMBODIAN COMMUNITY THEY'RE
VERY UNIQUE CHALLENGES AND IN
WHICH- ANOTHER CONSTANTLY
ASKING FOR MENTAL HEALTH
SUPPORT NOT ONLY FOR STUDENTS
BUT FOR THEIR- PARENTS. BUT
THIS IS WHERE THE IMMIGRATION
REFUGEE COMPENSATES COMPETENCY
THE CULTURAL COMPETENCE COMES
IN TO BE ABLE TO SUPPORT THEM.
SO I'M WONDERING- HOW WE ARE.
THAT IF OUR EFFORTS TO
DISAGGREGATE THE DATA IS OUR
SUCCESSFUL AND HOW WE'RE SORT
OF LOOKING AT THE API COMMUNITY
IN THAT IN THAT SENSE TO BE
ABLE TO PROVIDE THEM THE-
CUSTOMIZABLE AT THAT THEY NEED.
WHO WOULD LIKE TO TAKE A STAB
AT THAT- I'LL I'LL TAKE IT AND
JUST SAY THAT- YOU KNOW I'M
GONNA BE ASKING MY TEAM TO HELP
US COME UP WITH SOME- A FEW
STATISTICS THAT WE CAN SHARE
WITH YOU. BEFORE THE END OF
THIS HEARING- JUST KNOW THAT
THERE HAVE BEEN SEVERAL EFFORTS
TO FOCUS ON DISAGGREGATED DATA
IN EDUCATION THEY HAVEN'T ALL
BEEN MENTAL HEALTH SPECIFIC-
BUT THERE ARE SOME- THERE ARE
SOME MENTAL HEALTH COALITIONS
THAT ARE FOCUSED ON. A RACIAL
AND ETHNIC JUSTICE AND THERE'S
AN INCREDIBLE COALITION ON THAT
WE WORK WITH IN SACRAMENTO-
THAT DOES THIS WORK IT WILL
HELP US I THINK THROUGH- YOU
KNOW HOW WE JUST AGGREGATE THE
DATA. AND THEN IN GENERAL
SENATOR I THINK IT YOU'RE
POINTING TO WE NEED MORE
CULTURALLY COMPETENT- WAYS TO
DELIVER- MENTAL HEALTH SUPPORTS
IN THE WAY MENTAL HEALTH IS
DELIVERED HAS TO BE VERY
DIFFERENT- FOR MANY COMMUNITIES
AND- I KNOW THAT- YOU'VE GOT
GREAT PANELS HERE IN ALICE
RISCO AND DOCTOR WOULD SOON
WHO. WILL BE ABLE TO SPEAK ON
SOME OF THIS WITH MORE DETAIL
BUT OUR OFFICE WILL WORK TO GET
A FEW MORE POINTS SO WE CAN
SHARE BEFORE THE CONCLUSION OF
THIS YEAR. THANK YOU
SUPERINTENDENT I APPRECIATE IT
LOOK FOR TO WORKING WITH YOU.
AND SAYING WE LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH YOU THANK YOU FOR
RAISING THE ISSUE. THANK YOU
SENATOR GONZALES WE'RE GONNA GO
TO SENATOR CORTESE THEN SENATOR
ROSS. TURNER CORTESE. THANK YOU
VENTURE- THE MISSISSIPPI
ATTENDED- IT INTO EVEN
ANSWERING A SIMILAR QUESTION TO
WHAT I'M GOING TO ASK IN IN IN
VARIOUS WAYS HERE BUT- ON THE
VERY VERY POSITIVE SIDE. AND
I'M SURE YOU'RE AWARE OF THIS
GIVEN YOUR- BUT GIVEN
EVERYTHING YOU SAID IN YOUR-
EXCELLENT COMMUNICATION
PROTOCOL WITH THE COUNTY
OFFICES ON THE COUNTY OFFICE IN.
WELCOME VALUES IN KERR COUNTY-
RECENT RECEIVED ELEVEN MILLION
DOLLARS IN MH SSA FUNDS AND
THEY'VE GOT ABOUT ANOTHER SIX
MILLION DOLLARS THAT THEY'RE
ANTICIPATING THE NEXT COUPLE OF
MONTHS WHICH PUTS. ELEVEN
WELLNESS CENTERS IN ELEVEN.
UNIQUE DISTRICTS SCHOOL
DISTRICTS ARE THIRTY ONE
DISTRICTS DOWN THERE-
FORTUNATELY OR UNFORTUNATELY.
THE QUESTION- ALL MY MIND IS.
WITH TWO FOLD ONE WHO WILL BE
MONITORING- THE READY NESS FOR
ADDITIONAL DOLLARS- ALL OF THAT
THE QUESTION COURSE ANTICIPATES
THAT THERE WILL BE A WAY AT
SOME POINT TO. CONTINUE TO GROW
AND AUGMENT. THE SUFFERED- EVEN
INCLUDING IT IN THE NEXT BUDGET
CYCLE. BUT WHO WHO WILL BE
RESPONSIBLE FOR THAT IT SOUNDS
LIKE. GIVEN WHAT YOU SAID ABOUT
THE KIND THE QUALITY OF DATA
THAT YOU'RE GETTING IN THE
QUALITY OF COMMUNICATION THAT
YOU HAVE. WITH THE VARIOUS
COUNTY OFFICES- THAT YOU'RE IN
A UNIQUE POSITION TO. INFORM
THE NEED FOR THE READING OF THE
READINESS AND THE NEED. FOR
ADDITIONAL DOLLARS TO SUPPORT
GROWTH AND WE'VE TALKED ABOUT
MY COLLEAGUES WHO TALKED. IF T.
IAN STAFFING IN. A QUALIFIED
PERSONAL CRITICAL PERSONNEL.
BUT SOME OF THESE SOME OF THESE-
COUNTY'S COUNTY OFFICES
INCLUDING. THE ONE IN MY
DISTRICT THAT REPRESENTS THAT
AREA. THEY'RE READY NOW TO KEEP
GROWING IN IN IN SO THE SECOND
PART OF MY QUESTION IS BESIDES
WHO WHO WILL BE MONITORING THAT
INFORMING. THE LEGISLATURE AND
THE EXECUTIVE BRANCH- IS IT. IS
IT IS IT LIKELY OR ISIT
ALREADY PART OF THE SYSTEM THAT
THOSE WHO WERE- READY COMMAND
WILL BE ELIGIBLE TO GO
REGARDLESS OF YOU KNOW THE
TYPICAL- GEOGRAPHIC EQUITY
CONCERNS THAT WE WOULD WE WOULD
HAVE IN THAT I CERTAINLY VALUE-
THIS SEEMS LIKE ONE OF THOSE
SITUATIONS WHERE- GIVEN. THE
GRAVITY OF THE CIRCUMSTANCES-
WE NEED TO BE KEEP FEEDING AND
FUELING- HERE THE INTERVENTION-
KIND OF WORK THAT'S GOING ON IT
WHICH IS SO OFTEN A LIFE AND
DEATH PROPOSITION AMONG OUR
YOUNG PEOPLE. AND AND SO I
GUESS MY OPINION IS THAT WE
SHOULD BE. WE SHOULD BE- YOU
KNOW AGAIN FUNDING IN FUELING
WITH INVESTMENT DOLLARS- THE
GROWTH OF FOR THOSE WHO PERHAPS
HAD A HEAD START WHO ALREADY
HAD SOME INFRASTRUCTURE IN
PLACE BUT- BUT ARE READY TO
KEEP GROWING AND KEEP
PROTECTING YOUNG PEOPLE WHO
JUST LIKE YOUR COMMENTS ON THAT
AND REALLY TO EDUCATE ME ON ON
HOW THAT SYSTEM WILL WORK GOING
FORWARD IN TERMS OF. WHAT THE
WHAT THE OVERRIDING CRITERIA IS
GEOGRAPHIC EQUITY OR THOSE WHO
ARE READY TO GO GO NOW. THANKS
FOR THE QUESTION CENTER AND-
IT'S COMPLEX AND DIFFICULT BUT
I'M GONNA SPEAK PLAIN AND TELL
YOU SOME PLACES WHERE I THINK
THERE'S GOOD OPPORTUNITY AND
WHETHER SOME CHALLENGES HAT WE
NEED TO MANAGE AND STRATEGIZE
BECAUSE AS YOU MENTIONED THE
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES ACT
BONDS I REMIND FULL OF THE FACT
THAT- THOSE GREAT PROGRAMS.
GREW OUT OF YOUR CHAMBER GREW
OUT OF THE SENATE- AND-
CONTINUE TO LIVE ON WITH US-
BUT THEY HAD BEEN- YOU KNOW
PRIOR TO NOW BOTTLENECKS FOR
SOME COUNTIES AND IT'S BEEN
HARD TO MOVE THOSE DOLLARS-
IT'S BEEN HARD TO MOVE SOME OF
THOSE DOLLARS THE COMMUNITY
PRIOR TO THE END AND I THINK
WE'RE SEEING. GREAT MOVEMENT
NOW AND I THINK WHAT WE NEED TO
RECOGNIZE IS THAT A LOT OF WHAT
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT HIS MENTAL
HEALTH DOLLARS THEIR FOCUS ON
SCHOOLS BUT THAT'S NOT THE ONLY
WAY THAT STUDENTS AND THEIR
FAMILIES ACCESS MENTAL HEALTH
YEAH WE HAVE BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
ALLIANCE IN EVERY COUNTY HAS A
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH. ORGANIZATION
WE NEED TO PARTNER WITH THEM SO
GRADE AND- BLAND TOGETHER EVERY
SINGLE DOLLAR- THAT'S AVAILABLE
BECAUSE AS I POINTED OUT A LOT
OF THE MONEY THAT WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT RIGHT NOW IS ONE TIME
MONEY YEAH AND I THINK WE'LL GO
I THINK WE'LL BUILD STRONG
SYSTEMS BUT WE MAY ONLY GET A
LIFT FOR FEW YEARS UNLESS YOU
BUILD THE RIGHT KIND OF SYSTEM.
THAT CARRIES US BEYOND THE
INITIAL THREE OR FOUR YEAR-
THAT I THINK THESE DOLLARS CAN
PROVIDE INVESTMENT FOR I WOULD
SAY THAT EVERY COUNTY IS READY
TO RECEIVE THE FINANCIAL
SUPPORT OUR OFFICE WILL WORK
WITH EACH OF THE FIFTY EIGHT
COUNTY OFFICES AND EVERY SCHOOL
DISTRICT TO RECEIVE THEIR
AMOUNT OF DOLLARS THAT THEY
SHOULD BE RECEIVING ACCORDING.
TO YOU KNOW FORMAL- YOU KNOW
LOCAL CONTROL FORMULA L. LOKS
COOL FUNDING FORMULA AND SO-
THERE ARE SOME ABILITIES TO
MONITOR THAT SPENDING BUT I'M
GONNA BE FRANK WITH YOU SENATOR
MANY DISTRICTS HAVE SAID THAT
NOT JUST IN RELATION TO MENTAL
HEALTH. BUT IN TERMS OF ALL THE
DOLLARS COMING THEIR WAY. SOME
DISTRICTS HAVE SAID THEY'RE NOT
SURE- EXACTLY HOW DO YOU LOOK.
SOME OF THESE DUMB. A GROUP A
GREAT DEAL OF THAT IS OUT OF
CONCERN ABOUT THE ONE TIME
NATURE. OF THE MONEY WE
ACTUALLY PUT ON. A WE HAVE TO
PUT ON A TRAINING JUST A FEW
WEEKS AGO WE INVITED EVERY
DISTRICT IN THE STATE TO
PARTICIPATE IN. WHERE THE FOCUS
WAS ON HOW TO UTILIZE SOME OF
THESE NEW STATE DOLLARS AND WE
BROUGHT ON SEVERAL DISTRICTS
THAT HAVE ALREADY BUILT MENTAL
HEALTH PROGRAMS SO THEY CAN BE
SPOTLIGHTS- FOR OTHERS THAT ARE
BEGINNING. TO BUILD THEM WE
HAVE SCHOOL DISTRICTS LIKE TO
LIST- ELEMENTARY SCHOOL
DISTRICT WHICH HAS A SCHOOL
PSYCHOLOGIST IN EVERY SINGLE
ONE OF THEIR SCHOOLS EITHER A
SCHOOL PSYCHOLOGIST OR SOCIAL
WORKER. OR SOMEONE WITH A
CLINICAL BACKGROUND THAT IS NOT
TYPICAL FOR ALL OF OUR
DISTRICTS. AND BUT WE WANT TO
BUILD THAT KIND OF A SYSTEM AND
SO- THE DOLLARS WILL BE MOVING.
THE FOCUS WILL HAVE TO BE ON
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT AND
TRAINING. OUR OFFICE WILL BE
ONE OF THE STANDS TO HELP AND
TO DO THAT OBVIOUSLY THE MENTAL
HEALTH. ADVISORY AND OVERSIGHT
COMMITTEE WILL HELP WITH THAT
AND THEN OF COURSE THE ENTIRE
INFRASTRUCTURE AROUND THE
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES.
DEPARTMENT THE STATE'S HEALTH
AND HUMAN SERVICES DEPARTMENT
WILL HELP YOU BUILD THAT WE ARE
WE ARE HAVING TO BUILD A
SYSTEM. AND WE'RE GOING TO HAVE
TO SYNCHRONIZE IN TRIAGE SO TO
SPEAK. WITH OUR BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH SYSTEMS- ONE TO FIGURE
OUT EVERY DOLLAR- HOW THEY GET
MAXIMIZE. AND TO MAKE SURE THAT
ALL THE SYSTEMS ARE INTEGRATED
AND HOW THEY'RE MOVING FORWARD.
WHAT WHAT WILL HELP IS THAT THE
STATE HAS MADE THREE BILLION
AVAILABLE FOR COMMUNITY SCHOOLS
SO IT'LL BE WRAP AROUND
SUPPORTS. IN SCHOOLS HAVE SOME
EXPERIENCE AROUND USING
COMMUNITY SCHOOLS. AND SOME
HAVE EXPERIENCE WITH MENTAL
HEALTH BUT MANY DO NOT HAVE
EXPERIENCE WITH MEDICARE NOW IN
MANY DON'T HAVE EXPERIENCE IN
THE QUESTION. AROUND THE
RECRUITMENT AND THERE IS NO
SINGLE AGENCY WHAT'S UP THAT IS
THE POINT OF RESPONSIBILITY.
FOR BUILDING THAT WORK FORCE
BUT IT WILL BE UP TO. SO IN MY-
AND I TEAM AT THE- OF EDUCATION
SUPERINTENDENT GORDON AND MR
NAVAJO AND THE FOLKS AT THE
MAIN OFFICE OVERSTEP BY THE
OVERSIGHT COMMITTEE ALL OF US.
TO PULL TOGETHER OUR PARTNERS.
HOW TO BUILD THE SYSTEM- THAT
WE NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
HAVE THE SUSTAINABILITY OF FOR
HOW WE DO THIS- BUT THE DOLLARS
ARE MOVING NOW- TO SCHOOL
DISTRICTS- WILL BE PROVIDING
TRAINING ON HOW AND TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE. ON HOW TO DO
COMMUNITY SCHOOLS AND I WILL BE
WORKING WITH ALL THOSE PARTNERS
THE POOL TOGETHER THE
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH- YOU KNOW
AGENCIES- AND OTHER STATE
AGENCIES ALL ACROSS THE STATE
SO WE CAN BUILD A SUSTAINABLE
SYSTEM. FOR DOING THIS WORK.
SENATOR LET LET ME LET ME JUST
BUILD ON- SUPERINTENDENT
GOVERNMENT'S REMARKS BECAUSE I
THINK HE'S RIGHT I THINK HE'S
RIGHT ON TARGET- THE STATE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH
CARE SERVICES WILL BE INVOLVED
IN WORKING ON MAJOR INITIATIVES
TO WORK WITH THE MANAGED CARE
PROVIDERS. THERE ARE SO MANY
OTHER INITIATIVES AT THE STATE
LEVEL FROM THE FUNDING YOU
APPROPRIATELY. OUR SYSTEM IS
VERY VERY COMPLICATED AND ONE
OF THE THINGS HE DID. WAS
AUTHORIZED THE- MHS ALWAYS SEE
TO MAKE SURE EVERY SINGLE
COUNTY HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY
FOR- ROBOTS SCHOOL COUNTY
PARTNERSHIP. BECAUSE THOSE
PARTNERSHIPS AT THE LOCAL
LEVEL. ARE THE KEY TO HELPING
THE FARMS FLOW SMOOTHLY AT THE
LOCAL LEVEL BUT ALSO TO DEAL
WITH THE QUESTION. OF
SUSTAINABILITY WHICH WORRIES
SCHOOL PEOPLE SO MUCH SO I
THINK THAT WILL THAT WILL COME
INTO PLACE AND THAT WILL BE A
GREAT HELP. BECAUSE I THINK THE
COUNTIES THAT. ARE BLESSED TO
HAVE RIGHT NOW STRONG LIKE LIKE
IN OUR COUNTY STRONG LOCAL
SCHOOL. COUNTY PARTNERSHIPS ARE
MUCH BETTER ABLE TO MOVE MONEY
AND- AND INNOVATE. USING THE
EXISTING RESEARCH COURSES AND
DEVELOP THE. DIVORCE EXPANDABLE
RESOURCES. THANK YOU FOR THE
CHAIR OF MAJOR. FOR WEAPONS
JUST- I PRE VERY THE
THOROUGHNESS OF THE RESPONSES-
AND- YOU KNOW IN IN. THE I
APPRECIATE VERY MUCH SO
SUPERINTENDENTS. USE OF TOOL
THIS IS AN EXAMPLE I DO
REPRESENT I DO NOT REPRESENT
THAT AREA BUT- WHEN I WAS
TRYING TO SAY IS I REPRESENT AN
AREA. OF SIMILAR CAPACITY- AN
AREA WHERE. THE COMMUNITY
SCHOOLS PROGRAM WHICH IS CALLED
SCHOOLING SERVICES GOES BACK-
IN ITS FIRST ITERATION ALL THE
WAY TO AND PETE WILSON WAS
GOVERNOR THAT'S HOW LONG THE
PROGRAMS IN PLACE. SO MY
CONCERN IS I JUST WANNA MAKE
SURE FROM A AN APPROPRIATION
STANDPOINT. THE PERHAPS A
LEGISLATIVE STANDPOINT PERHAPS
IT'S JUST. A LEGISLATIVE
BUDGETARY STANDPOINT COMING
INTO THE NEXT FISCAL YEAR. THAT
WE- MAKE SURE THAT WE ARE
INCREASING FUNDING TO THE CHULA
VISTA AS- IN THE SANTA CLARA
COUNTIES OF THE WORLD WHO HAD
THE SIMPLE STRUCTURE IN PLACE.
TO MAKE SURE THAT THEY HAVE THE
CERTAINTY IN THE CAPACITY. TO
MAKE THOSE COMMITMENTS TO
CONTINUE GROWING THEIR PROGRAM.
BUT WHILE WE ARE PATIENTLY
WORKING WITH THE DISTRICTS THAT
AREN'T READY- YOU KNOW ONGOING
TRAINING AND GETTING THEM. TO
STAND UP THEIR PROGRAMS I DON'T
WANT THE PROGRAMS THAT WERE
TRYING TO STAND UP SLOW DOWN
THE FLOW OF MONEY COMING IN.
FOR THOSE THAT HAVE BEEN READY.
FOR A LONG TIME TO CONTINUE
GROWING SO- SHEET AGAIN- ABOUT
ASKING FOR IT. RESPONSE BUT- I
GUESS SOME KIND OF TELEGRAPHING
WHAT I EXPECT TO BE. ADVOCATING
FOR- YOU KNOW GOING FORWARD IN
OUR OWN BUDGET PROCESS THANK
YOU. THANK YOU SENATOR CORTESE
THAT'S WHY I SAY YOU HAVE AN
INCREDIBLE- SUPERINTENDENT IN
SANTA CLARA COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION WHO IS VERY FOCUSED
ON. YOU KNOW WHOLE CHILD
SUPPORT'S WILL WORK CLOSELY
WITH THE SUPERINTENDENT THERE
WE UNDERSTAND AS WE'RE AS WE'RE
EVEN IN THIS HEARING OUR TEAM
HAS BEEN SENDING ME
INFORMATION. THAT ONE OF THE
NEEDS FOR A SANTA CLARA COUNTY
IN GENERAL IS ADDRESSING THE
ISSUE OF COMMERCIAL INSURANCE
AND SO WE WILL PUT A SPOTLIGHT
ON THAT NEED WORK CLOSELY WITH.
YOUR OFFICE IN THE SANTA CLARA
COUNTY OFFICE OF EDUCATION ON
HOW WE MAKE SURE EVERYTHING'S
READY TO STAND UP- IN SENECA
COUNTY. THANK YOU THANK YOU MR%
SUPERINTENDENT THANK YOU
SENATOR CORTESE SENATOR ROTH.
THANK YOU- YOU KNOW I SKETCHED
A LITTLE QUESTION AS MY
COLLEAGUE WAS ASKING HIS I'LL
PROBABLY ASK IT BUT I'LL I'LL
PROBABLY DEVIATE FROM IT GIVEN
THE RESPONSE AND I THINK WE
NEED TO RECOGNIZE THAT OUR
SCHOOL DISTRICTS AROUND THE
STATE OR NOT. AND REALLY
SHOULDN'T BE MENTAL HEALTH
TREATMENT FACILITIES YOU HAVE
ENOUGH TO DO EDUCATING STUDENTS
AND THERE ARE CERTAIN MENTAL
HEALTH RELATED EDUCATIONAL
ISSUES THAT OUR PROPOSAL
APPROPRIATELY DEALT WITH ON A
SCHOOL CAMPUS BUT THEN THERE
ARE OTHER ISSUES THAT REALLY
NEED TO BE TRIAGED AND DIVERTED
TO OTHER TREATMENTS- RESOURCE
IS MY QUESTION THAT I WAS GOING
TO ASK AND I'LL ASK IT YOU KNOW
DO WE HAVE A SPECIFIC INTER
AGENCY PLANT A TREE- STUDENT
MENTAL HEALTH. ISSUES ON CAMPUS
AND EFFICIENTLY STEER THOSE
WITH MENTAL HEALTH RELATED
EDUCATIONAL ISSUES TO SCHOOL
COUNSELORS AND OTHER RELATED
MENTAL HEALTH PERSONNEL ON
CAMPUS AND THEN FOR THOSE WITH
A MODERATE- MENTAL HEALTH
ISSUES STEER THOSE TO OUR
MEDICAL PROVIDERS OF COMMERCIAL
INSURANCE PROVIDERS TO THE
EXTENT THAT'S APPROPRIATE AND
THEN THOSE WITH THE MOST
SERIOUS CASES TO THE COUNTIES.
I'M I'M I GATHER WE DON'T HAVE
A SPECIFIC PLAN I'M NOT SURE
THAT IT'S REALLY A GOOD IDEA TO
LEAVE IT UP TO THE INDIVIDUAL
SCHOOL DISTRICTS. AND I'M
WONDERING WHAT YOUR THOUGHTS
ARE I MEAN I WOULD SEEM TO ME
THAT WE WOULD NEED TO. INVOLVE
OUR MEDICAL PROVIDERS AND TO
THE EXTENT THAT WE COULD ENTICE
THEM ARE COMMERCIAL PROVIDERS.
TO PERHAPS PLACE PERSONNEL IN
DISTRICTS ARE CERTAINLY IN
COUNTY OFFICES TO HELP. WITH
THE TRIAGE EFFORT. TO MAKE SURE
THAT THOSE. STUDENTS WHO ARE
NOT ENROLLED IN MEDICARE ALL
WHO ARE APPROPRIATE RECIPIENTS
ARE SO AND ROLLED IN TO THE
EXTENT THAT THEY HAVE
COMMERCIAL INSURANCE THAT
PROVIDES MENTAL HEALTH COVERAGE
FOR THE MORE MODERATE. TO
SEVERE CASES THAT WE GET THOSE
STUDENTS. TO THE APPROPRIATE
TREATMENT PROVIDERS EFFICIENTLY
EFFECTIVELY AND- AS QUICKLY AS
POSSIBLE SO I I'D LIKE YOUR
THOUGHTS ON THAT. SUPERINTENDED
TOUR OR THE OTHER PANELISTS.
SENATOR RON THANKS FOR THE
QUESTIONS THAT I START WERE YOU
STARTED I AGREE WITH YOU
SCHOOLS ARE NOT NECESSARILY
MEANT TO BE MENTAL HEALTH
PROVIDERS- OUR SCHOOLS OUR
TEACHERS AND OTHER STAFF
THEY'RE THERE TO HELP SUPPORT
THE EDUCATIONAL NEEDS OF OUR
STUDENTS. ABOUT WHAT WE'VE
LEARNED THOUGH IS THAT SCHOOLS
CAN PLAY A KEY ROLE- IN BEING A
PORTAL FOR HELPING STUDENTS TO
GET SUPPORTED IN ONE OF THE
TRAINING AS A GUEST PROVIDED
FOR SCHOOLS IS A- A TRAINING
CALLED NOW HEALTH FIRST AID.
YEAH AND IT IS A TRAINING THAT
ALLOWS EDUCATORS TO LEARN HOW
TO RECOGNIZE SIGNS WHEN A
REFERRAL NEEDS TO BE MADE OR
STUDENT NEEDS TO BE CONNECTED
TO A SOCIAL WORKER OR TO A
COUNSELOR- AND SO THERE ARE
WAYS TO DO THAT YOU RAISE A
GOOD POINT- THAT WE HAVE TO
BUILD OUT YOU KNOW THE RIGHT
KINDS OF SYSTEMS. AND YOU KNOW
OUT I CAN ONLY SPEAK ABOUT WHAT
MY EXPERIENCE HAS BEEN I SPENT
FIVE YEARS WORKING IN A SCHOOL
BASED MENTAL HEALTH
ORGANIZATION THAT IS A PARTNER
TO A SCHOOL DISTRICT AND I HAVE
TO SAY THAT MY EXPERIENCE WAS
ONE. WHERE IT BURIED BY
DISTRICT HOW REFERRALS GOT MADE
AND WHAT SERVICES WERE IN PLACE
AND SOME DID BETTER THAN OTHERS
YOU'RE ABSOLUTELY RIGHT SO WE
HAVE TO BUILD A KIND OF SYSTEM
THAT RECOGNIZES- THAT HOW TO
RECOGNIZE NEEDS AND HOW TO GET
STUDENTS TO THE RIGHT LEVEL. OF
CARE I WOULD JUST SAY THAT
THERE ARE SO MANY- SCHOOL BASED
PARTNERS WHO SUPPORT OUR
SCHOOLS IN DOING THIS IN
ADDITION TO OUR SCHOOL BASED
STAFF AND A BIG SHOUT OUT TO
ALL OF OUR SCHOOL PSYCHOLOGIST
OUR SCHOOL SOCIAL WORKERS ARE
NURSES- ALL THE FOLKS WHO WORK
DIRECTLY WITH OUR STUDENTS ARE
BEHAVIORIST- YOU KNOW OUR
SPECIAL EDUCATION STAFF. THEY
DO INCREDIBLE WORK AND YOU'RE
RIGHT WE HAVE TO BUILD THE
SYSTEM THAT MAKES THE DELIVERY
HAPPENED INCONSISTENT WAYS AND
WE HAVE TO BUILD A SYSTEM THAT
MAKES ALL OF OUR MENTAL HEALTH
SYSTEMS TALKTO EACH OTHER WORK.
TOGETHER CLOSE TO A FAMILY IT'S
SHOULD MATTER A FAMILY SHOULD
GET PUSH AROUND INSTEAD- NO
YOUR MEDIC OUT OR- NO YOU HAVE
PRIVATE HEALTH INSURANCE. TO
THE FAMILY THAT YOU JUST KNOW
WHAT DOOR I GO THROUGH TO GET
WHAT I NEED YEAH WE DO HAVE
WORKED TO BUILD OUT THOSE
SYSTEMS AGAIN. SECRETARY GALLEY
HAS OUTWEIGHED A VISION FOR HOW
TO BUILD A SYSTEM THAT GETS
PRIVATE HEALTH INSURANCE IS
WORKING ALONGSIDE MEDI CAL. AND
OUR OFFICE WILL I'M SURE AND
ALONG WITH THE MICHAEL
PANELISTS WILL ALL BE WORKING
TOGETHER TO HELP. BUILD OUT
THOSE SYSTEMS- TO MAKE SURE
THAT- THERE'S A CLEAR DOOR TO
GO THROUGH TO GET THE SERVICE
THAT YOU NEED- WITHOUT ANYBODY
HAVING TO. WORRY ABOUT LOSS WHO
PAYS- BECAUSE THAT DOESN'T
MATTER TO SOMEONE WHO HAS A
NEED OUR KIDS ARE COMING BACK
TO SCHOOL AND THEY'RE WORRIED
ABOUT KOBE. OR THEY'RE FEELING
STRESSED FROM WHAT'S HAPPENED
IN THEIR HOUSEHOLD- LOST A LOVE
ONE SOMEONE'S LOST A JOB- MAYBE
EVEN HAD TO RELOCATE THEIR
STRESS AND SO ALL WE WANT OUR
STUDENTS AND FAMILIES. AND OUR
STAFF TO BE ABLE TO DO IS
ACCESS THE RIGHT LEVEL OF CARE
AND- SO WE'VE GOT WORK TO DO TO
BUILD UP THAT SYSTEM BUT WE
WILL FOLLOW YOUR DIRECTOR
SENATOR. INTO WORKING TO BUILD
THAT OUT. THANK YOU I LOOK
FORWARD TO. FOLLOWING UP WITH
YOU AND THE REST ON THIS NEXT
YEAR BUT THE ONE COMMON
DENOMINATOR ACROSS OUR STATE
AND ACROSS OUR- COUNTY OFFICES
OF EDUCATION IN OUR SCHOOL
DISTRICTS IS. OUR MEDICAL
SYSTEM. AND IT WOULD SEEM TO ME
THAT THAT'S THE ONE SYSTEM THAT
WE DO HAVE A LITTLE CONTROL
OVER. AND WE HAVE TO FIGURE OUT
A WAY HOW TO INCENTIVIZE OUR
MEDICAL PROVIDERS ON BOTH
SIDES. TO A PLACE WHETHER
WHETHER WE CALL THEM NAVIGATORS
ARE OTHER PERSONNEL ON OUR
SCHOOL CAMPUSES. TO HELP STEER
STUDENTS WHO ARE APPROPRIATELY.
OF SHOULD BE OR ARE IN THE
MEDICAL SYSTEM TO MENTAL HEALTH
TREATMENT. THROUGH THAT MEDICAL
SYSTEMS SO I LOOK FORWARD TO
SEEING WHAT YOU AND- INDUCT
KELLY AND THE REST PUT TOGETHER
BUT THANK YOU FOR YOUR EFFORTS
AS THIS IS A CRITICAL. ISSUE
THAT NEEDS TO BE ADDRESSED AND
ADDRESS NOW. THANK YOU SENATOR
OFTEN IF YOU HAVE THE- TO HEAR
FROM THE PALACE ALEX BRISCOE. I
THINK HE'S ONE OF THE FOREMOST
EXPERTS ON. MEDICARE HOW IN
SCHOOL BASED HEALTH AND MENTAL
HEALTH. AND SHE HELPED US PUT
TOGETHER A PIECE OF LEGISLATION
THAT ULTIMATELY BECAME-
EMBEDDED IN STATE BUDGET. THAT
TEACHES SCHOOL DISTRICTS HOW TO
UTILIZE MEDICARE OUT YOU KNOW
IT'S LIKE A IT IS IT'S A IT'S A
IT'S AN EXPERIENCE IN A
LANGUAGE UNTO ITSELF. TO KNOW
HOW TO DO MEDICAL BILLING BUT
IT IS A RELIABLE SOURCE OF
FUNDING FOR MEDICAL. MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES. AND IT IS YOU
KNOW AS YOU KNOW SENATOR IT IS
A FEDERAL ENTITLEMENT. THAT
MEANS THAT MEANS THAT WHEN OUR
STATE DOLLARS RUN LOW BECAUSE
OF OUR ECONOMIC CHANGES DOWN
THE ROAD. THE FEDERAL
ENTITLEMENT CONTINUES TO BE
AVAILABLE BUT CALIFORNIA HAS TO
DRAW DOWN MORE OF IT WE- WE
DRAW DOWN A SMALLER AMOUNT OF
IT GIVEN OUR SIZE AND OUR-
BRANCH. BUT IF WE FOLLOW THE
PLANS OF PEOPLE LIKE ALEX
CRISCO HAVE. IN OUR SECRETARY
OF HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES
DOCTOR MARK GALLI I FORESEE
THAT WE'RE GONNA MAXIMIZE MEDI
CAL- AND THAT MEANS GREAT
SERVICE FOR CALIFORNIA'S. WE
LOOK FOR TO WORK WITH YOU
SENATOR THANK YOU SENATOR.
THANK YOU MISTER SEA. THANK YOU
SENATOR RALPH AND THANK YOU ALL
SENATORS FOR YOUR QUESTIONS
THANK YOU SO MUCH TO OUR PANEL
MEMBERS. MISTER CHAIR NEWMAN
I'M GONNA TURN IT BACK TO YOU.
THANK YOU SENATOR LEVIN AND
THANK YOU TO OUR PANELISTS. MR
GORDON SUPERINTENDENT THURMAN-
TO MR NAVA THANK THANK YOU FOR
YOUR INSIGHT THAT AND THANK YOU
FOR MAKING THE TIME TODAY. AND
INTO CENTER IS PART THANK YOU
TO MY COLLEAGUES FOR THIS
INSIGHTFUL QUESTIONS. I WOULD
POINT OUT THAT THAT MANY OF
THOSE QUESTIONS ARE OF
RELEVANCE- TO THE SPHERES OF
SOME OF THE SECOND PANEL SO
THAT AS YOU. AS WE MOVE FORWARD
PLEASE PANELS KEEP SALLY'S
QUESTION MY PARTICULARLY I
SENATOR GLACIERS QUESTION ABOUT
MEASURING SUCCESS. CENTER
DOLLARS QUESTION THAT STAFFING-
SYRACUSE ALWAYS QUESTION THAT
DIVERSIFICATION OF THE
WORKPLACE. AND TO THE SUPER
TENNIS QUESTION ABOUT. HOW TO
STAIN- PROGRESS GIVEN SOME OF.
THESE INSTANCES IN ONE TIME
FUNDING. THE- I'D ALSO SPEAKING
OF TREE I SHOULD LIKE MY FOLKS
THAT WE'RE GONNA BE PRESSED FOR
TIME- IT'S ELEVEN O'CLOCK WE
HEART STOP. AT NOON NOT SURE
WHICH MOVE MOVE INTO THE NEXT
TWO PANELS- I DIED I DIDN'T
FIGHT YOUR INSIGHT BUT ALSO
ENCOURAGE YOU. TO BE CONCISE-
PARTICULARLY AMONG MY
COLLEAGUES- AND NOW WE WILL
MOVE ON TO THE SECOND PANEL- IN
WHICH WE'LL DISCUSS EXPANDED
LEARNING OPPORTUNITIES FOR
STUDENT RE ENGAGEMENT THROUGH
THE PANDEMICS THAT TODAY WE'RE
GOING TO HEAR FROM A PANEL OF
ACCOMPLISHED SCHOOL LEADERS.
COUNCILLORS AND COMMUNITY
PARTNERS ABOUT THEIR RESPECTIVE
EFFORTS TO RE ENGAGE STUDENTS
AND THEIR FAMILIES INCLUDING
HARD TO REACH STUDENT
POPULATIONS AS THEY WORK TO
HELP THEM. EMERGE FROM THE
PANDEMIC READY TO LEARN AND
THRIVE WILL HEAR FIRST FROM THE
SUPERINTENDENTS OF ONE OF THE
SCHOOL DISTRICT IN MY STATE
SENATE DISTRICT DIRECTOR JOANNE
CULVERHOUSE. WHO LEADS THE LA
HABRA CITY SCHOOL DISTRICT IN
HER TESTIMONY DOCTOR CONGRESS
WILL DESCRIBE HER DISTRICT'S.
INNOVATIVE SUMMER PROGRAMMING
EFFORTS AS WELL AS THEIR ON
GOING EFFORTS TO ADDRESS THE
SOCIAL EMOTIONAL HEALTH OF
THEIR STUDENTS DURING THIS
DIFFICULT TIME. IN TERMS OF
SCALING UP THEIR STAFF TO
HANDLE THE CHALLENGES PRSENTED
BY THE INTENSE SCOPE. OF THE
CURRENT NEEDS. THEN WE'LL HEAR
FROM DR LORETTA WHICH AN EXEC
DIRECTOR OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF SCHOOL
COUNSELORS. WHO PROVIDE HER
PERSPECTIVE. GAINED THROUGH
REPRESENTING PRACTITIONERS WHO-
WORKING SO CHARLES TIRELESS TO
HELP STUDENTS. IN THE DISENGAGE
HE'LL THRIVE IN THE WAKE OF
PANDEMIC. AND LASTEST. NOT
LEAST OUR THIRD PRESENTER ALEX
BRISCO. WHOM THE SUPERINTENDENT
ALREADY MENTIONED HE'S
IMPRESSED WITH THE CALIFORNIA
CHILDREN'S TRUST- AND THE
FORMER DIRECTOR OF THE ALAMEDA
COUNTY HEALTH CARE SERVICE J.
C. GET. TWO IMPRESSIVE MASTERY
OF THE ARCANE MECHANICS OF
FEDERAL MEDICAID POLICY
ADMINISTRATION. MR BRISCOE HAS
BEEN A LONG TIME ADVOCATE FOR
USING PUBLIC HEALTH AND
EDUCATION PARTNERSHIPS. AND
FAMILY ENGAGEMENT LINKAGES TO
AFFECT BROADER TRANSFORMATIONS
IN CHILD SERVING SYSTEMS
WELCOME TO ALL OF YOU. AND WE
LOOK FORWARD TO YOUR TO YOUR
TESTIMONY AGAIN KEEPING IN MIND
THE TIME DOCTOR COURTHOUSE-
PLEASE KING THAT KICK THINGS
OFF IT IS A PLEASURE TO SEE YOU
HERE VIRTUALLY. THANK YOU
SENATOR NEWMAN AS SIGNED YOU
INTRODUCED ME MY NAME IS DOCTOR
DURING COURTHOUSE ON THE PEARL
TO PRETEND TO HEAR HARBOR CITY
SCHOOL DISTRICT. JUST WANT TO
THANK ALL THE SENATORS WHO
ASKED THE QUESTIONS- AND JUST
APPRECIATE THAT THE THAT THE
PANEL IS. HAS THE
SUPERINTENDENT HERE BECAUSE THE
IMPACT AND THE DECISIONS THAT
YOU MAKE IN SACRAMENTO
REGARDING THE- FUNDING AND WHAT
IS BEST FOR KIDS DIRECTLY
IMPACT US ON A DAY TO DAY
BASIS- WE I'M VERY FORTUNATE TO
HAVE A GREAT BOARD OF EDUCATION
AND A COUNTY LEADER DR. A MORE
CARS WHO WORKS WITH US TO TRY
TO SOLVE THE PROBLEMS THAT WE
HAVE HERE IN IN IN OUR
DISTRICT. WE ARE LOW
SOCIOECONOMIC DISTRICT. AND WE
AS YOU KNOW WE SHUT DOWN ON
MARCH THIRTEENTH THINKING THAT
WE WERE GOING TO COME BACK TO
EDUCATION. AND WE HAD TO SHIFT
INTO EDUCATION VERY DIFFERENTLY
WE WENT INTO A DISTANCE
LEARNING AND WE STARTED SCHOOL
IN OCTOBER WE BROUGHT OVER
STUDENTS BACK IN A HYBRID
MODEL. MANY OF OUR STUDENTS
DECIDED TO STAY IN DISTANCE
LEARNING. WE SHUT DOWN AGAIN
BECAUSE OF THE HIGH POSITIVITY
RATES IN LA HABRA. AND THEN WE
BROUGHT OUR STUDENTS BACK IN
FEBRUARY ONCE AGAIN IN A HYBRID
MODEL- AND AS- YOU KNOW AS
SUPERINTENDENT THURMAN HIT ON
ALL OF THE ISSUES THAT WE ARE
EXPERIENCING WITH THE ANXIETY
AND THE FEAR IN THE
ANXIOUSNESS. WE DEAL WITH THAT
EVERY EVERY SINGLE DAY BUT I
HAVE TO TELL THE PANEL AND THE
LISTENERS THAT. IF WE WOULD NOT
HAVE RECEIVED THE ADDITIONAL
FUNDING THAT WE RECEIVE I JUST
DON'T BELIEVE THAT WE KIND OF.
DONE WHAT WE HAD DONE DONE
THROUGHOUT THE YEAR AD ALSO AS
WE'RE MOVING FORWARD INTO THIS
YEAR WE ARE BACK AND IN PERSON-
FULL TIME WITH MASKS. AND THE
MONEY THAT THAT- WE USED TO I
JUST HAVE TO JUST GIVE YOU SOME
SOLID EXAMPLES BECAUSE AS I
SAID IT DEFINITELY IMPACTS US
ON- YOU KNOW ON ON THE GROUND
HERE IN THE DISTRICTS. WE USED.
OUR BY OUR MONEY FOR THE-
SUMMER SCHOOL ABBY OF. IN THE-
ARE SCHOOL VERY LOW. ME HAD
ABOUT TWO HUNDRED STUDENTS AND
WE SIMPLY JUST HAD TO TARGET
THE STUDENTS WITH THE LOWEST.
LEVEL OF ACADEMICS AND THIS
YEAR WE GET SOMETHING VERY
DIFFERENT WE INSTEAD OF HITTING
ABOUT TWO HUNDRED STUDENTS WITH
THAT MONEY. WE SPENT ABOUT ONE
POINT TWO MILLION DOLLARS FOR
THREE WEEKS OF SUMMER SCHOOL
BUT WE WERE ABLE TO IMPACT
SIXTEEN HUNDRED STUDENTS. AND
WE HAD THAT JOB WE HAVE A
PROGRAM THAT DOES ALL OF OUR
SCHOOLS ALL NINE OF OUR
SCHOOLS. AND THEN WE PARTNERED
WITH THE CITY AND THEY
BASICALLY BROUGHT THEIR
EDUCATION PROGRAMS TO OUR
SCHOOLS FOR US. WE WERE DOING-
TAEKWONDO WE WERE DOING DANCE
WE WERE DOING ALL OF THE
RECREATION PROGRAMS THAT THE
CITY THAT THE CITY IS DOING ON
THERE- AT THE OTHER SUMMER
PROGRAM. SO WE WERE ABLE TO
SUSTAIN THAT AND WE ACTUALLY
USE THE MONEY TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE CAN DO THAT AGAIN NEXT YEAR.
I WAS VERY PLEASED TO HEAR THE
CONCERN THAT ALL OF YOU HAVE
FOR THE SUSTAINABILITY OF THAT
MONEY- AS WE'RE ON WE'RE MAKING
DECISIONS FOR ADDITIONAL
COUNSELORS. AND WE ARE DOING A-
COMPASS PROGRAM IN OUR DISTRICT
WHICH ALLOWS OUR STUDENTS IN
THE ELEMENTARY SCHOOL. THEY
HAVE CANNOT COUNSELING SERVICES
TWICE A WEEK. IT IS STILL NOT
ENOUGH AS WE TRANSITION INTO
THAT YEAR BUT ALSO I USE THE
WORD SCARY BECAUSE IT IS JUST
WE'RE PUTTING TOGETHER A MULTI
YEAR BUDGET. MAKING SURE THAT
WE ARE BEING ABLE TO SPEND
TAT. MONEY FOR COUNSELORS IN
THE FUTURE IT'S SO SCARY TO
THINK THAT WE ARE. EMPLOYING
STAFF TO GATHER COUNCIL SIR. TO
OUR STUDENTS AND KNOWING THAT
WE DON'T KNOW IF THAT MONEY IS
GOING TO BE A SUSTAINABLE FOR
NEXT YEAR. THE OTHER THING THAT
WE ARE STILL GETTING ON WITH
THAT MENTAL HEALTH PIECE OF IT
IS THAT I'M A- FIRM BELIEVER IN
PHYSICAL FITNESS WITH OUR
STUDENTS- WE WERE GOING FROM-
ONE TIME A WEEK WITH A WITH A
P. E. TEACHER- AND THEIR
TEACHERS WOULD. HANDLE THE
PHYSICAL EDUCATION THE OTHER
TIME- THE PART OF THE WEEK AND
THIS YEAR WE'RE GOING WITH
TWICE A TWICE A WEEK. SO WE ARE
LOOKING AT THE- LOOKING AT THAT
USING THAT MONEY TO FUND THE
PHYSICAL EDUCATION A PROGRAM
BUT I HAVE TO SAY THAT. THE THE
BURDEN ON THE SCHOOLS ALSO WITH
THE- WITH IT BUT THE TESTING
AND THAT AND THE CODE RELATED
ISSUES HAVE BEEN- ASTRID I HAVE
JUST BEEN HUGE. WE HAVE HAD TO
INCREASE THE NUMBER OF HOURS
AND ADDITIONAL STAFF. IN OUR
SCHOOL OFFICES JUST TO MANAGE
THE CONTACT TRACING AND THE-
ADDITIONAL WORK THAT WE HAVE TO
DO WITH THE FAMILIES THE
SPECIFIC CON AT THE SPECIFIC
PHONE CALLS. BUT THIS YEAR FOR
US WE ARE OPTIMISTIC WE STARTED
SCHOOL- ALL THE KIDS ARE VERY-
ARE VERY HAPPY TO BE BACK. OUR
MOTTO THIS YEAR IS TO RESET
RECONNECT AND REAFFIRM BECAUSE
WHAT WE WANT TO DO HERE IN THE
HARBOR IS WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE KNOW OUR STUDENTS BY
NAME BY FACE AND BY STORY.
BECAUSE WE KNOW THAT. OUR
STUDENTS ARE COMING TO US WITH
PROBLEMS THAT WE DON'T EVEN
KNOW EXIST IN OUR IN OUR
DISTRICT AND SO FOR US TO FOCUS
ON THE ACADEMICS. IS CRITICAL
BUT WE ARE MORE FOCUSED THIS
YEAR ON THE MENTAL HEALTH OF
OUR STUDENTS. BUT WHEN IT COMES
TO THE FUNDING- LIKE I SAID IF
WE DID NOT HAVE THAT FUNDING WE
WOULD NOT BEEN ABLE TO- TO MOVE
OUR OUR OUR DISTRICT FORWARD.
ARE NUTRITIONAL SERVICE WORKERS
WE BEGAN- FEEDING. STUDENTS-
AND WE NEVER STOP OCT WE
FEEDING THEM WHEN WE SHOW DOWN
AND- WE CONTINUE TO FEED OUR
STUDENTS. BOTH FOR OUR WALK UPS
AND ALSO IN ON OUR SCHOOL
CAMPUSES. SO I WOULD WELCOME
ANY OF YOU TO CALM I KNOW THAT
WE ARE IN- SENATOR NEWMAN'S I
DISTRICT. BUT I WOULD WELCOME
ANY OF YOU TO COME AND VISIT
BECAUSE WE ARE A VERY LOW
SOCIOECONOMIC DISTRICT. AND I
LOVED ALL THE QUESTIONS FROM
THE SENATORS BECAUSE THEY ARE
VERY REAL QUESTIONS ON HOW WE-
ADDRESS THIS POST PANDEMIC-
ISSUES THAT WE HAVE AT OUR
SCHOOL. AND NOW WITH THE
VARIANT COMING ON AND THE
ADDITIONAL FEAR THAT STAFF AND
PARENTS HAVE. IT'S ONCE AGAIN-
ADDRESS SCENE BE IT WHICH NOT
OVER AND WE CONTINUE TO HAVE TO
ADDRESS THE NEEDS OF OUR
PARENTS. AND OUR COMMUNITY SO
WITH THE FUNDING COMING IN WE
ARE ALSO USING THAT TO HELP
WITH OUR VIRTUAL PROGRAM
BECAUSE NOW- OUR DISTRICT DID
NOT HAVE A VIRTUAL PROGRAM
BECAUSE WE THERE WAS. NO NEED
FOR IT AND NOW WE HAVE A NEED
FOR. A LOT OF THE MONEY IS
GOING INTO THE- INDEPENDENT
STUDY PROGRAM FOR PARENTS WHO
ARE CHOOSING TO KEEP THEIR
STUDENTS AT HOME AND IT'S A
VERY SMALL PERCENTAGE FOR OUR
DISTRICT. SO I WOULD JUST LIKE
TO THANK ALL THE SENATORS FOR
ASKING THOSE CRITICAL QUESTIONS
I'D LIKE TO THANK OUR- OUR
SUPERINTENDENT THURMAN FOR WHAT
HE DOES FOR OUR EDUCATION
SYSTEM I WOULD INVITE HIM TO
COME TO. THE HARBOR SO HE CAN
SEE WHAT IS GOING ON IN OUR
DISTRICT- BUT WE ARE VERY
PROUD. OF THE WORK THAT WE'RE
DOING AND WE'RE VERY EXCITED TO
HAVE OUR STUDENTS BACK- THEY
STARTED MONDAY. AND THAT LET'S
HOPE THAT THEY ARE ABLE TO STAY
IN SCHOOL FOR THE REST OF THAT
FOR THIS ENTIRE. YEAR SO THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR HAVING ME.
AND YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY DR CONGRESS. DOCTOR
WHICH IS- PLEASE PROCEED. THANK
YOU FOR HAVING ME THANK YOU
AREN'T SURE LAID BACK AND NEW
MAN. AND AND SENATORS- THIS IS
REALLY AN HONOR TO BE A PART OF
THIS GROUP OF BRILLIANCE AND- I
ALSO WANNA JUST TECHNOLOGY I'M
PRESIDENT FINDS THAT IT
HAPPENED FOR MENTAL HEALTH. AND
IT COULD GET A QUITE TOO WE HAD
TWO THOUSAND STROP POSTINGS FOR
JOBS FOR SCHOOL COUNSELORS THE
LAST COUPLE MONTHS SO THAT
MONEY IS TRICKLING INTO PEOPLE
ON SITE WHICH IS ABSOLUTELY
WONDERFUL. SO I HAD IT BEFORE I
BECAME THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
FOR THE SCHOOL COUNSELOR SIGNS
OUR SCHOOL DISTRICT
ADMINISTRATOR IN LOS ANGELES
COUNTY OR TWENTY YEARS. AND I
WAS ALSO- THE CHERUB BABY
EDUCATIONAL COUNSELING PROGRAM
AT THE UNIVERSITY OF LAVERNE
SOX HAD EXPERIENCE FROM K.
THROUGH OUR HIGHER EDUCATION.
AND AS ODD ODD TONY THURMAN
SAID THIS IS UNPRECEDENTED
TIMES THINGS THAT WE'LL WE'LL
NOT SEE OUR FUTURE AND WE
HAVEN'T SEEN IN OUR PAST- THE
BEST WAY I CAN DO IS JUST- JUST
TO BE BRIEF WITH MY COMMENTS
BECAUSE THERE'S BEEN A LOT OF.
THINGS SAID THAT I AGREE WITH
YOU IN JUST A SHORT FROM THE
PENCIL LITTLE BIT ON A FEW
POINTS. BUT I THINK YOU KNOW
WHAT I'M HEARING FROM SCHOOL
COUNSELORS OUT THERE IS THAT
RESILIENCY REALLY VARIES
BETWEEN ONE STUDENT TO ANOTHER
AND AS ARE THE SUPER JANE JUST
SAD WE HAVE TO KNOW EVERY
STUDENT'S NAME FACE AND STORY
RIGHT NOW WE HAVE TO DETERMINE
WHERE THEY ARE WHAT THEIR NEEDS
ARE. ARE USING DIFFERENT
MECHANISMS FOR SCREENING. BUT
ONCE PERSON SAID IT REALLY
BRILLIANTLY AND SAID THAT GRIEF
COMES IN ALL SHAPES AND SIZES
BUT FOR EVERYONE IT MEANS THAT
LIFE IS FOREVER CHANGED AND SO
I WOULD SAY THAT THAT'S THE WAY
WE ARE RIGHT NOW THAT LIFE IS
FOREVER CHANGED IN SOME
CAPACITY. AND HOW WE MOVE
FORWARD IS REALLY IMPORTANT- I
A. I'D BECOME ASSOCIATIONS WILL
COUNT THAT ARE. OUR TWO SUPER.
ABOUT A YEAR AGO WHICH TALKED
ABOUT THREE TO. RE OPENING. AND
ONE OF THE THAT. ADVOCATE FOR
IS ASSESSING AND DIFFERENT WAYS
OF ASSESSING THE NEEDS OF
STUDENTS AND TRIAGING THE
SERVICES THAT ARE NEEDED REALLY
RAPIDLY AT THIS SPACE. AND ONE
OF THOSE WAYS AND THERE'S ALSO
A THERE'S ALL KINDS OF WAYS OF
DOING IT BUT ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT WE ADVOCATE FOR WE PROMOTE
OUR SCHOOL COUNSELORS TO DO IS
TO TRAIN TEACHERS. TO SUPPORT
TEACHERS IN REGARDS TO SEEING
RED PLAQUES WITH STUDENTS. AND
WITH THOSE RED FLAGS WHAT WE
CAN DO IS STAND. I DO WARM
HANDS OFF TO COMMUNITY HEALTH
PROVIDERS HAVE PEOPLE ON OUR
CAMPUS TO CAN HELP WITH OUR
MENTAL HEALTHSERVICES AND
THINGS LIKE THAT. RIGHT LET ME
GIVE YOU ONE ONE PIECE THAT YOU
KNOW I ASKED SCHOOL COUNSELOR
SO TELL ME A STORY. ONE STRUCK
ME IN ACCOUNTS ARE HIGH SCHOOL
COUNSELOR SAYS YOU KNOW I HAVE
AN ART STUDENT THIS HAS. GREAT
ANXIETY BECAUSE FOR THE LAST
EIGHTEEN MONTHS HE WAS LEARNING
SPANISH ONE IN SPANISH THROUGH.
ONLINE THROUGH FLASH CARDS AND
NOW HE'S GOING TO DO SPANISH
THREE. AND HE'S GOING TO HAVE
TO DIALOGUE IN CLASSROOMS WITH
THAT AND THAT'S A LOT OF
ANXIETY PRODUCING AND HE AND
THE SCHOOL COUNSELOR. HAD TO
WORK WITH HIM TO GET HIM BACK
IN THE CLASSROOM. SO IT JERRY
AS IT'S- TO WE ARE. ON BUT IT
REALLY TAKES PERSONNEL. TO DO
IT BECAUSE IT REALLY TAKES TO
KNOW WHAT'S GOING ON WITH EACH
STUDENT'S LICENSE SOMETIMES IT
JUST DOESN'T PRESENT ITSELF. IN
A WAY THAT'S REALLY EVIDENT IN
THE CLASSROOM- THERE WAS A
SURVEY THAT WAS DONE RECENTLY.
AND THAT WAS DONE BY THE ACLU
WITH STUDENTS AND THEY DID ONE
IN TWENTY TWENTY AND THEN THE
ONE THAT'S GOING TO BE RELEASED
IN THE NEXT WEEK OR SO. AND
WITH THAT SURVEY WHAT ARE THE
THINGS THAT THEY CAME UP WITH.
AND WHAT THEY DETERMINED WAS
THAT STUDENTS SAD THAT WHAT
THEY NEED IS THEY NEED PEOPLE.
ON SCHOOL CAMPUSES BUT THEY CAN
TRUST. AND THEN THAT TRUSTING
SOMEONE THAT THEY KNOW AND THEY
CAN COUNT ON IT THEY CAN SHARE
WITH AND TALK THROUGH THINGS
WITH STRONG. AGAIN THAT MEANS
WE NEED MORE PERSONNEL SO. I
JUST WANT TO SAY AND I AND I
KIND OF. TOOK SOME NOTES OF
SOME OF THE QUESTIONS I WAS
ASKED TO THE LAST- AGAIN I WANT
TO ADDRESS A COUPLE OF THOSE.
WHAT ARE THINGS ABOUT WORK
FORCE AND I THINK IT'S SO
IMPORTANT IS THAT- THERE ARE.
PROBABLY THE ONLY WORK FORCE
GROUP THAT HAS ENOUGH PEOPLE
AVAILABLE TO FILL SOME OF THESE
ROLES AS SCHOOL COUNSELORS AND-
THAT'S BECAUSE WE HAVE THIRTY
EIGHT TRAINING INSTITUTIONS IN
THE STATE. ARE THAT ARE
PRODUCING ABOUT TWO THOUSAND
SCHOOL COUNSELORS EVERY YEAR.
ALL WHAT WE KNOW IS THAT WE
HAVE ELEVEN THOUSAND FIVE
HUNDRED. COUNSELORS WORKING IN
OUR SCHOOLS AND WE HAVE ABOUT
TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND WHICH
ACTED CREDENTIALS SO. I FEEL.
REALLY CONFIDENT THAT WE CAN
FEEL ALL ROLES EXCEPT FOR THE
FACT THAT SOMETIMES THE RULER
IS IT'S MORE DIFFICULT TO DO
THAT. WHICH IS ONE REASON WHY I
THINK TELEHEALTH IS REALLY-
THANK GOD PRESERVE. AND FOR
THOSE OPPORTUNITIES TO BE ABLE
TO DO COUNSELING SERVICES WHEN
WE HAVE INTERNET CONNECTIONS
WITH KIDS THAT LIVE IN RURAL
AREAS THAT CANNOT GET TO OTHER
PLACES. THAT WE CAN DO THAT AND
THE OTHER PLACES THAT ARE.
TWENTY THERMOSTAT IS THAT
SCHOOLS ARE THE PLACE. SKIP
MOST OF THEIR MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES WE KNOW THAT
STATISTICALLY THAT'S WHERE THAT
HAPPENS SO HAVING PEOPLE ON
CAMPUS THAT CAN PROVIDE THOSE
SERVICES AND BE ABLE TO HELP
THEM THROUGH ROUGH SPOTS. GREAT
BUT IN OTHER CASES WE CAN'T
WHEN WE LOOK AT OUR WORKFORCE
AND WORKFORCE ISSUES IT BECOMES
MORE DIFFICULT SO WHEN I WAS A
SCHOOL LEADER. WE WOULD ASK FOR
YOUR DATE PROSPECTOR VALUATION
CHANGE WE HAD A- KID THAT WAS
PSYCHOTIC TO COME OUT TO HELP
US- WITH A STUDENT AND
HOSPITALIZE USUALLY IS IT WAS
THE END RESULT. AND LOT OF
TIMES WE WOULD CALL AT NINE IN
THE MORNING WE WENT TO GET
SOMEONE TO LEAVE UNTIL EIGHT AT
NIGHT TO DO THE ASSESSMENT. AND
SO THOSE ARE THE PLACES THAT WE
WERE ASKED. FIVE YEARS AGO AND
IT LOOKS LIKE FROM WHAT I'VE
BEEN READING IN REGARDS TO
RESEARCH THAT WE'RE STILL THERE
SO WE NEED TO. BUILD OUR
WORKFORCE IN REGARDS TO OUR
COMMUNITY WORK FORCE AND WE
NEED TO INVEST. IN ONGOING
FUNDING WITH INDIVIDUALS THAT
CAN BE THERE SO STUDENTS CAN
TRUST THOSE INDIVIDUALS AND NOW
THERE IS SOMEONE THERE TO COUNT
ON THEY CAN TALK TO. SO THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR FOR
ALLOWING ME TO SPEAK TODAY.
NINE AND THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
JOINING US DOCTOR WHICH IS- MR
BRISCOE- WELCOME. AND PLEASE
FOR SIX. HI GOOD AFTERNOON-
UNABASHEDLY MOVE QUICKLY BUT I
I'LL SOURCE WITH TO- HIGHLIGHT
ALL OF CREDIT COMMENTS- THE
STATE OR SHOULD- WE ALREADY
MOMENT TIME- IS TRUE THAT OUR
SYSTEM HAS STRUGGLED- IN FACT
WE ARE THE STATE'S LARGEST OF
THE NATION'S LARGEST MEDICAL
PROGRAM AMONG WORST- BUT I ALSO
THINK THAT THE WINDS OF CHANGE
ARE BLOWING. SO WITH BOTH- WHAT
REALISTIC REVIEW OF WHERE WE
STAND BUT ALSO SOME REAL
HOPEFULNESS. I'D LIKE TO TAKE
YOU THROUGH SOME KEY PRINCIPLES
AND A LITTLE BIT OF DATA. SO
FIRST HIS WHILE TODAY'S HEARING
IS ABOUT THE IMPACT OF COLD IT.
IT MUST BE NAMED THAT YOUNG
PEOPLE IN CALIFORNIA WERE IN
THE MIDST OF A CRISIS BEFORE
THE PANDEMIC. IN THE DECADE
BEFORE THE PANDEMIC TWICE AS
MANY CHILDREN WERE ADMITTED TO
SELF INJURY THROUGH EMERGENCY
DEPARTMENTS. WE SAW A 50%
INCREASE IN HOSPITALIZATION FOR
PAEDIATRIC MENTAL HEALTH.
DURING A TIME WHEN THE REST OF
THE HEALTH CARE SYSTEM. SO
DRAMATIC DECLINE IN BAD TASTE.
YOUNG PEOPLE HAVE BEEN TELLING
US SINCE TWO THOUSAND FIVE THE
CALIFORNIA HEALTHY KIDS SURVEY.
THAT THEY NEED A LOT MORE THAN
THEY'RE GETTING. AND
UNFORTUNATELY WE RANK FORTY
EIGHTH IN THE NATION AND ACCESS
TO CARE FOR MEDICAID POPULATION
WHICH REPRESENTS SIX OUT OF TEN
CHILDREN IN THE STATE. AND
BEFORE I GO ANY FURTHER ALL OF
THESE NUMBERS MEAN SOMETHING TO
ME BOTH PERSONALLY AND
PROFESSIONALLY. I HAVE WORKED
AS A THERAPIST AND YOGA PUBLIC
SCHOOLS. I WAS EMERGENCY ROOM
SOCIAL WORKER AND I LET ONE OF
THE STATE'S LARGEST. HEALTH
CARE SYSTEMS I KNOW THIS WORK
FROM ACTUALLY BILLING SERVICES
FOR YOUNG PEOPLE. AND SCHOOLS
ARE ESSENTIAL FACTORS AT ANY
RESPONSE TO SCALE. BUT IT'S
IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT KOBE
THESE PROBLEMS HAVE BEEN
GROWING IN OUR SOCIETY. MAYBE
FROM FOUR HUNDRED YEARS OF
STRUCTURAL INEQUALITY MAYBE
FROM ONE SOCIAL MEDIA BECAME
AVAILABLE IN TWO THOUSAND NINE
MAYBE FROM A PERPETUAL NEWS
CYCLE. THAT IS INAPPROPRIATE
FOR YOUNG PEOPLE TO CONSUME
WHATEVER THE REASONS SOMETHING
IS HAPPENING IN YOUNG PEOPLE'S
LIVES AND WHETHER YOU EVER WERE
A CHILD OR HOW. YOU'RE PROBABLY
WORRIED ABOUT THE SOCIAL AND
EMOTIONAL WELFARE CHILDREN AND
SCHOOLS ARE ON THE FRONTLINES
OF THAT CHALLENGE. AND YOU HAVE
TO DECIDE TO GET THIS DATA BY
RACE REALLY APPRECIATE THE.
QUESTIONS FROM THE
REPRESENTATIVE FROM LONG BEACH.
BLACK AND BROWN CHILDREN. A
MUCH HIGHER PRICE. FOR THE
FAILURE OF OUR ABILITY TO
SUPPORT THEIR SOCIAL AND
EMOTIONAL WELFARE. MAKING
HEALING CENTER SCHOOLS ISN'T
JUST A QUESTION OF GETTING THE
MEDICAID REIMBURSEMENT RATES
BUT THAT'S A BIG PART. IT'S WE
HAVE TO ACKNOWLEDGE THE
EXTRAORDINARY WORK OF OUR
SURGEON GENERAL WHO'S BRINGING
A BROAD CONSENSUS TO THE
REALITY THAT RACE AND CLASS
MATTER. THE EXPERIENCE FOR
YOUNG PEOPLE AND I CAN SEE THIS
FROM HAVING BUILD LITERALLY
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS A SAFETY
THAT NORMAL SERVICES THE VAST
MAJORITY OF THE CHILDREN AND
FAMILIES I SERVED WE'RE NOT
PATHOLOGICAL. THEY WERE DEALING
WITH LIVING IN A CULTURE THAT
TOLD THEM THEY WEREN'T WORTH
ANYTHING OR STRUGGLING WITH THE
IMPACTS OF STRUCTURAL RACISM
AND POVERTY ON THEIR WELFARE.
AND OUR MENTAL HEALTH SYSTEM
TODAY HAS LARGELY FALLEN DRIVES
THAT EXPERIENCE AND SO AS WE
INVEST THESE DOLLARS AS WE
BUILD THE CAPACITY OF SCHOOLS
TO DO THIS WORK. WE MUST ALSO
WE IMAGINE OURSELVES NOT AS A
RESPONSE TO BEST OLOGY. BUT AS
A SUPPORT FOR HEALTHY
DEVELOPMENT. FOR THOSE OF YOU
WANT TO MASK THE IMPACT OF KOBE
EVERYTHING HERE IS COMING TO
PASS DRAMATIC INCREASES IN
EMERGENCY DEPARTMENT
UTILIZATION FOR YOUNGER AND
YOUNGER AGES. IN FACT IF YOU
HAD WITH THE IMPACT OF THE
PANDEMIC TO THE DATA I SHOULD
JOIN THE FIRST SLIDE. RADY
CHILDREN'S AS ONE EXAMPLE HAS
SEEN 17100% INCREASE IN
EMERGING FROM UTILIZATION FOR
CHILDREN. AND IN FACT WHEN YOU
DECIDE TO GET JUST THE LAST
YEAR. WE HAVE SEEN 34% FEWER
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES. THEN
AGAIN DESPITE THESE DRAMATIC
INCREASES IN UTILITY. SO IF
YOU'RE NOT A LITTLE BIT SCARED
OR DEPRESSED THEN YOU'RE NOT
LISTENING. AND SCHOOLS HAVE TO
BE ESSENTIAL ACTORS THE DOCTOR
PAM'S QUESTION ABOUT THE
ESSENTIAL ROLE OF PEDIATRIC
PRIMARY CARE. THAT'S REALLY
ESSENTIAL FOR LITTLE CHILDREN
ZERO TO FIVE ZERO EIGHT. WHEN
KIDS GET TO BE ABOUT EIGHT
YEARS OLD THEIR PERIODICITY
MEANING HOW OFTEN THEY GO TO
THE DOCTOR DECLINES
DRAMATICALLY MANY CHILDREN IN
THE MEDICAID SYSTEM BETWEEN THE
AGE OF TWELVE AND TWENTY FOUR.
GO TO THE DOCTOR ONCE OR TWICE
FOR THEIR WHOLE ADOLESCENCE. SO
SCHOOLS ARE ESSENTIAL ACTORS
BECAUSE THAT'S WHERE KIDS ARE
AND DOCTORS MARCH DURING THE
TIME THAT 75% OF MUSLIMS
MANIFESTS. AND I'M NOT GONNA DO
A BIG MEDICAID PIECE BECAUSE
THAT'S THE WHOLE MEDICARE
REFORM LANDSCAPE THAT'S A WHOLE
SEPARATE PRESENTATION. WE HAVE
UNIQUE LEADERSHIP AND INDIRECT
LIKE PORN AND MARK GALLI WHO
WORK INCREDIBLY SOPHISTICATED
NEW TUNE TO THIS ISSUE. BUT THE
FINANCES ALIGNED THERE'S REASON
THAT'S THE SCHOOLS AND MEDICARE
ARE LIKE PEANUT BUTTER AND
CHOCOLATE. SOME OF THE
UNPRECEDENTED INVESTMENT IS
SOMETIMES SO MUCH IT'S HARD TO
TRACK. BUT I TRY TO ORGANIZE IT
IN A FOUR POINT FOUR BILLION
DOLLAR USE BEHAVIOR HEALTH
INITIATIVE. THE FIFTEEN PLUS
BILLION DOLLARS IN THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET. AND THE
FEDERAL STIMULUS DOLLARS WHICH
CAN'T BE EXCLUDED. IN ORDER TO
UNDERSTAND HOW WE ARE INVESTING
IN SCHOOLS YOU HAVE TO LOOK AT
ALL THREE OF THESE TOGETHER. IN
THE CONTEXT OF THE REFORM OF
OUR MEDICAL PROGRAM. SO WHY IS
MEDICARE ALSO IMPORTANT. IT
COVERS ALMOST SIX OUT OF TEN
KIDS MORE INVOLVED IN EDUCATION
PROBABLY SEVEN OUT OF TEN. AND
UNFORTUNATELY LESS THAN 5% OF
THOSE CHILDREN GET ACCESS TO
ANY CARE AT ALL LESS THAN THREE
PERCENT. ARE AN ONGOING CARE AS
MEASURED BY FIVE OR MORE VISITS
IN A CALENDAR YEAR. SO LET ME
END WITH A SLIDE. IN WE HAVE A
ONCE IN A. GENERATION
OPPORTUNITY TO ADDRESS THE
CRISIS THAT IS A SOCIALLY
CONSTRUCTED EPIDEMIC OF DESPAIR.
WE DIDN'T JUST CHANGE SOMETHING
IN THE WATER IN THE EARLY TWO
THOUSANDS ACTUALLY DIDN'T GET
SPIKED TWICE AS MANY KIDS
DIDN'T GET ADMITTED FOR SELF
INJURY JUST BECAUSE- OF
SOMETHING IN THE WATER. WE ARE
SO SOMETHING IS HAPPENING IN
OUR CULTURE WE ARE MAKING
CHILDREN SICK. WE HAVE TO HAVE
THE COURAGE TO REIMAGINE TO
TAKE RESPONSIBILITY FOR THAT
AND REDEFINE WHAT MENTAL HEALTH
THIS IS NOT SIMPLY RESPONSIBLE
POLICY. IT'S A SUPPORT FOR
HEALTHY DEVELOPMENT. AND IT IS
BASED ON THE BELIEF IN THE
WISDOM AND INTELLIGENCE OF LOW%
INCOME COMMUNITIES AND
FAMILIES. I HAVE SEEN A LOT OF
HUMAN SUFFERING. AND WHILE
THOSE EXPERIENCES HAVE MARQUEE.
MY LARGEST TAKEAWAY IS A BEAUTY
AND WISDOM AND ABILITY TO
SURVIVE AND EVEN THRIVE IN THE
FACE OF THESE CHALLENGES. SO
THIS REDEFINITION OF MENTAL
HEALTH HAS TO BE PART OF THE
SOLUTION. WE HAVE TO HELP
SCHOOLS UNDERSTAND AND NAVIGATE
THE NEXUS OF HEALTH AND
EDUCATION WHICH MEANS
UNDERSTANDING A COMPLEX AND
EXTREMELY TROUBLED MEDICAID
SYSTEM IN CALIFORNIA. WE HAVE
TO TEACH SCHOOLS TO PARTNER
WITH THIS ORGANIZATION WHO
ALREADY CAN NAVIGATE THE
SYSTEM. YES WE SHOULD BE
INVESTING IN THEIR OWN CAPACITY
BUT THE ANALOGY I LIKE TO GIVE
THIS IS YOUR HOUSE EDUCATION
BUT YOU DON'T HAVE TO OWN ALL
THE FURNITURE IN IT. EVEN
THOUGH YOU HAVE TO KNOW WHERE
IT IS. SO THE ESSENTIAL FOR
SCHOOLS IS TO COORDINATE OLD
UNDERSTAND MANAGE NOT
NECESSARILY DO. AND FINALLY.
THAT LIST OF DOLLARS I GAVE.
SCHOOLS HAVE TO SPEND THOSE
DOLLARS STRATEGICALLY TO BUILD
SUSTAINABLE PROGRAMS BASED ON
BEST PRACTICES THERE ACTUALLY
ARE THERE IS A CONSENSUS. ABOUT
THE MULTI TIERED SYSTEMS OF
SUPPORT AND THE CENTRICITY OF
COORDINATION OF SERVICE TEAMS
ON SCHOOL CAMPUSES WE KNOW
SOMETHING ABOUT THIS WORK. SO
HOW IT'S STRUCTURED IS ACTUALLY
PRETTY COMMONLY AGREED UPON.
HOW TO FIND AND SUSTAIN IT
MEANS NAVIGATING A TROUBLED
MEDICAID SYSTEM. THAT'S IN THE
MIDST OF REFORM. THANK YOU SO
MUCH AND I WANT TO. ACKNOWLEDGE
THE LEADERSHIP. OF THE CENTER
OF THIS COMMITTEE. WHO CREATED
A REALLY GREAT CREATE A REALLY
GREAT RESOURCE GUIDE THAT I
ENCOURAGE EVERYONE TO TAKE A
LOOK AT THANK YOU. AND THANK
YOU MISS RICHARD IF IT'S OKAY
WITH ME WE WOULD BE GRATEFUL IF
WE CAN SHARE A COPY OF YOUR
PRESENTATION WITH MY COLLEAGUES
HERE TODAY- I'M ALSO WENT TO A
DOCTOR CALLED RESPECT WHICH
AND- FOR YOUR TESTIMONY AND I'M
GOING TO DIVERGE A LITTLE BIT
IN THE INTEREST OF TIME FROM
THE ORIGINAL PLAN SO LET US
MOVE ON- TWO PANEL THREE AND
THEN WE'LL TAKE QUESTIONS TO
BOTH THE PANELS AT ONCE SO WE
DON'T RUN THE RISK OF RUNNING
OUT OF. TIME AND TO THE PUBLIC-
WE'RE GONNA DO OUR BEST TO GET
TO PUBLIC COMMENTS- IF WE DO
NOT I WILL PROVIDE AT THE END A
WEBSITE FOR YOU TO SUBMIT
PUBLIC COMMENT- ONLINE- MOVING
ON TO THE THIRD PANEL FOR
TODAY'S FINAL PANEL BUT WE WILL
LOOK AHEAD AND BEYOND TO
ONGOING EFFORTS TO SUPPORT
STUDENTS WELL BEING. AND KEEP
THEM ENGAGED VOLUNTEERING
ACADEMIC RIGOR WE WILL HEAR
FROM SCHOOL SUPPORT SPECIALISTS
RESEARCHERS AND WELLNESS
FOCUSED YOUTH LEADERS WHO WILL
HIGHLIGHT ONGOING SOCIAL
EMOTIONAL LEARNING EFFORTS AND
SPEAK TO THEIR RESPECTIVE
PARENTS SERVING YOUTH IN
NONTRADITIONAL SETTINGS WE ARE
FORTUNATE TO HAVE OUR FIRST
PANEL SHOWING US DOCTOR JULIAN
LEE ASSISTANT SUPERINTENDENT OF
EDUCATIONAL SERVICES- FROM
FULLERTON SCHOOL DISTRICT WHICH
IS ALSO IN MY DISTRICT DOCTOR
LEE'S WORK IS A REFLECTION. OF
OUR DEEP COMMITMENT TO
PROVIDING A SAFE COLLABORATIVE
AND INCLUDING THE INCLUSIVE
LEARNING ENVIRONMENT FOR ALL
AND SHE WILL HIGHLIGHT ONGOING
EFFORTS TO BUILD STUDENT
RESILIENCE IN FULTON SCHOOLS
NEXT WE'LL HEAR FROM MANDY
CORBIN ASSOCIATE SUPERINTENDENT
OF SPECIAL EDUCATION AND
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH SERVICES WITH
THE CINEMA COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION MISS CORBIN HAS AT
THE COUNTY STUDENT BEHAVIOR ON
MENTAL MENTAL WELLNESS EFFORTS
FOCUSING ON DISASTER RESPONSE.
AND RETURN TO SCHOOL DURING
CODE NINETEEN OUR THIRD
PRESENTED TODAY IS DOCTOR
KIMBERLY SHINER REICHEL A
LEADING EXPERT IN THE FIELD OF
SOCIAL EMOTIONAL LEARNING A
TECHNICIAN RACHAEL DISCUSS HER
WORK AS THE LEAD RESEARCHER FOR
MIND UP A NON PROFIT
ORGANIZATION FOUNDED BY ACTRESS
GOLDIE HAWN WITH THE MISSION OF
FOSTERING MENTAL FITNESS AND
WELLBEING AND BOTH STUDENTS AND
EDUCATORS MIND UP HAS A NUMBER
OF LARGER MISSIONS TAKING
PLACE. THAT FOCUS DIRECTLY ON
YOUTH. WELLNESS SPEND
RESILIENCE- AND FINAL- ARE LESS
PRISON IN THE MORNING BE
DOCTORS. A SHINE- THE STAND
CENTER FOR YOUTH MENTAL AND
WELL. ALONG WITH FAMILY ONE OF
HIS STUDENTS WILL PROVIDE THE
STUDENT PERSPECTIVE. AND
SHOWCASE THE IMPORTANCE OF
PROGRAMS- THAT MAKE CRITICAL
NET CONNECTIONS TO SCHOOL
MENTAL HEALTH- WELCOME AND
THANK YOU ALL FOR SHARING YOUR
EXPERIENCES. I KNOW I SPEAK FOR
EMILY- WHEN I SAY I HOPE THAT
WE CAN GET EVERYBODY'S
TESTIMONY IN PRIOR TO THE END
OF THE HEARING. THAT SAID DR
LEE IF YOU COULD PLEASE
PROCEED. WELCOME AND THANK YOU.
HELLO EVERYONE AND THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR THE CALIFORNIA STATE
SENATE FOR THIS INVITATION IS
TRULY AN HONOR TO BE A PART OF
THE PANEL. I DO WANT TO START
BY JUST KIND OF REWINDING A
LITTLE BIT. WHEN THE PANDEMIC
HIT OUR DISTRICT. OF FOCUSED
HEAVILY ON DIFFERENT LEARNING
OPTIONS TO BE ABLE TO PROVIDE.
A FOR NOT ONLY THE STUDENTS BUT
THE COMMUNITY AND THE PARENTS
AND WE- QUICKLY SPENT OUR OUR
FUNDS EXAMINING THE ACCESS AND
EQUITY WITH EQUIPMENT IN
CONNECTION- TO VIRTUAL
LEARNING. HOWEVER WE QUICKLY
ALSO LEARNED THAT TRUE ACCESS
TO STUDENT LEARNING MEANT THAT
STUDENTS WERE ENGAGED. AND HOW
CAN STUDENTS BE ENGAGED WHEN
THERE IS SUCH DISPARITY WITH
STUDENT NEEDS AND- WE DEVELOPED
A MODEL CALLED SSDS. WHICH
REPRESENTS FULTON SCHOOL
DISTRICT THREE SIXTY AND IT WAS
WRAPAROUND SERVICES.
UNDERSTANDING THAT STUDENTS TO
BE ACCESSED. TRUE LEARNING
THERE IT NEEDS NEEDS TO BE MET
HUNGER SHELTER. SOCIAL
EMOTIONAL NEEDS. AND WITH THAT.
WE LOOK AT OUR RESOURCES AN
ALLOCATION- OF OUR STAFF OUR
STAFF CAPACITY. TO CREATE-
SIMILAR TO WHAT DOCTOR
CULVERHOUSE SHARED A
PERSONALIZED MODELS SO- IT WAS
THE PHILOSOPHY. OF REALLY
EXAMINING INDIVIDUAL STUDENT
NEEDS AND THE MODEL WAS I SEE
YOU YOU ARE IMPORTANT. AND YOU
MATTER. BECAUSE LOST IN THE
VIRTUAL WORLD WE WERE
DISCONNECTED WITH STUDENTS AND
FEELING. OF ARE THEY FEELING
CONNECTED TO STUDENT LEARNING
ARE THEY FEELING CONNECTED TO
THEIR TEACHERS ARE THE FEELING
CONNECTED TO. THEIR COMMUNITY
AND WITH THAT- WE EXPANDED. OUR
DIVISION TO INCLUDE ADDITIONAL
SOCIAL SERVICE ASSISTANCE ARE
CAPTURED IN THE COUNSELORS- WE
FOCUS HEAVILY ON POSITIVE
BEHAVIOR INTERVENTION SUPPORTS-
AND EXPANDING SOCIAL EMOTIONAL
PRACTICES IN THE CLASSROOM. SO
THEIR DIRECT SERVICES TO
STUDENTS. AND WITH THAT A
WRAPAROUND SERVICES ALSO
INCLUDES OUR. BEHAVIOR CRISIS
RESPONSE INTERVENTION TEAMS AND
EXAM- TRUE HEALTH NEEDS- AND I
CAN GO ON PROBABLY QUITE SOME
TIME IN IN JUST JUST SHARING
WITH YOU OUR OUR FUTURE PLANS
FOR LEARNING RECOVERY. KNOWING
HAND IN HAND IT GOES WITH THE
WITH THE SERVICES TO PROVIDE
SOCIAL EMOTIONAL AND MENTAL
HEALTH SUPPORTS FOR KIDS- WE DO
HAVE PLANNED- A VERY ROBUST IN
PERSON- AT THE- CONTINUED
ACADEMIC OFFER OPPORTUNITIES
NOT ONLY FOR INTERVENTION
SUPPORTS EXAMINED THE- THE
LEARNING GAPS. BUT ALSO TO MOVE
FORWARD WITH LEARNING IN
PERSONAL LOSS WE INCLUDE ARTS.
HE PHYSICAL ACTIVITIES SPORTS
AS A PART OF OUR LEARNING
RECOVERY BECAUSE STUDENTS DO
NOT HAVE THOSE EXPERIENCES MANY
DIDN'T- DURING THE PANDEMIC.
AND SO WITH THAT I JUST WANT TO
REALLY EXPRESS MY GRATITUDE FOR
INVITING SCHOOL DISTRICTS TO BE
HEARD AND SEEN- I THINK IT'S
VERY IMPORTANT THAT THE FUNDING
HAS A FACE AND A NAME TO IT.
THAT IT'S UNDERSTOOD THAT IN
ORDER TO. SEE HEAR AND FEEL HOW
THIS IS IMPACTING STUDENT
LIVES- THE STATE MUST HEAR FROM
THE SCHOOL SITES THANK YOU WITH
THAT IF YOU HAVE ANY FURTHER
QUESTIONS FOR ME I'D BE MORE
THAN HAPPY TO EXPAND. ON ANY OF
THE TOPICS THAT I COVER TODAY.
THANK YOU SO MUCH DOCTOR LEE-
MOVE VERY MUCH APPRECIATED-
NEXT WE'LL HEAR FROM MISS
CORBIN I MISS CORBIN. WELCOME I
APPRECIATE. IF YOU GET MORE
SENATOR. THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK WITH YOU
TODAY ABOUT THE SYSTEMS WE ARE
IMPLEMENTING IT'S NOT A COUNTY
TO SUPPORT STUDENT WELL BEING.
MY NAME IS MANDY CORBIN AND I
AM THE ASSOCIATE SUPERINTENDENT
FOR SPECIAL EDUCATION AND
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH SERVICES AT
THE CINEMA COUNTY. OFFICE OF
EDUCATION. I RESIDED IN CINEMA
COUNTY FOR ALMOST THIRTY YEARS.
TO WORK AS AN EDUCATOR HERE FOR
TWENTY FIVE. THIRTY YEARS. MY
SON IS A YOUNG ADULT WITH
AUTISM WHO LOST HIS AND HIS
FATHER'S HOME IN COFFEY PARK
DURING THE TUBBS FIRE THE
TWENTY SEVENTEEN. I CONTINUE TO
SEE THE IMPACT OF THIS DRAMATIC
EVENT. THE COMPOUNDING OF
ADDITIONAL DRAMATIC EVENTS IN
THE ISOLATION EXPERIENCE DURING
THE NINETEEN. ON HIS AND OTHER
STUDENTS EMOTIONAL AND PHYSICAL
WELL BEING. WELL IN THE COUNTY
USE THE NEW STRANGER TO FLOOD
RELATED DISASTERS FOR DECADES.
THERE IS NOTHING LIKE A
WILDFIRE THAT COMES WITHOUT
WARNING IN THE MIDDLE OF THE
NIGHT AND WHAT THAT DOES. TO A
COMMUNITY ITS INFRASTRUCTURE
ITS FAMILIES. AND MOST
IMPORTANTLY OUR CHILDREN OVER
MANY YEARS. THERE IS ALSO
NOTHING LIKE A GLOBAL PANDEMIC
THAT CONTINUES FOR YEARS
IMPACTING OUR CHILDREN'S
ABILITY. TO CONNECT WITH THE
WORLD AND LEARN IN THE WAY THAT
WE HAVE KNOWN. IT'S BEEN ALMOST
FOUR YEARS SINCE THE TUBBS FIRE
OF TWENTY SEVENTEEN HERE IN
CINEMA COUNTY IT IS HARD TO
BELIEVE. THAT WE HAVE SEEN
THREE MORE CATASTROPHIC FIRES A
FLOOD AND NOW A CONDIMENT. THIS
INCLUDES EVACUATING MORE THAN
TWO HUNDRED AND FIFTY THOUSAND
PEOPLE IN THE FALL OF TWENTY
NINETEEN. AND IN THE FALL OF
TWENTY TWENTY WHILE IN CHILDREN
PLACED DUE TO COOK AT NINETEEN.
FIFTY THOUSAND MORE PEOPLE WERE
EVACUATED. I REALIZE OUR
PANELISTS HERE TODAY TO INFORM
YOU ABOUT WORK IN THE
EDUCATIONAL FIELD AS IT RELATES
TO COOK AT NINETEEN IN STUDENT
AND PERSONAL AND BEHAVIOURAL
WELL BEING. WE BELIEVE THAT OUR
LESSONS LEARNED IN CINEMA
COUNTY FROM OUR MULTIPLE
NATURAL DISASTERS THE PLIGHT.
OF THE COOK AT NINETEEN BECAUSE
WELL. THERE IS A CASE THE
PUZZLE THAT I'M HERE TO SHARE.
ON BEHALFOF CINEMA COUNTY
UNDER SUPERINTENDENT OF SCHOOLS
DR STEVEN HARRINGTON. WHO'S
BEEN A CHAMPION OF MENTAL
ILLNESS WORK FOR STUDENTS. BUT
DURING DISASTERS- IT WE BELIEVE
THAT THIS WILL FIT WITH
CALIFORNIA'S RESPONSE TO THE
EMOTIONAL WELLNESS FOR STATE
STUDENTS IN THE WAKE OF COVERT
NINETEEN. GOING TO GIVE YOU A
STEP BREAKDOWN OF THE STEPS WE
USE HERE IN CINEMA COUNTY. TO
SUPPORT STUDENTS IN THE WAKE OF
A DISASTER. THE STEPS OR A
COMBINATION OF THE STEP TRIAGE
TO CARE APPROACH IN A FOCUSED
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT
PROGRAM. STEP ONE. FIND OUT
WHAT HAS HAPPENED TO OUR
CHILDREN DURING AND AFTER THE
DISASTER. HERE WE USE A
SITUATIONAL SCREENER TO FIND
OUT USE A SCREENER KANSAI START
IT IS A SIMPLE TWENTY QUESTION
EVENT SCREENER AT EITHER SCHOOL
STAFF CAN USE TO INTERVIEW A
STUDENT WORK FAMILY. OR IT CAN
BE DELIVERED ELECTRONICALLY FOR
FAMILIES TO COMPLETE. IT GIVES
INDIVIDUAL RESULTS RESULTS HIGH
SCHOOL RESULTS BY DISTRICT.
THIS TOOL HAS THE ABILITY TO
INFORM SCHOOL LEADERS ABOUT THE
SITUATION OF THAT STUDENTS. IN
TO ASSIST IN THE DIRECTING
RESOURCES AND TRAINING FOR
SCHOOL STAFF. STEP TWO PROVIDE
PSYCHOLOGICAL FOR STATE
IMMEDIATELY POST DISASTER TO
OUR CHILDREN AND SCHOOL STAFF.
NATIONAL DEVELOPMENT OR
TRAINING IS ACTUALLY A FORM OF
PSYCHOLOGICAL FIRST AID FOR
STOCK AT A SYSTEM TO KNOW HOW
TO CARE FOR THEMSELVES CONNECT
AGAIN TO TELL THEIR OWN TRAUMA
STORY. AND A TOUCH COPING
STRATEGIES TO THAT STORY OR
NARRATIVE THIS EMPOWERS THE
STAFF WAS SIMPLE HANDS ON TOOLS
OF HOW TO TALK TO CHILDRENHOW
TO TAILOR LESSONS IN CLASS WHAT
TO LOOK FOR AND HOW TO CONNECT
TO ITS TWO ADDITIONAL RESOURCE.
STEP THREE. RESOURCE OUR SCHOOL
STAFF SO THEY FEEL CONFIDENT TO
RESPONSE TO OUR CHILDREN WHILE
KEEPING EDUCATION MOVING
FORWARD. EARLY ON CLOSE TIMES I
WAS TOLD. IF YOU DO NOT GIVE
THE STAFF RESOURCES AND A
PATHWAY TO ACCESS THEM. YOU'LL
BE SURPRISED BECAUSE STAFFEL
FREEZE PERHAPS IS THAT THE
EVENT NEVER OCCURRED. RESOURCE
IN OUR STAFF INCLUDES HAVING
KNOWN SUPPORTS AND HAVING
SYSTEMS IN PLACE TO ACCESS THE
SUPPORT. HAVING PUSHIN SUPPORTS
INTO THE CLASSROOM AND HAVING
TIME FOR SCHOOL STAFF TO ACCESS
INFORMATION. TO SUPPORT THEIR
STUDENTS DURING THE WORK DAY
THESE ARE KEY. STEP FOUR
CONDUCT POST DISASTER SCREENING
FOLLOWS THE SITUATIONAL
SCREENING IN CINEMA COUNTY OR
COUNTY OFFICE TEAMS USE THE
CHILD PTSD SYMPTOM SCALE FIVE
THIS EVALUATES POSTTRAUMATIC
SYMPTOMS SEVERITY IN CHILDREN
ADOLESCENTS IT GIVES OUR SCHOOL
COUNSELING STAFF INDIVIDUALIZED
STUDENT DATA. STUDENTS MEETING
A THRESHOLD OF CONCERN-
PROVIDED A SHORT TERM TRAUMA
FOCUSED COGNITIVE BEHAVIORAL
THERAPY. STEP FIVE A TEAM
PLANNED ANNUAL TRAINING AND
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT THAT
INCLUDES MAINTENANCE OF SKILLS
MY SCHOOL STUFF OVER YEARS. YEP
SIX LEVERAGING THE SUPPORT AND
SERVICES AVAILABLE IRON COUNTY
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH DEPARTMENT
MEDICAL PRACTITIONERS AND
COMMUNITY BASED MENTAL HEALTH
PROVIDERS OUR WORK NOW IS
SUPPORTED THROUGH OUR RECENTLY
AWARDED IN THE CHEST A STATE
GRANT THANK YOU. AND IN A
SYSTEM WHERE GRANTS. RESOURCE
STAFF WILL PROVIDE RESOURCE
THIS RESOURCE STAFF WHO KNOW
THERE IS A SOUND SYSTEM IN
PLACE TO CARE FOR STUDENTS ARE
MORE LIKELY TO CARE FOR
OURSELVES AND IN TURN BE ABLE
TO CARE FOR CONNECT TO AND
EDUCATE OUR STATE'S CHILDREN.
AS I SIT HERE WITH ALL OF YOU
TODAY. MANY OF MY COLLEAGUES IN
EDUCATION- COPING WITH
WILDFIRES ALONG WITH THE
COMPLETE NINETEEN ENDEMIC.
DOING ALL THEY CAN TO SUPPORT
STUDENTS. HAVING A SENSE OF
AGENCY DURING A CRISIS BY THE
ADULTS IS THE BASIS OF OUR
ABILITY TO PROVIDE STUDENTS
SUPPORT IMPLEMENT CURRICULUM
ENGAGE STUDENTS IN LEARNING.
DURING THE MOST CHALLENGING F
TIMES. THIS IS THEN THE PRIMARY
GOAL FOR US HERE IN CINEMA
COUNTY TO PUT THE SYSTEM IN
PLACE FOR EDUCATORS. SO THAT WE
KNOW WHAT TO DO DURING A CRISIS
AND HOW TO DO IT TO SUPPORT OUR
STUDENTS. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME TODAY TO CONSIDER HOW A
RECURRENCE IN THE COUNTY WE
SUPPORT THE STATE'S EFFORTS IN
ENSURING OUR CHILDREN ARE ABLE
AND READY TO ENGAGE AND RE
ENGAGE WITH LEARNING. AND
CONTINUE ON THE PATH TO HEALTHY
EMOTIONAL. DEVELOPMENT IN THE
WAKE OF THE NINETEEN. THANK YOU
MISS CORE MISS CORE DUPRI. YOUR
TESTIMONY TODAY AND I KNOW I
SPEAK FOR MY COLLEGE WE TRULY
EMPATHIZE WITH. WHAT YOU AND
YOUR WHOLE DISTRICT HAD BEE
THROUGH. OUR NEXT PRESENTER IS
DR COMPLETION- RACHAEL- PLEASE
PROCEED DIRECTLY. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH IT'S BEEN A PLEASURE
TO BE HERE I'M SO HONORED TO BE
PART OF THIS HEARING AND
CONTRIBUTES A BIT BUT I WILL
GIVE JUST. A LITTLE BIT OF
BACKGROUND I AM A RESEARCHER
I'M ALSO A BOARD MEMBER OF
CASTLE THE COLLABORATIVE FOR
ACADEMIC SOCIAL EMOTIONAL
LEARNING HERE IN CHICAGO WHERE
I AM- THE NOBEL FOUNDATION
ENDOWED CHAIR IN SOCIAL
EMOTIONAL LEARNING AT THE
UNIVERSITY OF ILLINOIS AT
CHICAGO SOCKS. I FEEL LIKE I'M
A BIT OF AN OUTSIDER HERE BUT
I'LL SAY I'M A BIG FAN OF
CALIFORNIA AND HAVING RICH
RESEARCH ALL THAT YOU'RE DOING
ON SOCIAL AND EMOTIONAL
LEARNING. YOU REALLY ARE A
BEACON FOR THE NATION AND A
PROTOTYPE OF THE WAYS HE MOVED
FORWARD SO I REALLY I JUST WANT
TO CONGRATULATE EVERYONE'S
EFFORTS AND- I KNOW YOU CAN
OFTEN PICK OUT THE THINGS THAT
AREN'T WORKING BUT I WILL JUST
TELL YOU FROM OUTSIDE. YOU
REALLY ARE A LEADER IN THE
NATION IN THE FIELD OF SOCIAL
EMOTIONAL LEARNING SUCKS I'M
JUST GOING TO MENTION THREE
THINGS ONE IS I AM I HAVE BEEN
DOING RESEARCH FOR THE PAST
THIRTY PLUS YEARS ON SOCIAL
EMOTIONAL LEARNING PROGRAMS AND
PRACTICES. I SPENT MY ENTIRE
CAREER FOR STARTING OFF AS A
TEACHER IN ELEMENTARY AND- HIGH
SCHOOL TEACHER FOR AT RISK
YOUTH. AND CAME TO REALLY STUDY
SOCIAL EMOTIONAL LEARNIG
BECAUSE OF ITS FOCUS ON
PREVENTION AND I THINK THAT'S
REALLY WHAT I WANT TO EMPHASIZE
OF HOW MUCH- YOU KNOW IT IS
IMPORTANT TO ADDRESS MENTAL
HEALTH PROBLEMS BUT ALSO TO
SEE. HOW WE CAN PREVENT HEM
AND HAD THEM OFF ESPECIALLY IN
THIS UNPRECEDENTED TIME I'M
REALLY NEED INTENTIONAL
EFFORTS. MIND UP- IS A PROGRAM
WHICH I'VE BEEN DOING RESEARCH
FOR THE PAST FIFTEEN YEARS IT'S
THAT EVIDENCE BASED SOCIAL AND
EMOTIONAL LEARNING PROGRAM FOR
CHILDREN AGES THREE TO
FOURTEEN. IT IS- INVOLVES
BASICALLY THE INCORPORATION OF
NEUROSCIENCE SOCIAL EMOTIONAL
LEARNING POSITIVE PSYCHOLOGY-
AS WELL AS MINDFUL ATTENTION
AWARENESS- CHILDREN- ENGAGE IN
A NUMBER OF LESSONS ACROSS THE
SCHOOL YEAR. OR THEY LEARN
ABOUT THEIR BRAIN AND HOW THEIR
BRAIN WORKS AND IF IMPACT OF
STRESS ON THEIR BRAIN AND THEN
REALLY- DID AL. KIND OF A QUICK
A QUICK TO- WITH THE TOOLBOX.
FOR STRATEGIES TO HELP YOU L.
WITH STRESS BUT NOT ONLY- HOW
TO REDUCE YOUR STRESS BUT ALSO
HOW TO ONCE THEY LEARN THE
STRATEGIES TO REDUCE YOUR OWN
STRESS. HOW TO HEAR AND BEHIND
FOR OTHERS SO THEY ENGAGE IN.
ACTS OF GRATITUDE PERFORMING
ACTS OF KINDNESS AS WELL AS
COMMUNITY ACTION SO. THIS
PROGRAM HAS REALLY BEEN AROUND
FOR A LONG TIME IT'S- INCLUDED
IN A NUMBER OF OUR CLASSROOMS
AND SCHOOL DISTRICTS ACROSS
CALIFORNIA. AND THE RESEARCH.
WE HAVE A NUMBER OF DIFFERENT
RESEARCH STUDIES- REALLY
SHOWING IT'S AFFECTED AND NOT
ONLY REDUCING. STRESS ABOUT
REALLY PROMOTING THESE POSITIVE
HUMAN QUALITIES OF COMPASSION.
AND WELL BEING- AND ALSO HAVE
FOUND THAT INCREASES ACADEMIC
ACHIEVEMENTS- REALLY. INCLUDES
ALL OF THOSE STRATEGIES. KIND
UP IS NOW EXPANDING TO INCLUDE
A FOCUSED ON- AND FOR PARENTS
AS WELL AS- IN SPORTS AND
BEYOND. AND AND NOW FOR
TEACHERS AND THAT'S REALLY THE
SECOND POINT I WANT TO MAKE IS
ONE OF THINGS I HAVEN'T HEARD.
DISCUSSED AS MUCH AS I WOULD
LIKE IS WHAT WE KNOW FROM
RESEARCH. AND SYSTEMIC
APPROACHES TO SOCIAL EMOTIONAL
LEARNING WE NOT ONLY INCLUDE
THE PROVISION ARE THERE
OPPORTUNITIES PROMOTE THE
SOCIAL EMOTIONAL COMPETENCIES
OF STUDENTS. BUT HOW IMPORTANT
IS THAT WE PROMOTE THE WELL
BEING OF TEACHERS- WE KNOW THAT
RIGHT NOW WITH THE- RECENT RAND
STUDY. FOUND THAT- WITH THE
PANDEMIC THERE'S ACTUALLY ONE
IN FOUR TEACHERS WERE PLANNING
ON LEAVING THE PROFESSION.
WE'RE GOING TO HAVE A HUGE
TEACHER SHORTAGE AND HOW CAN
YOU HAD THAT OFF- AND WHAT WE
KNOW IT'S UNPRECEDENTED LEVELS
OF STRESS. AND WHAT I'D LIKE TO
JUST MENTION THE STUDY THAT WE
DID. A FEW YEARS AGO ABOUT
STRESS CONTAGION IN THE
CLASSROOM YES STRESS IS
CONTAGIOUS AND EVEN IF YOU'RE
NOT STRESSED. IF YOU'RE AROUND
PEOPLE WHO ARE HIGHLY STRESSED
YOU WILL CATCH IT. AND HAVE THE
NEGATIVE PHYSIOLOGICAL
CONSEQUENCES. EXAMINE THIS IN
THE CLASSROOM WE LOOKED AT PORT
THE SEVENTH GRADE CLASSROOMS.
AND HEAD TEACHERS COMPLETE A
MEASURE OF STRESS AND BURNOUT.
AND THEN FOR THE STUDENTS WE
WANT. TO GET THEIR STRESS UNDER
THE SKIN TO SEE. HOW WERE THEY
TO AND THERE'S A HORMONE
CORTISOL. WHICH YOU CAN COLLECT
AND SALIVA SO WE WENT TO THE
STUDENTS AND WE YES WE DID
COLLECT THEIR SALIVA AND JUST
SO YOU KNOW FOR THE SEVENTH
GRADE KIDS LIKE TO GIVE YOU
THEIR SPENT- AND SHIPPED TO
REALLY UNDERSTAND THEIR STRESS
PHYSIOLOGY. WHAT WE FOUND WAS
FASCINATING WE FOUND THOSE
CLASSROOMS IN WHICH THE
TEACHERS REPORTED THE HIGHEST
LEVELS OF STRESS AND BURNOUT.
HAD STUDENTS WITH THE HIGHEST
LEVEL OF STRESS. SO WHAT WE
KNOW NOW IS THAT IF YOU
ACTUALLY- HELP THE TEACHERS AND
HELP THEIR WELL BEING. THERE
WILL BE A- A RIPPLE EFFECT INTO
THE CLASSROOM FOR THE POSITIVE
WELL BEING OF STUDENTS. SO I
THINK IT'S SO IMPORTANT FOR US
TO REALLY THINK OF OUR
EDUCATORS AS WELL AS ONE. IN
WHICH I'VE BEEN DOING RESEARCH
FOR THE PAST SEVERAL YEARS IS
INCORPORATING S. YELL INTO
TEACHER PREPARATION- IF YOU
REALLY WANT TO HAVE A WIDE
SCALE- UPTAKE ACROSS. YOUR
ENTIRE STATE HOW IMPORTANT IT
IS TO ACTUALLY INTEGRATE- THE
PROMOTION OF SOCIAL EMOTIONAL
LEARNING AND MENTAL HEALTH
WITHIN. OUR TEACHER PREPARATION
AND I AND I CAN TELL YOU THE
DEGREE TO WHICH THAT IS
HAPPENING A BIT IN YOUR STATE-
AND FINALLY. MAY REALLY WANT TO
MENTION IS THIS NOTION OF
CALIFORNIA BEING A LEADER AND
THE IDEA OF ASSESSMENT IS SO
CRITICAL- AND THE IDEA- I'VE
WORKED IN- I ACTUALLY WORKED
FOR SEVERAL YEARS IN BRITISH
COLUMBIA CANADA WHERE I WAS A
PROFESSOR AT THE UNIVERSITY OF
BRITISH COLUMBIA. WHERE WE
ACTUALLY HAD A PER PROVINCE
WIDE- POPULATION MONITORING
PROBES AND CHILD WELL BEING
THAT WE DID- OVER SEVERAL YEARS
AND YOU KNOW HOW FUN AT UCLA'S
ACTUALLY FOLLOWING THAT LEAD
SO. I MAY SAY I HAD SOME GREAT
IDEAS AND THINKING ABOUT HOW DO
YOU ACTUALLY MEASURE THIS. AND
FINALLY I JUST WANT TO END WITH
ONE ONE STATEMENT AND I THINK
IT'S VERY MUCH A PART OF WHAT
YOU'RE DOING. IS THAT A SOCIAL
EMOTIONAL LEARNING IS NOT ONE
MORE THING ON TEACHERS PLAYED
IT IS ACTUALLY THE PLATE AND
SO. I JUST AM SO- JUST HONORED
TO BE HERE AND TO HEAR ABOUT
THE AMAZING EFFORTS HAPPENING.
AND LOOK FORWARD TO ANY
QUESTIONS ANYONE MIGHT YEAH
THANK YOU. THANK YOU- DOCTOR
SHOWN RADICAL- AND- NOW WE GET
TO OUR LAST PRESENTER- DOCTOR
STEPHEN EDELSTEIN. AND EMILY.
IS STEPHEN AND ADAMANT ON AND
WE PLAYED FOR SIX. SO MUCH OF
REALLY REALLY QUICK BECAUSE YOU
NEED TO HEAR FROM THE FAMILY
SO- I JUST WANT TO SAY A COUPLE
THINGS YOU KNOW I EIGHT- I'M
NOT SOME PSYCHIATRIST AT
STANFORD I WORKED IN SCHOOL
MENTAL HEALTH FOR MANY YEARS AS
A DIRECTOR OF SCHOOL MENTAL
HEALTH PROGRAMS IN NEW MEXICO
AND AS A NATIONAL CONSULTANT
AND I JUST WANT TO SAY I'M
EXCITED TO SEE THE WORK THAT'S
HAPPENING HERE ACROSS
CALIFORNIA A LOT OF THE EFFORTS
SO WE'VE ALSO BEEN INVOLVED IN
A- REVOLVED AROUND YOU SUICIDE
PREVENTION. WORKING WITH TRIBAL
PROGRAMS. AND I WILL TELL YOU
THAT YOU KNOW AS AS I'VE KIND
OF MOVED TO CALIFORNIA. I'VE
BEEN SO GRATEFUL TO SEE THE
SUPPORT FOR SCHOOL MENTAL
HEALTH IT'S BEEN DEVELOPING
NOW. I'M CONCERNED ABOUT THE
NEED TO CONTINUE TO EXPAND
INFRASTRUCTURE SUPPORT FOR THE
BROAD BASED IMPLEMENTATION. OF
MODELS AND PROGRAMS AND ONE OF
THINGS I WOULD SHARE WITH YOU
TODAY IS THAT WE'RE REALLY
TRYING TO LOOK AT FROM A PUBLIC
HEALTH PERSPECTIVE. HOW DO WE
BUILD A CONTINUUM OF EARLY
INTERVENTION MENTAL HEALTH
SUPPORT FOR YOUNG PEOPLE. FROM
SCHOOL MENTAL HEALTH TO OTHER
MODELS I THE COMMUNITY HAS
BEEN DISCUSSED EARLIER ONE OF
THE MODELS WE'VE REALLY BEEN
INVOLVED IN THROUGH THE SUPPORT
FROM. ALL OF YOU IN THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE AND ME ALWAYS
SEE HAS BEEN AROUND THE DROPOUT
PREVENTION FINDS. IN DEVELOPING
THE ALL CODES MODEL OF
INTEGRATED YOUTH MENTAL HEALTH
SUPPORT. AND THESE ARE MODELS
AND SITES THAT ARE DEVELOPING
ACROSS THE STREET. WITH THE
NOTION OF BEING ABLE TO LINK
EARLY MENTAL HEALTH SUPPORT.
EARLY PRIMARY CARE VERY MUCH
LIKE THE SCHOOL BASED HEALTH
CENTER MODEL AND REFERENCING
THE ROLE. AS A SENATOR PAN
MENTION OF PRIMARY CARE AS
CRITICAL PARTNERS. BUT ALSO WAS
SUPPORTED EDUCATION SUPPORTED
EMPLOYMENT SUPPORT. PEER
SUPPORT AS WELL FOR EARLY
SUPPORT FOR YOUNG PEOPLE IN THE
COMMUNITY THAT CAN LINK TO
SCHOOLS. AS PART OF AN
EFFECTIVE COMFORTABLE PLACE AS
WAS MENTIONED BEFORE AN
ADDITIONAL TRUSTED PLACE TO
SCHOOLS. FOR YOUNG PEOPLE TO
COME IN FOR EARLY CARE. WHAT'S
BEING CRITICAL ABOUT DEVELOPING
THIS MODEL HAS BEEN THE ROLE OF
THE YOUTH VOICE. IN DEVELOPING
THE SERVICES AND WE TALKED
ABOUT THE IMPORTANCE OF THE
YOUTH PERSPECTIVE. TODAY ON
SCHOOL MENTAL HEALTH SUPPORTS.
SO REALLY EMILY IS GOING TO
SPEAK TO THAT IMPORTANCE. OF
THE ROLE OF THE USER VOICE IN
DEVELOPING ALL CALLED MODELS
AND- THE INTEGRATION WITH
SCHOOLS AND WHY THAT'S JUST SO
CRITICAL. SO EMILY LET ME HAND
THINGS OVER TO YOU. I THINK
IT'S AT ALL SAY THANK TO
EVERYONE HERE THE SENATOR ND
ALL THE ADULT B. R. PANEL HERE
YOUR AMAZING SOME- I WAS A
SENIOR IN HIGH SCHOOL I CAN SAY
THAT I'M SO HONORED AND SO
GRATEFUL THAT STUDENT AND YOUR
DENTAL HEALTH IS BECOMING MORE
AND MORE DISCUSSED IN OUR
SOCIETY HAS BECOME A MORE
SUPPORT IN OUR COMMUNITY- BRIEF
INTERACT ENGINE INTRODUCTION
SORRY- I'M PART OF THE- YOUTH
ADVISORY GROUP AND ACTS OF COKE
SO I AM ALONG WITH. AROUND
TWENTY FOUR OTHERS USE WE GOT
TWO POINTS DECISIONS AND I CAN
SAY THE OUTCOME HAS BEEN TRULY
SOMETHING UNIQUE AND SOMETHING
THAT HAS BEEN COMPLETELY
DIFFERENT TO ANYTHING ELSE I'VE
BEEN PART OF MY WHOLE LIFE SO
FIRST AND FOREMOST- OUTCOME HAS
REALLY PROVIDED THE CONFIDENCE
AND EMPOWERMENT AND THE
VALIDATION THAT YOU REALLY NEED
TO BE ABLE TO ADVOCATE FOR
THEIR OWN NEEDS AN ADVOCATE FOR
THEIR APPEARANCE NEEDS. AND
SOMETHING THAT'S REALLY AWESOME
ABOUT THE YOUR DEVICE A GROUP
THAT I'M PART OF IS THAT WE GOT
TO INFLUENCE THESE LARGE
DECISIONS THAT WE'VE NEVER
REALLY THOUGHT ABOUT AND
WHENEVER WE'VE TAKEN A
LEADERSHIP ROLE WE GOT TO
INFLUENCE HOW THE SITE LOOKS
LIKE WHAT- HOW YOURS ARE
TREATED AND THE INSIGHT HOW-
LIKE THE CONFIDENTIALITY HOW
SAFE THEY FEEL IN THE SIDE
WHETHER OR NOT THERE ARE
CAMERAS IN CERTAIN PLACES. AND
YOU KNOW WHAT THE WEBSITE LOOKS
LIKE OR WHAT THE LOGO LOOKS
LIKE- YEAH HOW HOW THEY ARE
DRESSED LIKE NITTY GRITTY NITTY
GRITTY DETAILS ALL THE WAY TO
THE TOP WHERE INVOLVED AND
WE'RE SO ONORED TO BE ABLE TO
DO THAT BECAUSE THAT'S TRULY.
UNIQUE I'VE NEVER SEEN THAT
BEFORE. OUR OPINION AND GOALS
AND NEEDS ALSO IN. VALIDATED
AND I'LL GO AND WHETHER OR NOT
THAT'S IN. KIND OF MARTIN
LUTHER SIDE AS A ADVISORY GROUP
MEMBER. AS A SERVICE- SOMEONE
WHO IS ACCESSING SERVICES YOUR
GOALS ARE HEARD. THERE ARE ARE
SO MANY PEOPLE THAT ARE THERE.
THAT MAKE UP A COHESIVE
COMMUNITY WHO ARE THERE TO
SUPPORT YOUR NEEDS AND TO
LISTEN. AND TO TRULY BE PART OF
A CONVERSATION THAT. THAT'S I'M
WORKING TOWARDS A MUTUAL GOAL
OF. YOUR MENTAL WELLNESS
WHETHER REGARDLESS OF WHAT THAT
LOOKS LIKE SH- AND BEING PART
OF THE YOUTH ADVISOR GROUP HAS
ALSO DEINITELY REALLY HELPED
ME FEEL MORE ORGANIZED. I A
AUTONOMY OR THAT I FEEL THAT I
HAVE MORE AGENCY AND- BEING
ABLE TO EXECUTE MY GOALS SO
BEFORE I DON'T KNOW WHAT BEFORE
I DIDN'T KNOW SAY LIKE D. D. E.
R. LAWS OR REGULATIONS BEHIND
WHAT I MAY WANT TO DO FOR MY
COMMUNITY OR- WHETHER OR NOT I
WOULD FEEL I WOULD BE- MY
CONFIDENTIALITY WOULD BE
RESPECTED IF I WERE TO. SAY
ACCESS THERAPY MYSELF SO I
COULD DEFINITELY PROVIDES THAT
AND I KNOW THAT YOU OFTEN FEEL
UNSURE OR INSECURE ABOUT
ACCESSING SERVICES BECAUSE OF
THE- MARK WHAT'S TRANSPARENT
SIDE ABOUT ACCESSING SERVICES
AND- I CAN ASSURE YOU CAN CHECK
OUT FOR YOU- I WOULD ALSO SAY
THAT OUTCOME HAS HELPED ME.
TAKE BETTER CARE OF MYSELF AND
ALSO OTHERS WE HAVE TRAININGS
AND SO MANY OTHER AMAZING
OPPORTUNITIES THAT- HELP ME
SUPPORT MYSELF AND OTHERS
INCLUDING ONE ANOTHER YEAR FROM
MY PEERS OR JUST. MY FAMILY
MEMBERS OR OTHER PEOPLE AROUND
ME. AND IT'S ALSO DEFINITELY ME
IN THE- SENSE OF SELF CARE AND
CARE IN GENERAL. IS THAT ON
MANTA HOLD REALLY LOOKS
DIFFERENT FOR EVERY SINGLE
PERSON SO. I'M SO HONORED AND
GRATEFUL THAT I GET TO BE PART
OF THIS GROUP BECAUSE I LEARNED
FROM SO MANY OTHER PEOPLE AND I
GOT TO SPEAK WITH SO MANY.
STRONG AND LIKE PASSIONATE
PEOPLE WHO HAVE SUCH DIVERSE
EXPERIENCES AND BACKGROUNDS.
BUT THEY EACH HAVE SOMETHING
ELSE TO BRING FROM THE TABLE
AND I BELIEVE THAT REALLY IS. A
VITAL STEP IN OUR COMMUNITY TO.
DEVELOP THE BEST- SERVICES THAT
CAN BE TAILORED TO VARIOUS
PEOPLE REGARDLESS OF WHERE YOU
ARE AT. THE HOUSE SH. AND
FINALLY I WOULD SAY- CODE HAS
BEEN THE PROVIDE AN EDUCATION
AND THE COMMUNITY THAT I NEED
TO. REALLY UNDERSTAND MENTAL
HEALTH WHETHER OR NOT THAT'S
HOW I'M GONNA SUPPORT MYSELF OR
OTHERS. SO WHEN I FIRST JOINED
SOMETHING THAT I HAD LEARNED IS
THAT- SO. HEARING FROM EVERYONE
HERE I MAYBE IT MAYBE OR MAYBE
NOT YOU PART OF THIS. BUT I
LEARNED THAT HALF OF ALL MENTAL
HEALTH CONDITIONS BEGIN UP.
BEGIN AT THE AGE OF FOURTEEN
SO. ON WHETHER OR NOT YOU KNOW
SOMEONE PERSONALLY WHO IS
FOURTEEN YEARS OLD- I GUESS
I'LL REMIND YOU THAT FOURTEEN
IS GENERALLY THE AGE FOR MOST
USE. WHEN YOU'RE TRANSITIONING
BETWEEN MIDDLE AND HIGH SCHOOL.
SO- I THINK IF I AN **** I CAN.
LIKE I TRUST THAT YOU CAN MAYBE
TRY TO REMEMBER THAT A PRETTY
DIFFICULT TIME. YOU'RE FACING
PHYSICAL AND MENTAL AND-
EMOTIONAL CHALLENGES OF THAT'S
LIKE. YOU KNOW YOU'RE
TRANSITIONING INTO A COMPLETELY
NEW ENVIRONMENT WHICH IS HIGH
SCHOOL THAT GIVES YOU A
DEFINITE. AND YOU'RE IN A NEW
ENVIRONMENT WITH YOUR PEERS NEW
TEACHERS NEW CLASSES SO MANY
DIFFERENT THINGS THAT ARE BEING
THROWN AT YOU AND THEN YOU'RE
ALSO BEING. YOU'RE ALSO TRYING
TO NAVIGATE WHO YOU ARE AS A
PERSON AND HOW YOU WANT TO
OPERATE AND FUNCTION. AS THEIR
OWN SELVES IN THIS. VAST
COMMUNITY ABOUT SOCIETY. SO THE
FACT THAT MENTAL HEALTH
CONDITIONS STARTED SUCH A YOUNG
AGE AND THEN. YET SO LIKE AS
RARELY TALK ABOUT I DIDN'T KNOW
ABOUT THAT STATISTIC UNTIL
UNTIL LAST YEAR WHEN I JOINED
TACOS. IT REALLY LIKE SHOCKED
ME IN AND- REALLY BROUGHT TO MY
ATTENTION THE WIDESPREAD ISSUE
THAT YOU DON'T HAVE THE
COMMUNITY ABOUT THE NEED TO
RELY ON. AND ESPECIALLY IN THAT
TRANSITION TRANSITIONING AGE
BETWEEN MIDDLE AND HIGH SCHOOL
NOW I WANT TO TRANSITION FROM
BACK INTO HOW- RETURNING BACK
TO SCHOOL IS A WHOLE OTHER
TRANSITION. TRANSITIONING
PROCESS I CAN BE A LARGE
CHALLENGE SO. AFTER OVER A YEAR
OF BEING AND THE PANDEMIC WE I
KNOW WE'VE ALL BEEN TALKING
ABOUT- I MEAN THIS IS THE NEW
NORMAL. AND SO NOW WE HAVE TO
RE ADOPT TO WHAT IT USED TO BE
LIKE OR WHAT WHAT'S THE CLOSEST
TO WHAT IT USED TO BE LIKE
THERE'S A WHOLE NEW LEVEL OF
DEMAND AND- HOW YOU'RE GOING TO
PERFORM PERFORM ACADEMICALLY.
WHAT KIND OF LEARNING STYLE
YOU'LL BE AND WHETHER OR NOT
YOU'RE GOING BACK TO SCHOOL
YOU'RE STILL STAYING ONLINE.
THE SOCIAL SOCIALIZATION OF
THINGS OPEN BACK UP THERE ARE
SO MANY THINGS FOR YOU TO BE
INSECURE ABOUT. ALONG WITH.
ANYONE REALLY THERE ARE SO MANY
THINGS THAT. WERE UNSURE ABOUT
THAT MAY BE WHETHER OR NOT
PEOPLE IN YOUR SCHOOL ARE
UNVACCINATED OR- THE DELTA AREA
AS A WHOLE OTHER ISSUE AND IF
YOU EVER EXPERIENCED THINGS
LIKE SOCIAL ANXIETY OR TO
SOMEBODY AND BEING AROUND
PEOPLE. REGARDLESS OF AGE TO
WHAT EXTENT THERE ARE SO MANY
THINGS THAT YOU MIGHT BE
ANXIOUS ABOUT AND- NEWS I THINK
WE REALLY NEED TO FEEL
VALIDATED. AND LIKE- PREVIOUS
COUNCIL ALSO MENTIONED SALUTE
SO DID THE TEACHERS AND- I
REALLY COMMEND TEACHERS FOR
ALWAYS BEING THERE FOR THE
STUDENTS. AND I'M REALLY
THANKFUL FOR THAT. SO LIKE I
SAID I. WANT EVERYONE TO KEEP
IN MIND THAT THIS IS A- A
CENTRALLY IN YOUR ENVIRONMENT
BECAUSE WE'VE BEEN USED TO IT
FOR. ALMOST TWO YEARS. AND YEAH
IT'S IMPORTANT TO VALIDATE YOU
THREE YEARS FOUND THIS
TRANSITION IS INTIMIDATING. AND
PLEASE BE OKAY REGARDLESS OF
WHO YOU ARE WHETHER OR NOT YOUR
NEWS OR STUDENT OR- ADULT. Z.
OKAY WITH BEING. PERFORMING AT
A DIFFERENT LEVEL BECAUSE IT'S
A COMPLETELY DIFFERENT
ENVIRONMENT AND I WOULD LIKE TO
SAY THAT. I THINK WHAT WE NEED
TO LOOK FORWARD TO IS HOW WE'RE
GOING TO. MAKE THIS TRANSITION
LESS OF A BLIND JUMP INTO A
COMPLETELY NEW ENVIRONMENT
WHERE WE FEEL INSECURE. AND
MORE OF A SMOOTH PATH WHERE WE
HAVE RESOURCES TO FALL BACK ON.
WHEREVER YOU ARE OR WE FORCE IT
RESOURCES TO LOOK FORWARD TO
EVERY STEP OF THE WAY. SO IN
ORDER TO FEEL SECURE I FEEL
LIKE THERE SHOULD BE SOMETHING.
FOR EVERYONE TO LOOK TOWARDS-
I'D ALSO LIKE SAY. ON OF
VISIBILITY IS VERY VITAL AND- I
KNOW THAT THINGS HAVE BEEN
IMPROVING THIS YEAR AND I'VE
SEEN THAT IN MY OWN SCHOOL.
SCHOOLS MUST BE DOING BETTER
THAN JUST FOR EXAMPLE PRINTING
A SUICIDE PREVENTION HOTLINE
NUMBER ON THE BACK OF STUDENT
ID CARDS THAT'S VERY PASSIVE WE
DON'T SEE IT OFTEN DEPENDING ON
WHAT SCHOOL YOU GO TO YOU MIGHT
NOT USE YOUR ID CARDS VERY
OFTEN. AND IT JUST BEING THERE
AND I WAS NOT GETTING TO KNOW
WHAT IS ON THOSE CARDS WHAT
EXACTLY THAT ENTAILS IF I WERE
TO CALL THIS NUMBER WHAT HOPE
WHAT I RECEIVED OR- WHEN THEY
ACTUALLY PICK UP OR WOULD THEY
ACT WHEN THEY PUT ME ON HOLD
WHAT. YOU KNOW WHAT RESOURCES
WHEN THEY BE OFFERING TO ANSWER
THIS CONVERSATION ABOUT AND
THIS OCCASION ABOUT THESE MEN
ABOUT MENTAL HEALTH AND MENTAL
HEALTH RESOURCES THAT YOU CAN
CURRENTLY ACCESS AND WHAT WE'RE
WORKING TOWARDS MUST BE
NORMALIZED SO THAT TEACHERS AND
STUDENTS ALIKE CAN FEEL SECURE
ABOUT WHAT WHAT THEY HAVE. AT.
THEIR DISCRETION OR AT. AT THE
OTHER THING- YEAH SO AGAIN WITH
BEING PROACTIVE I REALLY THINK
THAT. REGARDLESS OF IF YOU'RE
THINKING ABOUT MORE OF THE ACT
DON'T MAKE SENSE OR IN THE
MENTAL HEALTH PROBLEMS WE'VE
REALLY BEEN TRYING TO REACH
STUDENTS WHERE THEY ARE SO I
CAN BE AN ACADEMIC SENSE FOR
EXAMPLE OFFERING MORE OFFICE
HOURS FOR TUTORING. OR ONLINE
RESOURCES VIDEOS LECTURES
WEBSITES SO ON AND SO FORTH OR
EVEN JUST KEEPING YOUR DOOR
OPEN BETWEEN PASSENGERS OR
LUNCH OR BRUNCH THE SITE YOU
KNOW THAT THERE ARE. THERE ARE
THINGS THAT THEY CAN ACCESS IF
THEY NEED IT. IN SCHOOL- MENTAL
HEALTH RESOURCES. I'VE SEEN
THAT IT'S BECOMING MORE AND
MORE POPULAR RECENTLY WHICH I'M
REALLY GRATEFUL FOR BUT WHEN
IT. COMES LOOSE CLINICIANS
SOCIAL WORKERS PSYCHIATRISTS OR
EVEN JUST WORKSHOPS THAT ARE.
CREATED BY GUEST SPEAKERS OR-
JUST. EARLY MENTAL HEALTH AND
EDUCATION WILL REALLY BENEFIT.
BECAUSE WE WELL UNDERSTAND WHAT
WORK RACE AND WILL KNOW. THAT
IT'S NOT IT'S VALID BECAUSE-
EVERYONE HAS MENTAL HEALTH AND-
WE I THINK WE HAVE THE SUBWAY
FROM THE IDEA THAT- MENTAL
HEALTH HAS ONE STRICT
DEFINITION OR ABOUT IT LIKE IF
IT. FITS INTO THIS ONE SPECIFIC
BOX BECAUSE IT REALLY DOESN'T
BECAUSE IT CAN. COME IN MANY
SHAPES AND FORMS DEPENDING ON
HOW YOU'RE BROUGHT UP OR MAYBE
EVEN JUST. YOU KNOW JUST LIKE
COMMUNITY FACTORS. A LITTLE
HELP IS THERE ANY TO CUT YOU
OFF THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR-
REALLY IS APPRECIATED REALLY IS
INSIGHTFUL. WE ARE ENFORCING
COMING UP. ON THE ADVERTISEMENT
ALSO THANK. ALL OF THE SEVEN
OTHER PETITIONS BECAUSE THE
OTHER TWO PANELS WE HAVE TIME
FOR ALL OF I THINK TWO
QUESTIONS. FROM MY COLLEAGUE
SENATOR PENN  SEE YOU MR DALIO
TO USE A LET'S START WITH
SENATOR PAN- FOR ANY OF THE
PANELISTS. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
AND PERHAPS MORE A COMMENT AND
A QUESTION- I WOULD MAKE NOTE
OF THAT- MR OF THE ATI
LEGISLATIVE CAUCUS THAT-
WINDOWS THAT ACTUALLY- ASIAN
AMERICAN STUDENTS ARE FAR MORE
LIKELY TO BE LEARNING REMOTELY-
THAN ANY OTHER RACIAL ETHNIC
GROUP IN THE UNITED STATES
ISN'T BORN OUT OF THE DATA.
BECAUSE NOT ONLY DID FREIGHT OF
COVETED- ARE CONCERNED ABOUT
COVE IT HAS LIKE MANY OTHER
PARENTS- ALSO BECAUSE OF THE
HATE DIRECTED TOWARD. ATI
STUDENTS SENT IT AND H. I.
COMMUNITY AND SO I THINK AS
WE'RE LOOKING AT- PROVIDING
ACCESS TO MENTAL HEALTH
RESOURCES. WE HAVE TO LOOK
THINK ABOUT IT'S NOT ONLY FOR
THE STUDENTS TO ACTUALLY SHOP
FOR IN PERSON LEARNING IT'S
ALSO OPTIONS FOR DISTANCE
LEARNING AND ALSO PROVIDING
THOSE SUPPORTS FOR DISTANCE
LEARNING AS WELL. AND CREATING
A VERY SAFE ENVIRONMENT IN THE
SCHOOLS SO- IN TERMS OF THE
MENTAL HEALTH SUPPORT. WHEAT
AND FORTUNE WE DON'T ONLY HAVE
A VIRAL PANDEMIC WE ALSO HAVE A
HEAT CAN DAMAGE. AND FOR CITY
H. I. COMMUNE'S PARTICULARLY
BEEN TARGETED- AS AND UNFAIRLY
BLAMED US FOR THIS PANDEIC AND
SO THIS IS CAUSING. IT AND THIS
IS IN A GROUP OF. PEOPLE WHO
USUALLY YOU KNOW THINK ABOUT
ALL THERE TO WANT TO ALWAYS
WANT TO GO TO SCHOOL AND THE
FACT IS THE DATA SHOWS THAT
MUCH LESS LIKELY TO ACTUALLY GO
TO IN PERSON LEARNING SO I HOPE
THAT- I KNOW WE'RE VERY SHORT
TIME BUT I HOPE THAT- I KNOW
OUR PANELISTS AND EDUCATION
COMMITTEE WILL BE THINKING VERY
CAREFULLY ABOUT HOW WE CAN
ADDRESS THIS ISSUE AND I KNOW
THAT OUR STATE BUDGET WE AS
PART OF THE THAI EQUITY BUDGET
AS WELL- ALLOCATE SOME MONEY.
THAT'S RIGHT THE DIRECT MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES BUT TO HELP
SCHOOLS I FIGURE THIS OUT AND
THEY GET SOME RESOURCES THERE
AS WELL THANK YOU. THANK YOU
DOCTOR WILL WILL PUT ADDITIONAL
DOLLARS. THANK THANK MY OWN
THANK YOU THANK YOU MR CHAIR AS
WELL AS A- EMILY THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TESTIMONY I THINK THAT WAS
OUTSTANDING OBVIOUSLY NO
ISOLATION IS THE NUMBER ONE ONE
OF THE NUMBER ONE REASONS FOR A
DEPRESSION AND THE LIKE SO-
ALCO IS IT A GREAT ORGANIZATION
I'M EXCITED TO SEE THAT HAPPEN.
MY QUESTION IS TO AND I WAS
REALLY IMPRESSED BY THE SLIDES
THAT ALEX I BELIEVE WAS ALEX
THAT 2% OF THOSE SLIDES VERY
IMPRESSED BY THAT IN YOUR
HISTORY OF SHOWING US THAT EVEN
PRIOR PANDEMIC WE HAD LOTS OF
ISSUES THAT- WE SHOULD'VE BEEN
ADDRESSING. AS LEGISLATORS WE
ALLOCATE MONEY THAT'S REALLY
WHAT WE DO WE ALLOCATE THE
MONEY AND WE TRY TO FIGURE OUT
THE POLICY BUT WE'RE REALLY.
NOT EXPERTS IN ALL FIELDS WERE
WERE JACKS OF ALL TRADES WE
KNOW A LITTLE BIT ABOUT A LOT
OF THINGS AND SOME OF US ARE
EXPERTS IN ONE AREA BUT FOR
THOSE OF US WHO ARE NOT AN
EXPERT IN- THE HEALTH- ONLY. BY
OBSERVANCE OR DEALING WITH OUR
OWN FAMILY MEMBERS ARE
CONSTITUENTS. IF MONEY WAS NOT
A FACTOR. AND PAUL AS IT WERE-
IS THERE SOME PROGRAMS THAT YOU
COULD POINT US TO AND I THINK
ALEX MIGHT BE THE BEST ONE TO
ANSWER THIS THAT ACTUALLY WORK
THAT WE WERE WE ACTUALLY HEAL
PEOPLE- AND THERE'S A FORMULA
I'M LOOKING FOR- SOMETHING WE
IS WHAT WORKS IF WE HAD ALL
THE- IF WE HAD EVERYTHING WE
NEEDED THIS IS HOW THIS WOULD
BE THE PERFECT MODEL DO YOU
HAVE THAT INFORMATION. SO THAT
WE COULD THEN ANALYZE AND
FIGURE OUT HOW WE WOULD THEN.
ALLOCATE THE RESOURCES TO GET
THERE. I'LL BE VERY BRIEF BUT
THE ANSWER IS YES YES YES. WE
KNOW THAT CULTURALLY RELEVANT
BEHAVIOR HEALTH SUPPORTS THAT A
RELATIONSHIP BASED. IMPROVE
SCHOOL SUCCESS. IMPROVE
EDUCATIONAL ATTAINMENT IMPROVE
LIFE OUTCOMES AND ARE ESSENTIAL
TO HEALTHY GROWTH AND
DEVELOPMENT OF CHILDREN. I WILL
SEND A COUPLE SLIDES TO THE
STAFF AND INTERACTING WITH JUST
SO YOU CAN SEE A LIST OF FOUR
EVIDENCE BASED PRACTICES. HOW
COOL IS AN EXCELLENT EXAMPLE.
OF THESE TYPE OF SERVICES THE
CHALLENGE AND I THINK IT WAS
NAMED BY EMILY AND SOME OF THE
OTHER SPEAKERS WHAT WE SAY IS
THERAPIST IS ALL THERAPEUTIC
GAME PRESUPPOSES THERAPEUTIC
ALLIANCE. IT DOESN'T MATTER HOW
GOOD IF THEY'RE TOO SHORT TO
KEEP ONE TALK TO YOU. SO THE
ESSENTIAL CHALLENGE FOR US IS
IN DO WE HAVE MODELS THAT WORK.
IS CAN WE FINANCE THEM. AND
PLACE THEM WHERE YOUNG PEOPLE
WILL ACCESS SEVEN. DELIVERED BY
PEOPLE WHO LOOK LIKE THEM AND
YOU CAN GENERATE TRUST AN
ALLIANCE WITH THEM. AWESOME I
WOULD REALLY LOOK FORWARD TO
SEEING THAT SO THAT WE AS
LEGISLATORS CAN. RESEARCH THAT
INFORMATION. AND PUT IN A MALL
I'M A FARMER I KNOW IF YOU HAVE
SUNLIGHT WATER AND GET SO-
YOU'RE GONNA GROW CROP DOWN
OBVIOUSLY THERE'S SOME
VARIABLES IN THERE. AND
ANOTHER'S VARIABLES IN
DIFFERENT PARTS OF THE STATE
BUT IF WE HAVE THOSE BASIC
THINGS AS LEGISLATORS THEN WE
CAN THEN TRY TO FIGURE OUT HOW
TO GET THOSE TOOLS. RESOURCES
TO MAKE THOSE TOOLS AVAILABLE
FOR YOU SO I APPRECIATE ALL
THAT THE TESTIMONY IT WAS A
VERY- LEARNING AND I LOOK FOR
THOSE- BE HAVING AVAILABLE THE
SLIDES THAT WERE AVAILABLE
THOSE I THINK WERE VERY
IMPACTFUL LEAST WHAT I COULD
READ FROM THIS DISTANCE- SO I
APPRECIATE THAT THANK YOU. BOTH
TO MY CO CHAIRS- THAT TO PUT
THIS COMMITTEE TOGETHER SEE
WERE THE LAST ONES HERE ALSO.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MISTER
BRISKET THANK YOU THAT
STANDARDIZED THAT'S ACTUALLY
VERY PROBABLY A GOOD AND
APPROPRIATE NOTE TO END ON- I
WANT TO FIRST THANK AND
APOLOGISE TO EVERYONE CALLED
IN. TO PARTICIPATE IN PUBLIC
TESTIMONY TO HIM UNFORTUNATELY
OUT OF TIME IF YOU WERE NOT
ABLE WHICH YOU WERE NOT. AS IF
YOU'RE NOT ABLE TO VIEW THE
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE WE WOULD
ASK THAT YOU PLEASE SUBMIT YOUR
COMMENTS OR SUGGESTIONS IN
WRITING. TO THE COMMITTEE AT
THE FOLLOWING EMAIL ADDRESS
THAT IS S. C. P. E. R. AT S. C.
N. DOT CA DOT GOV THAT'S . C.
P. E. R. FOR THE SENATE
COMMITTEE ON PANDEMIC MERGER
RESPONSE. AT SEN DOT CA DOT
GOV. THE LINK IS ALSO ON OUR
WEBSITE. YEAH AND NOW I WANT TO
I'M LOOKING FOR SENATOR LEYVA.
THERE SO I WOULD. I'M SORRY SO
WE HAVE TO DO PUBLIC COMMENT
WE'RE GONNA GIVE. TEN MINUTES
OF PUBLIC COMMENT I DO
APOLOGIZE- WE ARE BOTH BEING
TOLD TO LEAVE THE ROOM BUT TO
DO THIS AS WELL. SO IF YOU HAVE
CALLED IN AND YOU'RE STILL ON
THE LINE. MCMASTER MODERATE IF
YOU COULD PLEASE GIVE
INSTRUCTIONS. FOR FOLKS FROM
THE PUBLIC TO COMMENT- WE WERE
LIMITED COMMENTS TO TEN
COMMENTS- AND ONE MINUTE EACH.
ABSOLUTELY I THANK YOU MR CHAIR
IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO MAKE
PUBLIC COMMENTS AT THIS TIME
PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY
THE ZERO. NINE AT T. OPERATORS
GOING TO GO AND GIVE YOUR LINE
NUMBER OFFLINE AND THEN PLACED
BACK INTO THE QUEUE. SO AGAIN
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS
TIME TO MAKE PUBLIC COMMENT-
PERSPECTIVES THAT IS LINE
TWENTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. L. ERIN
HAPPY WITH PUBLIC ADVOCATE
THANK YOU FOR HOLDING THIS
HEARING AND EMPHASIZING STUDENT
MENTAL HEALTH SOCIAL EMOTIONAL
WELL BEING WILL BE OPEN IN
PERSON THIS FALL WITH ALL THAT
MANY DISTRICTS AROUND THE STATE
HAVE COMMITTED TO A RESTORATIVE
RETURNED TO SCHOOL WITH A FOCUS
ON REBUILDING STRONG
RELATIONSHIPS AND CREATING SAFE
AND INCLUSIVE LEARNING
ENVIRONMENT. MAINTAINING A
POSITIVE SCHOOL CLIMATE IS
FOUNDATIONAL FOR STUDENT
ACHIEVEMENT FOR STUDENTS TO
ENGAGE FULLY IMMERSIVE AND
RIGOROUS LEARNING BASICS WHAT
VIRGIN BRADY ABUNDANT STATE AND
FEDERAL FUNDING THEY HAVE
RECEIVED THIS YEAR TO CREATE
VIBRANT RACIALLY CHAT AND
RELATIONSHIPS THAT ARE
COMMUNITY SCHOOL. IN ADDITION
TO THE THREE BILLION DOLLARS
PROVIDED TO COMMUNITY SCHOOL
FIFTEEN PEOPLE LIVE IN THE
MULTI BILLION DOLLAR INVESTMENT
AND MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES
SOCIAL EMOTIONAL LEARNING AND
TRAUMA INFORMED PRACTICES IN
USING ADDITIONAL LPS HAUNTED
TAKING FUNDING TO HIRE AND
TRAIN STAFF TO SUPPORT HIGH
NEED STUDENTS. TO INSURE
HYUNDAI SANTA FE ACTIVELY AND
ADDRESS THE URGENT NEEDS OF
STUDENTS ALL OF US MEANINGFULLY
ENGAGE WITH STUDENTS FAMILIES
EDUCATORS AND COMMUNITY
STAKEHOLDERS EARLY AND OFTEN IN
COLLABORATIVE VISION MAKING THE
PLAN HOW TO INVEST DOLLARS FOR
TRANSFORMATIVE CHANGE INCLUDING
A DISTRICT COMPLETE THERE AFTER
THREE SPENDING. PLANS DUE IN
OCTOBER THANK YOU. THANK YOU I
THINK WHAT WE WE'RE WE'RE SET
WE'RE ALTER HERE I'VE- THAT WE
DO HAVE MEMBERS OF. IN THE- IF
YOU ARE IN THE GALLERY YOU LIKE
TO COME IN PUBLICLY. YOU CAN
SEE THE MARKET IS TO YOUR
RIGHT- PLEASE. MAKE A LINE IN
FRONT OF THE MICROPHONE- AND WE
WELCOME YOUR PUBLIC COME IN
THEY WILL GO BACK. TO CALLERS
ON THE PHONE. PLEASE PROCEED.
HI MY NAME IS SHANNON PRIMETIME
WITH EDUCATE ADVOCATE AND I'M A
SPECIAL EDUCATION PARALEGAL AND
I'D LIKE TO ADDRESS THE MENTAL
HEALTH OF OUR STUDENTS WHO
CANNOT WEAR MASKS AND WHO ARE
NOW BEING SEGREGATED AND
DISCRIMINATED AGAINST IN THEIR
SCHOOLS THEY STILL IF THEY HAVE
A P. STILL HAVE AN EDUCATIONAL
RIGHT TO BE WITH THEIR PEERS
AND WE'RE HOPING THAT PEOPLE
WILL ACKNOWLEDGE THAT. AND THEN
ALSO ARE SEVERELY DISABLED
CHILDREN WHO LOST TO YOUR
SCHOOL ALL OTHER KIDS ARE
ALLOWED TO BE HELD BACK A YEAR
BUT OUR KIDS WILL NOT KING THAT
YEAR BACK AT AT TWENTY TWO WILL
STILL BE ACCIDENT HOW WILL WE
BE HANDLINGARE SEVERELY
DISABLED KIDS. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH- ANYBODY ELSE IN THE
GALLERY WHO'S INTERESTED IN
MAKING PUBLIC COMMENT PLEASE
THANK YOU TO MY PHONE PLEASE
PROCEED. YOU HAVE ONE MINUTE.
HI MY NAME'S NICOLE YOUNG AND
I'M WITH THE NATIONAL
ORGANIZATION CALLED MOMS FOR
LIBERTY. WE ARE AN ORGANIZATION
THAT IS AN ADVOCATE FOR
CHILDREN IN EDUCATION. AND
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES WOULD
NOT BE NEEDED IF THE MEMBERS OF
THIS COMMITTEE WOULD OPEN
SCHOOLS MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES
ARE TOO LATE FOR THE CHILDREN
WHO DIED BY SUICIDE OR FELL SO
FAR BEHIND IN SCHOOL THEY ARE
LOST FOREVER. WE DON'T NEED
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES ON
CAMPUS WE NEED THE SENATE
COMMITTEE TO STOP TAKING MONEY
FROM SPECIAL INTEREST GROUPS
AND GET PEOPLE IN THE STATE
HOUSE TO ACTUALLY CARE ABOUT
CHILDREN. AND THE QUALITY OF
THEIR EDUCATION WE SAW THE
SIGHTS FROM AD ALEX FIND THAT
THE INCREASE IN SUICIDES AND
MENTAL HEALTH HOSPITALIZATIONS
<c.cyan>OR CHILDREN. AND NOW YOU ARE</c>
ALL SITTING HERE TRYING TO
CLEAN UP YOUR MESS. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR COMMENT IS
ANYBODY ELSE IN THE GALLERIES
LIKE TO MAKE PUBLIC COMMENT. HI
I'M MICHELLE DARBY AND I'M ALSO
WITH MOMS FOR LIBERTY CONNECT
TO CHILDREN. AND PEOPLE SAYING
THAT THEY CARE ABOUT THE HEALTH
OF OUR CHILDREN THEN THEY
WOULDN'T BE TAKING OUR
CHILDREN'S OXYGEN AWAY. WHEN
THERE'S NO SCIENCE THAT IT'S
PREVENTING ANY VIRUS AND LIKE
NICOLE SAID YOU GUYS ARE TRYING
TO CLEAN UP YOUR MESS. WE PAY
MANY HUNDREDS AND THOUSANDS OF
DOLLARS IN HEALTH INSURANCE.
OUR KIDS SHOULD BE AT SCHOOL
FOR EDUCATION NOT TO BE POLICED
AND NOT TO BE. SCARE TACTIC TO
NOTHING CAN THEY HAVE MENTAL
HEALTH ISSUES WE AS PARENTS
KNOW WHAT'S BEST FOR OUR
CHILDREN NOT THE SYSTEM. THESE
CALL THE COUNSELORS ARE EVEN
LICENSE STATION ONE LADY EVEN
SET HERSELF TWO THOUSAND AND
ELEVEN THOUSAND ON SCHOOL
CAMPUSES ALREADY. THEY SHOULD
NOT BE EVALUATED BY UNLICENSED
STRANGER THIS WILL IMPACT ALSO
TAXPAYER MONEY WHICH IS ALREADY
TOO HIGH WHEN THEY HAD TO LEARN
FROM WHEN YOU'RE VIRTUALLY WE
DON'T WANT THIS DRUG MONEY FOR
SUPPOSED MENTAL HEALTH
ASSISTANCE FROM THE GOVERNMENT.
PUT ON OUR CHILDREN KIDS ARE
IMPRESSIONABLE AND THEY DO NOT
UNDERSTAND LAWS AND WE'LL HAVE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
COMMENTS SHOULD NOT BE
INTERROGATED. THANK YOU THANK
YOU FOR YOUR PUBLIC COMMENT-
ANY IS THERE ANYONE ELSE IN THE
GALLERY. ALSO WISHING TO
COMMENT PUBLICLY. YES SIR. YES
MY NAME'S THOMAS KING AND- I'D
LIKE TO. SAY A QUICK WORD- THE
BIGGEST OBSTACLE TO MENTAL
HEALTH IS THE CONTINUED
RESTRICTIONS IMPOSED ON OUR
CHILDREN WHEN THE TRUE REMEDY
IS BRING BACK NORMAL ATTENDANCE
WITHOUT THE CONSTANT
BOMBARDMENT OF FEAR FOR
PANDEMIC FOR ABANDONMENT
THERE'S STATISTICALLY NO MORE.
A HEALTH ISSUE THAN A LONG LIST
OF DEATHS BY OTHER DISEASES
LISTEN ON CDC WEBSITE. HERE'S
TO REPAIR AND GRANDPARENTS
FIFTIES COMMITTEES ARE MORE
INTERESTED IN TAKING AWAY
PARENTS RIGHTS WITHOUT
REPRESENTATION. THE MENTAL
HEALTH IS NOT THE GOVERNMENT'S
JOB WE PARENTS WANT NORMAL
SCHOOLING WITHOUT AN ATMOSPHERE
OF FEAR AND OPPRESSION. WITH
THIS LOSS OF SCHOOL CONTROL AND
SAFE PROPER LOWER LEARNING
ENVIRONMENT STUDENT RE
ENGAGEMENT WILL HAPPEN WITH A
RETURN TO NORMALCY IN OUR
SCHOOLS WITHOUT THESE
RESTRICTIONS AND FEAR
MONGERING. BY LABELING TO
CHILDREN WITH MENTAL ISSUES.
CHILDREN ARE RESILIENT ROVER
OVERCOME OBSTACLES OF THIS
PANDEMIC WITHOUT THE INFUSION
OF BUREAUCRACY. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR PUBLIC COMMENT. WE DO
RESPECTIVELY DO APPRECIATE IT-
WE HAVE ONE MORE IN THE GALLERY
ABSOLUTION PLACE YOU SEE. HI MY
NAME IS HANNAH MCINTYRE AND I'M
A PARENT. HERE'S THAT ALL THESE
CONVERSATIONS AND SOLUTIONS ARE
REACTIONARY AND NOT PROACTIVE
THE CD PH SHOULD NOT BE MAKING
DECISIONS IN A VACUUM WITHOUT
THE INPUT OF CHILD PSYCHOLOGIST
TEACHERS AND PEDIATRICIANS
INSTEAD YOU'RE SPENDING MONEY
ON NEW PROGRAMS AND RESOURCES
TO HELP CLEAN UP THE MESS.
CREATED BY MASKING DOESN'T SEEM
CONTENT CONTACT QUARANTINING
CLOSING OF SPORTS AND BAND
WHERE THESE GOVERNMENT AGENCIES
NOT COLLABORATING ON THE FRONT
END OF PUBLIC HEALTH POLICY SO
LESS HARM IS DONE TO THE
CHILDREN AND THE EDUCATIONAL
ENVIRONMENT TO BEGIN WITH. I
JUST SEE SPENDING MORE MONEY TO
PUT OUT MENTAL HEALTH FIRES THE
CDPH HELP START. THANK YOU IN
FACT ARE FOR YOUR COMMENT DOES
ANYONE ELSE IN THE GALLERY
WHICH SHOULD MAKE PUBLIC
COMMENT. AS SAYING NO ONE LET
ME GO TO THE OVERFLOW ROOM- IN
ROOM ONE TWELVE THIS ANYBODY IN
ROOM ONE TWELVE WOULD LIKE TO.
MAKE A PUBLIC COMMENT YOU HAVE
ONE MINUTE. YES SIR. HELLO MY
NAME IS MARK RHODES I AM A
RESIDENT OF CALIFORNIA AND A
UNITED STATES CITIZEN. WE PAY
TAXES WE HAVE RIGHTS AND
EDUCATION IS ABOUT EDUCATION.
THE RIGHT TO MAKE EDUCATED
INFORMED STATE DECISIONS FOR
OUR FAMILY. AND TO BE TURNED
AWAY BY THE PUBLIC SCHOOL FIRST
DECISIONS THAT WE CHOOSE TO
MAKE. BASED ON OUR RIGHTS THE
RIGHTS THAT YOU TOOK AWAY BY SP
TWO SEVENTY SEVEN TO MAKE
RELIGIOUS EXEMPTIONS. WE ARE
NOW FORCED TO BE A BURDEN TO
THE SYSTEM YOU JUST DISCUSSED
TALKING ABOUT. PUTTING IN
MENTAL HEALTH PRACTITIONERS IS
NOT THE SOLUTION. ALLOWING US
TO COME INTO OUR SCHOOLS
UNIMPEDED WITH OUR
CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHTS INTACT AS
LAW ABIDING CITIZENS IS THE
FOUNDATION OF OUR COUNTRY. WE
DESERVE THAT RIGHT HE DESERVED
THAT RESPECT. IN MY TAX MONEY
FROM MY BUSINESS FROM MY
PERSONAL ACCOUNT. FROM EVERY
AVENUE WE ARE TAX GOES DIRECTLY
TO YOU AND YOU ARE MISMANAGING.
THAT MONEY YOUR HARMING OUR
CHILDREN. WE WANT FAIR ACCESS
TO. OUR SAME EDUCATION
SURROUNDED BY OUR PEERS
UNIMPEDED BY THE GOVERNMENT.
THAT IS OUR FUNDAMENTAL RIGHTS
AND WE WILL STAND HERE EVERY
PUBLIC COMMENT AND REMINDS YOU.
THAT THE SOLUTIONS YOU ARE
OFFERING ARE JUST REACTIONARY.
THANK YOU. POLICIES WE THANK
YOU FOR YOUR COMMENT WE RESPECT
YOUR COMMENTS DEPRECIATED. AND
NOW IS THERE. ELSE WE WANT
TWELVE. M. C. NO ONE. LOOKING
TO ROOM TWO ZERO FOUR ZERO. AS
YOU KNOW AND WE WILL NOW RETURN
TO THE PHONES MR MODERATOR IF
YOU WOULD WIN WE WILL EXTEND
THIS HEARING FOR FIVE MORE
MINUTES. WHICH GIVES US TIME
FOR FIVE MORE COMMENTS. THANK
U. S. CHAIR IS DEFINED REMINDER
PRESS FOLLOWED BY ZERO TO MAKE
PUBLIC COMMENT. AND WE HAVE ONE
ONE MOMENT MISTER CHAIR.
QUEUING UP WITH AN OPERATOR. TO
BE. WITH. MEDIA'S RESOLUTION AT
THE COLLECTIVE ACTION AT THE
LOCAL LEVEL THAT CAN BE A
POWERFUL COUNTERWEIGHT AGAINST
SOMEONE MANDEL COUNTIES APPROVE
THIS RESOLUTION WITH A
COMMITMENT ONE OF THE FOLLOWING
PRINCIPLES ARE GOOD ACCOMPLISH
WITH MEDICAL HELP. IN OUR
COUNTIES ARE BEST SERVED BY
UTILITIES RESPOND LOCALLY TO
ECHO THE NINETEEN VIRUS IN
ACCORDANCE WITH OUR LOCAL DATA
ON CIRCUMSTANCES THAT WILL
DISTRICT IN OUR JURISDICTION
URGED TO SAFELY OPEN ALL
SCHOOLS AS SOON AS POSSIBLE
PROVIDE IMPROVED IN PARTICULAR
PERSON INSTRUCTION. TO THE
GREATEST EXTENT POSSIBLE
WITHOUT FURTHER DELAY AND THE
LOCAL STATE OF EMERGENCY IN
YOUR COUNTY NO MAN KNOWS ACTING
THERE MUST BE CHOICE GIVE LOCAL
COUNTIES AND THEIR DISTRICT THE
POWER TO DECIDE WHAT IS BEST.
OR THEIR FAMILIES THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. THANK YOU YOUR CALL.
ABOUT THIS MATTER DO WE HAVE
ANY OF COMMENTERS ON. WELL WE
HAVE NO OTHER PARTICIPANTS
QUEUED UP AT THIS TIME. IF YOU
COULD ASK ONE MORE TIME TO SEE
IF THERE'S ANYBODY WHO HAS
JOINED ONE LAST TIME FOR PUBLIC
COMMENT. THANK YOU MR CHAIR AND
THE FINAL REMINDER PLEASE PRESS
ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO TO MAKE
PUBLIC COMMENT AT THIS TIME. WE
ARE GETTING ONE ONE MOMENT
PLEASE.
M. I. TWENTY ONE YOUR
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO
THANK YOU FOR EXTENDING THE
TIME FOR PUBLIC COMMENT FROM ON
THE PHONE MY NAME IS KAREN
WALKER AND I LIVE IN ORANGE
COUNTY AND I WOULD LIKE TO JUST
EXPRESSED MY- SINCERE
APPRECIATION FOR BRINGING IN
THE PROFESSIONALS FOR MENTAL
HEALTH TO OUR COMMUNITY I'D
ALSO LIKE TO ASK ABOUT THE
SPECIAL COMMITTEE- DO WHATEVER
CAN BE DONE. TO- PUSH BACK ON
THE MISINFORMATION THAT OUR
CHILDREN ARE HEARING FROM OUR
ELECTED SCHOOL BOARD TRUSTEES
DOWN FROM THE PUBLIC WHICH IS
INCREASING THE PRESSURE ON
THEM- I'M REALLY SUPPORTIVE OF
DIFFERENT CANDIDATES- AND I
FEEL LIKE. THIS IS GOING TO
BRING MUCH NEEDED SUPPORT AND
AS WE MENTIONED EARLIER ON BY
ONE OF THE- PANELISTS- TRUSTED
INDIVIDUALS DIRECTLY TO OUR
STUDENTS. THANK YOU THE
COMMITTEE FOR ALL THE WORK THAT
YOU'VE DONE ON THE- NINE AND
THANK YOU MS LAWSON FOR YOUR
CALL- MYSTERY ONE LAST TIME FOR
COMMENTS ON THE PHONE AND THEN
WE WILL MOVE TO CLOSE ACCOUNTS.
AGAIN PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED
BY ZERO IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO
MAKE PUBLIC COMMENT AT THIS
TIME. WE HAVE NOBODY QUEUEING
UP. AT THANK YOU MISS MODERATE
MISS MARIE THANKS FOR YOUR
PATIENCE AND FOR YOUR WORK
TODAY- LET ME TURN. THE GAVEL
OVER TO CENTER LABOR FOR YOUR
CLOSING COMMENTS CENTER. THANK
YOU MR CHAIR AND THANK YOU FOR
PARTNERING WITH THE US SENATE
EDUCATION COMMITTEE I REALLY
WANT TO SAY THANK YOU AND
EXPRESS MY EXTREME GRATITUDE
FOR ALL OF OUR PANELISTS. WHO
RECENTLY BROUGHT FORWARD SOME
GREAT INFORMATION AND INSIGHTS
AND I JUST WANTED TO ALSO
ADDRESS THAT YOU KNOW MENTAL
HEALTH AS SEVERAL OF OUR
PANELISTS SAID. WAS HERE BEFORE
COVE IT AND IT IS JUST BEEN
EXACERBATED BY THE LAST YEAR
AND A HALF. I'VE SAID BEFORE
AND I WILL SAY AGAIN THIS IS MY
FIRST PANDEMIC MAYBE OTHER
PEOPLE HAVE ALREADY GONE
THROUGH A PANDEMIC. BUT FOR
THOSE OF US WHO HAVE NOT PEOPLE
ARE TRYING TO MAKE THE BEST
DECISIONS POSSIBLE IN EVERY
ASPECT OF THEIR LIFE ESPECIALLY
WITH OUR SCHOOL CHILDREN. I
THINK THAT OUR SUPERINTENDENT
OF PUBLIC INSTRUCTION AND ALL
THOSE AND ALL OF OUR SCHOOLS
HAVE DONE A TREMENDOUS JOB
REACHING OUT TO OUR CHILDREN
AND TRYING TO MAKE SURE THAT A
BAD SITUATION. IS MADE AS BEST
AS POSSIBLE SO THANK YOU TO
EVERYONE FOR WHAT YOU DO WE
WILL CONTINUE TO WORK ON THESE
ISSUES HERE AT THE STATE LEVEL.
AND MISTER CHAIRMAN THANK YOU
FOR HAVING ME TODAY. AND THANK
YOU FOR YOUR PARTICIPATION
THANK FOR THE POSITION ALL OF
OUR COLLEAGUES. I'D ALSO LIKE
TO THANK ALL OF THE PANELISTS
THAT FROM WHOM WE'VE HEARD
TODAY- YOUR PERSPECTIVE
INSIGHTS ARE TRULY INVALUABLE-
AND WILL INFORM OUR WORK MOVING
FORWARD WE HAVE ALL IN SOME
FORM OR ANOTHER AS WE'VE HEARD
TODAY. EXPERIENCE GRIEF LOSS
AND ANXIETY FROM LIVING THROUGH
THIS THIS PANDEMIC- PROBABLY
NONE MORE SO THAN OUR CHILDREN-
AND STUDENTS. TO EVERY MEMBER
OF OUR SCHOOL COMMUNITY WILL
PLAY A VITAL ROLE IN THE
WELLNESS FOR STUDENTS THIS YEAR
AND BEYOND. AS WE MAKE OUR WAY
PAST THE PANDEMIC- THIS
PANDEMIC WILL BE TO A
GENERATION- WHAT THE DEPRESSION
AND THE SECOND WORLD. WAR WHERE
TO OUR GRANDPARENTS IN A
RELATION WE SHOULD KEEP IN MIND-
THAT IT WILL NOT BE. WILL NOT
BE EASY IT WILL TAKE SOME TIME.
TO MOVE PAST ALL OF THE EFFECTS
OF THIS EXPERIENCE. I WANT TO
THANK EVERYONE WHO CALLED IN TO
PARTICIPATE IN PUBLIC TESTIMONY
TODAY I CAN'T APOLOGIZE FOR THE
TIME CONSTRAINTS- WE LOOK
FORWARD TO INCLUDING WRITTEN
COMMENTS AND SUGGESTIONS IN THE
OFFICIAL HEARING RECORD. FOR
THIS HEARING. AGAIN THE EMAIL
ADDRESS BEFORE SUBMITTING
WRITTEN COMMENTS S. C. P. E. R.
S. E. N. DOT C. EIGHT DOT GOV.
AND LASTLY SPECIAL THANKS TO
LYNN LORBER CHIEF CONSULTANT TO
THE SENATE EDUCATION COMMITTEE-
TO SENATOR LEAHY VOTE FOR YOUR
WILLINGNESS TO WORK WITH US ON
PLANNING FOR TODAY'S HEARING-
AND LENDING OUT YOUR COLLECTIVE
EXPERTISE. BACK INTO MY OWN
COMMITTEE CONSULT CASSIE ROYCE.
WHO DOES WONDERFUL WORK AND
WITHOUT WHOM WE WOULD BE LOST-
SO I KNOW I SPEAK FOR CASH TO
ENSURE WE APPRECIATE THIS
OPPORTUNITY COLLABORATE. WITH
YOU AND YOUR STAFF AND THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS AGAIN OUR
DEEPEST THANKS TO ALL OF OUR
PANELISTS TO MAKE YOURSELVES
AVAILABLE TODAY TO SHARE YOUR
INSIGHTS. TO MY COLLEAGUES- AND
WE LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUE
THIS DISCUSSION ACROSS A RANGE.
OF FORMS MOVING FORWARD- WE'VE
NOW COMPLETED TODAY'S AGENDA
AND. WITH THAT THIS HEARING IS
ADJOURNED THANK YOU.